GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO THE HEARING ARE
WE GOOD. YEAH OKAY. GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO HEARING
OF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTINCT SAYING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUE SAYS
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL E DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-692-8953 AGAIN THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN ZERO FIVE. SIX NINE
ZERO NINE AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THE MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
NORTH COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT AND SO ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
TO MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND SO WE WANT
YOU TO MAKE SURE YOUR MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING US SO WE
CAN HEAR HEAR FROM YOU AND
OBVIOUSLY WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. ALL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT- WHO'S GOING TO TESTIFY
TODAY THAT THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
THAT YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM YOUR PRIOR
POLICY COMMITTEE TEST ABOUT
MONEY OR RE LITIGATING THE
MERITS OF THE BILL WE WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACTS.
BY EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND OUR TECHNOLOGY. PLEASE
REVERT BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD WE HAVE A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA THREE OF WHICH
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASSED
MOTION. THE REST OF THE BILLS
ARE SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
OBVIOUSLY FOR FOLKS OUT THERE
IN- SOCIAL MEDIA LAND- WHO HAVE
BEEN REQUESTING THAT BILLS BE
TAKEN UP TODAY FOR ACTION- I
HOPE THAT THE FOLKS THE AUTHORS
OF THE BILLS LET THEIR- FRIENDS
KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM ENDS. FILE
IS A PER. ACTION THAT WE TAKE
TODAY. AND THOSE BILLS ARE NOT
DEAD THEY'RE JUST GOING TO
SUSPENSE AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS WATCHING.
MAY NOT KNOW THE PROCESS. FOR
ANYONE LISTENING IN WHO IS
INTERESTED- IN AB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BY IGOR CURRY. THAT BILL
HAS BEEN SENT DIRECTLY TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PURSUANT TO SENATE
RULE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT. ALSO
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE STILL
LISTED IN THE DAILY FILE. BUT
THEY'VE BEEN RESCHEDULED FOR
OUR HEARING NEXT MONDAY. AB
THREE FONG A. B. NINETY SEVEN
THIS AREA AND AB FIVE FIVE NINE
ARAMBULA. AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
STONE AB EIGHT THIRTEEN MULLIN
AB EIGHT SIXTEEN TWO. AND A. B.
TEN SEVENTY TWO RACE. BEFORE WE
HEAR OUR PRESENTATIONS ARE
GOING TO ESTABLISH ACCORDING TO
MR QUORUM SO MISTER CHIEF
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR PORTANTINO I'M
HERE YOU KNOW HERE CENTER BATES
CENTER BRADFORD. AND A BRADFORD
HERE CENTER JONES JONES HERE
CENTER COURT CAN ORDER. AND
KAMLAGER HERE LAIRG HERE LATER
HERE M. TASK HERE ASKING. A
COURT. AB FORMS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE OF THE DAY. DUE
TO CAN REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARING- AND TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATION AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS OF INSTITUTING A TIME
LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES OF TIME FOR
THE PRIMARY TESTIMONY. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIMONY
MUSCLE TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION AND THE
MEASURE WE COMMONLY CALL THAT
THE ME TOO. TESTIMONIES IF
NECESSARY WE WILL ALSO LIMIT
THIS ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY TO
TWELVE MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE.
AS A REMINDER ALL WITNESSES
SHOULD LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY
AGAIN TO THE FISCAL IMPACTS OF
THE BILL AND REFRAIN FROM PRIOR
TESTIMONY I WILL STRICTLY
ENFORCE. THE ME TOO PORTION OF
THE BILL I HEARINGS AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO RIGHT TO SB SIX
THREE ONE WHICH IS A STATE
CLAIMS CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. BILL THAT'S
TRADITION FOR THE CHAIRS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TOO-
TAKE AND- I'M GONNA GIVE A
BRIEF MR Y. CASKEY IF YOU COULD
BE THE CHAIR FOR THE MOMENT
WHILE I PRESENT. CENTER
PORTANTINO WHEN YOU'RE READY 2%
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU- AB SB
SIX THIRTY ONE WOULD
APPROPRIATE APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD FOR THE
PAYMENT OF ONE STATE CLAIM.
RELATED TO THE ARANEUS.
CONVICTION OF WILLIAM RICHARDS
IN THIS CASE. THE COURT SET
ASIDE HIS CONVICTION IN MADE A
FINDING OF FACTUAL INNOCENCE
WHERE HE HAS SERVED OVER TWENTY
TWO YEARS IN PRISON. THE BOARD
RECENTLY APPROVED THE CLAIM AND
RECOMMENDED APPROPRIATION TO
COVER THE REQUIRED PAYMENT. I
HAVE NEIL ANNIS FROM THE
VICTIM'S COMPENSATION BOARD
HERE ON THE COAST LINE AS A
SUPPORT WITNESS AND HE'S
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I'LL ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE FOR MR WHITE HOUSE
KEEP. BOAT FACTORY OPENS UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT MR ENNIS IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINES PLEASE
PROCEED. DO WE HAVE MISTER
ENNIS ON THE LINE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S LET'S MOVE TO A PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN%
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE SIX. SIX
THREE ONE. SEEING NO ONE LET'S
LOOK TO ROOM- TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE TESTIFYING
C. NUMBER ONE THEY'RE
MODERATELY LET'S SALUTE MOVED
TO THE- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA%
TELECONFERENCE A SERVICE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX THREE ONE.
CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND-
SCHEDULE THEM OR SET THEM
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO I%
TESTIFYING IN WHICH ARE YOU
TAKING SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
SIR. YOUR SUPPORT THE SUPPORT
TO SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH IF YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR A SB SIX THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME NOW IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS GOING TO
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
IN THE PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE SO AGAIN PLEASE PRESS.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. THANK
YOU. I ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A
PARTISAN QUEUING UP. AND WE
WILL GO TO OUR LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M OPPOSED
THIS WAIT A SECOND WE'LL GET
YOU IN A MOMENT THESE ARE FOR
OUR MEMBERS AND THE OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B- SIX THREE ONE. BEGIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB SIX THREE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. M. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING UP ALL
RIGHT IF MR ENNIS COMES FROM
THE- VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD- WILL HAVE TO GIVE THEM
HE'S ON THE LINE BUT I THINK
YOU SHOULD JUST FOR QUESTIONS
OKAY. EXCELLENT LET'S GO THE
OPPOSITION OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WILL WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
THREE ONE. SEEING NONE LETS GO
TO ROOM TO AT TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NOBODY THERE- WISHING TO
TESTIFY SO. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SIX ONE AND CALL THEM
FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO A SPEAKER
I SIX THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT YOU DON'T
SEEM TO HAVE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WHY IS THIS BILL NOT
GETTING EQUAL REPRESENTATION.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT EITHER SO
IT'S YOU SHOULD WELL YEAH
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET YOUR
PHONE SYSTEM TO WORK WHICH IS
PART OF WHY CALIFORNIANS CAN'T
SEEM TO CALL IN WHEN THEY
NEEDED TO. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
MAYBE YOU SHOULD STREAMLINE
YOUR PROCESSES I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL AND I'M OPPOSED TO
EVERY BILL UNTIL YOU START
DEALING WITH A REAL PROBLEM
WHICH IS THE TYRANT LUNATIC
GOVERNOR. STATE FREE. THANK YOU
OKAY IS THERE A ELSE WHO. WANT
ME TO TELL MORE IN OP. YEAH AND
AGAIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
SIX THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE QUESTION AND- MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE IS KEEPING UP AT
THIS TIME LET'S CHECK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
ZOOM LINE MISS. A NOTE THERE-
ARE YOU THERE. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR- AND MEMBERS JELLY
EDITOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS MEASURE. OKAY VERY GOOD-LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISCON WATER. YES
THANK YOU- I HAD A QUESTION FOR
THE GENTLEMAN WHO'S ON THE LINE
I WAS JUST CURIOUS ABOUT HOW
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS. WAS DETERMINED- I'M IN
DOLLARS IS THE PAYMENTS. PER
DAY OF INCARCERATIONS FOR. MR
ENNIS IF YOU CAN ADDRESS STEVE
PER DAY COMPENSATION. FOR YES
SIR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES I CAN.
YES THAT ISN'T STATUTE OF THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS- THAT
WAS PASSED- A FEW YEARS AGO BY
THE LEGISLATURE AN INCREASE
FROM ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS TODAY
THE DATE. HUNDRED FORTY.
CENTCOM WORKER. OTHER QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT CENTER PORTANTINO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. SORRY
CENTER JONES THAT'S OKAY JUST A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS CANNOT
REALLY IT JUST IN GENERAL NOT
SPECIFIC TO THIS CASE- HOW IS
THE- HOUSES APPROPRIATE IS IT
LIKE ONE SINGLE CHECK. TO THE-
TO THE INDIVIDUAL OR IS IT PAID
OVERTIME AND THEN ALSO IS THE
INCOME OR THE THIS IS NOT
INCOME- IS THIS TAXED ALSO. MR
ENNIS. GATE YES IT IS ONE ONE
FROM CHECK AND- IT IS NOT TAX
BY STATUTE THAT'S GOOD. DOES
THE STATE OFFER ANY. SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO THE PERSON THAT
FACT SOMEBODY WROTE ME A CHECK
FROM NINE AND A HALF DOLLARS I
WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO MANAGE IT.
SO IS THERE SOME SUPPORTED
MATTER THEY JUST LEFT ON THEIR
OWN ON HOW TO. MANAGE THE MONEY.
THAT IS THE ONLY COMPENSATION
THAT THE- THE ONLY OTHER
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE-
AVAILABLE TO THEM ARE NOT
OTHERS SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO A DISCHARGED. HOME
FROM DESTRUCTION. I GUESS WHAT
I'M ASKING DOES THE STATE. THE
STATE RECOMMEND MONEY MANAGERS
OR INVESTMENT. FOR ADVICE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. NO THAT IS
NOT PART OF THE PROGRAM OKAY
AND THEN MY FINAL QUESTION IS-
I'M NOTICING THAT THE STATE IS
PICKING UP THE ENTIRE COST OF
THIS BUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD BE ON THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
PROSECUTED THE CASE IN THE
FIRST PLACE ARONIE ISLEY I
WOULD THINK THAT YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY. AT SOME POINT TIME
WOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN A HEADS
UP THAT. THIS IS A POTENTIAL
ARONIE THIS CASE WIRED WIRE THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE ON ANY OF THESE
ISSUES. THERE ARE OFTEN CIVIL
SUIT AGAINST. THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT MAY BE
MISSING IN ADDITION TO THIS
PAYMENT- BUT THERE IS THERE'S A
BLENDER STANDOUT- I'M NOT AN
ADDICT YOU KNOW COMPENSATION
MECHANISM. SIMILAR TO THAT
SUPPORT OR- OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY GOOD- I THINK THERE'S
A MOTION BY SENATOR COM LONGER-
IN SUPPORT OF A SB THREE SIX
SIX THREE ONE CENTER PORTANTINO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TIME THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
MISTER CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATE BILL SIX THREE
ONE MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE JONES
I'VE JONES BY KAMLAGER. CAMERA
A LAYERED HI LARRY HI MY COUNTY
HI LCI WE'LL KEEP THE MATTER
OPEN FOR THOSE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND I'LL RETURN TO GAVEL TO
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU-
CENTER WHITE HOUSE HE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON AB NINE. SIDE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD ON FIRE
SAFETY AND PREVENTION- THE NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE IS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM. FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOMS. TWENTY
MODERATOR PLEASE GIVE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINE
PARDON ME ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME. NOW WE CAN. AB NINE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL AB NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WELL THE
FIRST ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE IS OPEN. SPOHR
CHAIR NUMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BRITNEY BENNETT THE ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL AND
THE PIER CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE. SIXTY THREE SIX THREE.
POSTED THAT SPELL TWENTY THREE
CUMAE. CERTAINLY FINE. FIFTY
FOUR FIVE FOUR. THIS IS CHRIS
ROSA ON BEHALF OF HEALTH FOREST
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANKS MISTER
JOURNAL FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT ALL RIGHT ANOTHER
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE. IF YOU WISH CHAU LIKE TO
SHOWS OPPOSITION TO AB NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SIXTY THREE IS THAT ME. ALL
RIGHT YOU ALREADY HAD ONE
OPPORTUNITY PLEASE STATE YOUR
POSITION. WELL I AM I IN THE
OPPOSED TO LINE I NEED TO MAKE
SURE I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE IS
THIS THE GENERAL FIRE SAFETY
PREVENTION BILL BECAUSE IF IT
IS I'M VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO IT
AND I WOULD APPRECIATE THE
COURTESY OF MODERATOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE WITNESS
IN OPPOSITE R. REITER.
MODERATOR WILL ONE MODERATOR I
NEED YOU I NEED A MODERATOR I
NEED YOU TO BE MORE ATTENTIVE-
SO ALLOW SAY ENOUGH ENOUGH SO
PLEASE KEEP UP WITH US THANK
YOU I'M SORRY. I COULD NOT HEAR
OVER I'M SO SORRY- WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY ONE NOW. THANK
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY ONE.
MISTER TERRY JOHNSON ALONG HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE U. S. GREEN
BUILDING COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN DIEGO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AB
NINE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE
ON OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT BUT
THE WILL QUEUE UP THE FOLKS
ONLINE LET'S GO. AND ONCE AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AMATEUR NOBODY ELSE IS
COMING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT I HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. FOUR A. B.
NINE- WILL CHECK IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
SAME LINE YOU HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
CITES THE NEED FOR FIVE
POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS UP AS OUTLINED
IN THE BILL. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL CREATES SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. WHEN AT THE CAL FIRE
NOT PROVIDE A FISCAL ESTIMATE
AT THE TIME OF OUR ANALYSIS-
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE BILL. IS
LIKELY TO HAVE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS RELATED TO THE
TRANSFER OF MULTIPLE CAL FIRE
PROGRAMS TO THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES ANNUAL COST OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FND ANNUALLY
OR MORE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE WE'VE
HEARD FROM EVERYONE ELSE THIS.
COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. FORTY
ONE. ALSO BY DOCTOR WOULD ON
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
SUSPEND CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL GO TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND THEN IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. IN SUPPORT O AB
FORTY ONE. I SEE NO ONE I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY ONE. TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. NOW WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH THE ONLINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN SHARON
MEMBERS BERNIE BENNETT THE WITH
SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXUS NINE
EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. NINE
EIGHTY THREE I HAD TO CALL BACK
YOU SEEM TO BE CUTTING ME OFF
AND CENSORING MODERATOR MOVE ON.
THANK YOU- LINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU UP
RIGHT THANKS ON BEHALF OF
APPROACH AND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO LINE THIRTY
EIGHT AND AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. RIVARD'S
WORLD CAUCUS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WILL NOW GOOD
OPPOSITION DAVEY FORTY ONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM BOOK. COME ON UP. I DIDN'T
SEE OVER THERE. GOOD MORNING
HONORABLE CHAIR PORTANTINO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHANNA FINNEY AND WITH THE
NEVADA COUNTY TELECOM PUBLIC
WORKING GROUP. THANK YOU FOR A
TIME TO SPEAK TODAY MANY OF
THIS YEAR'S STATE BROADBAND
BILLS INCLUDING AB FOURTEEN
UNNECESSARILY SUBSIDIZE THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY EXPANSION. WE
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER SUPPORT
THE INTENTIONS OF THIS BILL
LISTED WORKS IN ONE YOU WERE
NOT ON THE LIST OF ONE OF OUR-
KEY. HOLD ON. WHEN YOU'RE HERE
ON FOURTEEN OR FORTY ONE. I'M
SO SORRY DYSLEXIC AT THE MOMENT
THERE YOU GO. RIGHT ANYONE ON
FORTY ONE. SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM ON FORTY ONE WILL MOVE
TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
WE ARE GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINE AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
OPPOSITION AND PLEASE. STAY
ALERT. YES SIR- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR- AB FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON
AB FORTY ONE. WE'LL CHECK IN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AT
ESTIMATES ONGOING FISCAL IMPACT
OF FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES. COMMISSION UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT TO UPDATE
ITS MAPPING AND IDENTIFY
PRIORITY AREAS FOR CALTRANS
CALTRANS ESTIMATES A ONE TIME
FISCAL IMPACT OF SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.
DEVELOPED THE MICRO TRENCHING
GUIDELINES. THANK YOU IT'S
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. ON SPORTS FISHING
LICENSES. FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD AS WELL THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE DR WHAT IS
WAY PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE IN WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SEEING KNOWN. ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR AB EIGHT SEVENTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FISHING BILL BUT
I'M ALSO CLOSE TO THE FIRE BILL
AND I KEEP GETTING CUT. THANK
YOU. TO AND AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI ONE EIGHT ONE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. I WILL NOT RE OPEN
THAT LINE. THERE'S NOBODY ELSE
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OUR POSITION EIGHT SEVENTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
STATE SEVENTEEN. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
JOHNSON'S ON A PERMANENT
SOMEBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION-
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE ESTIMATES COST BETWEEN
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND DEPLOYMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. WOULD
KNOW THAT THE BILL DOES HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO AFFECT
SPORTFISHING LICENSE REVENUE-
IMPLEMENTING ELECTRONICALLY
DISPLAYED LICENSE IN. A NEW
GENERATED FROM THE SALES AS
MUCH AS FOUR HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
FURTHERMORE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAY
LICENSE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
AFFECT REVENUES. RANGING FROM A
THIRTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION TO AN INCREASE
OF UP TO SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY BASED ON EXPERIENCES
IN OTHER STATES. THANK YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS SEEING NONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT SEVENTEEN.
VOTE TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
A. B. THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY DOCTOR
WOULD ON RECYCLING- BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OPPOSITE WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. THERE'S NO
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN.
DO I TO TRANSPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE BUT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY DO
YOU CUT ME OFF I'M OPPOSED TO
THREE OF JIM WAS BUILT BY USED
TO LIVE IN HIS DISTRICT WAS
CUTTING. CYCLING FIRES. WHICH
IS SIXTY HOURS AND HOURS. NEXT
PERSON IN SUPPORT. IT TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI WILL- WITH
THIRTEEN ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS GOING ON I APOLOGIZE
MISTER CHAIR SHE KEEPS CALLING
IN ON A DIFFERENT NUMBER ALL
RIGHTS IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT. AND
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE HER
RESPECTFULLY ASK OFFER HER
COMMENTS IN THE RIGHT SEQUENCE
IF SHE WOULD COOPERATE AND SO
LET THE RECORD SHOW. THAT WE
ARE. SUSPENDING HER EACH TIME
WHEN SHE'S NOT FOLLOWING THE
PROCESS. SO WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. WHO IS WISHING TO ACTION
ME WERE AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THIS COMPANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION. TO AB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN. TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO OPEN THAT LINE. SURE
WILL GIVE HER ONE MORE CHOI
OKAY. OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE CONFINE YOUR
NICK COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME IN
YOUR POSITION. AB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN AM I IN THE RIGHT PLACE
BECAUSE THE PHONE SYSTEM IS
CONFUSING FOR AVERAGE PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY FIRE VICTIMS LIKE
ME WHO USED TO LIVE IN JIM
WOODS DISTRICT I AM OPPOSED TO
THIS LEGISLATION ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. IF GETTING THAT AS A
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR A. B.
THIRTEEN ELEVEN. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. TO ME IT'S
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
TO IMPLEMENT THE ALTERNATIVE
SCHEDULE PROCESS FOR RECYCLING
CENTERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SAYING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN ELEVEN.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO'S BILLS
WE HAVE AB THIRTEEN WHICH IS A
PUBLIC CONTRACTS AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL MOVE
RIGHT PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SING
NOBODY RUSHED TO THE MICROPHONE
IN THIS ROOM SEEING NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR WILL GO
RIGHT TO THE PHONE LINE. ON AB
THIRTEEN FOR SUPPORT. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE SOMEBODY WITH AN OPERATOR.
EVERYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND LOCALIZER BEFORE YOU
ARE OPEN. CHEN MEMBERS CALLING
AGAIN SAID THAT CARBON TIED
THERE ON BEHIND THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND A
FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. MR CHANNEL ONE ELSE'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTEEN THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HAD FROM MY
AFFILIATION IS A GOAT FARMING
MOTHER OF FOUR DISPLACED PERSON
FROM THE TUBBS FIRE AND I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB THIRTEEN WE
HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP MR
SURE ONE MOMENT. WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
BY THIS IS LIBERTY I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOUNG AND
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIXTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. PINE SIXTY FIVE ARE
YOU MUTED. AND THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. THERE'S NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION MOVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THEY COULD
RESULT IN UNPLANNEDONGOING
EXPENDITURES TO THE STATE AND
PROPOSES OVERLY BROAD
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES AND STATEWIDE
PROCUREMENT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AND DISSIPATES ONE
TIME COST OF ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
OVER TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY THREE. TO
SUPPORT POSSIBLY FIVE
POSITIONS. BEYOND THE INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD THE
DEPARTMENT INDICATES RETURNED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
ONGOING COSTS. IN ADDITION THIS
BILL IS LIKELY TO RESULT IN
UNKNOWN AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR ALL STATE
ENTITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
WORKLOAD REPORT ON OUR
AUTOMATED DECISION SYSTEMS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
THE BILL IS ALSO LIKELY TO
RESULT IN INCREASED IT COSTS AS
ANY POTENTIAL COST OF ANDERS SO
SEATED WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
IMPACT ASSESSMENT REPORTS WILL
BE INCLUDED IN FUTURE BIDS FOR.
IT'S OUR LICENSING OF AUTOMATED
DECISION SYSTEMS BY STATE
ENTITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON AB SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SEVEN MEMBER CHAO ON FOREST
RESOURCES- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND SUPPORT. IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX NINE
SEVEN. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIX NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIX NINETY SEVEN. AND WE HAVE
NO PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX NINE SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM ROOM IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. SIX NINE SEVEN.
BEGIN TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB
SIX NINE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE EIGHTY NINE. SB. SIX
NINE SEVEN. CORRECT THEIR
POSITION EXCELLENT YOUR
POSITION MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM I HAVE AN AFFILIATION OF
A DISPLACING BOTH FARMER FROM
THE TUBBS FIRE AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS LEGISLATION BE WELL
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
I OPPOSE THIS BILL. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO OTHER PURCHASE
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION ON A. B. SIX NINE
SEVEN. IS THERE A FILE. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
ANTICIPATE THE COST TO
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
STILL. NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
ESTIMATES NO FISCAL IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STILL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS OF
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE PACKAGE WHICH MAKES
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA.
INCLUDING ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS INCLUDING FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX MILLION MADE
AVAILABLE FOR EXPENDITURE IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HAVING HEARD
FROM FINANCE AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SIX. NINE SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHALLENGE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
LIMITATIONS OF ACTIONS THIS IS
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WITH
THE PRESENTATION HAS BEEN
WAIVED. THE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
NOBODY AROUND TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN. EXPRESSO.
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT AB TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. AND ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
ONE PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING HIT ONE
FOUL BY ZERO FOR A. B. ONE TWO
FOUR SEVEN. BUT. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN WELL I WILL
I WILL. VERY GOOD. WITNESSES
PLEASE USE YOUR MUTE BUTTON
WOULD NOT SPEAKING ONE FIFTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. AND THEY
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT ACUMEN
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT SO LET'S
GO IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED A. B.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN. THIS
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
WILL ALIGN NINETY YEAH NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMO
DON'T GET MY SUPPORT I AM
AGAINST THIS BILL. AND THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MANDARIN HAD
STRUM I AM STILL A DISPLACED
PERSON FROM THE THOMAS FIRE
VOTE FARMING MOTHER OF FOUR AND
I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION AB
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BY LENGTHENING
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
EXISTING CRIMES THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
PROSECUTIONS AND SENTENCES
ARTISTIC PRISONER COUNTY JAIL.
WITH NO THAT IS UNLIKELY THIS
BILL RESULT IN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN STATE PRISONS
MISSIONS BUT WARMER MORE LIKELY
RESULT IN LONGER PRISON STAYS
FOR THOSE WITH A SUBORDINATE
COMPUTER HACKING OFFENSE. WITH
ADDITION OF THIS MEASURE COULD
IMPOSE NEW COSTS AND WORKLOADS
ON COUNTIES WHICH- SURE ON A
LOCAL CHANNEL JUSTICE. ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN POSTED
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO ON PRIVACY
AND DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK
SYSTEMS THE PENSE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ON FORTY TWO OH
THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
LINE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
NUMBER TITLE AT THE END SAYS
THE CORBIN AND HIDE THEIR ON
THE HALF PRIVACY RIGHTS
CLEARINGHOUSE AND ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOUNG. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
UNIVERSAL SUPPORT FOR A BI.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. MISTER
CHAIRMAN NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT HAVE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX.
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FELL BY ZERO ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
A COUPLE QUEUEING UP. I WILL
BEGIN WITH LINE NINETY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. YES LINE NINETY FOUR
SACRAMENTO RESIDENTS OPPOSING
THE SCALE. THANK YOU NEXUS NINE
NINETY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JUST HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. MISTER WILL KNOW THE
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION GO TO PARMA FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE ANY COSTS
RELATED TO THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY DO NOT
ANTICIPATE FISCAL IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX CLOSE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON AB FOURTEEN-
WHICH WE KNOW WE HAVE SOME
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THIS IS
AGUILAR CURRY ON COMMUNICATIONS
BROADBAND SERVICES. THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SO RIGHT TO
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE- SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN. YES MISTER KERRY EVAN
Q. UP AND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING HIT ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN. AND
WE WILL BEGIN WITH WINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AS CHAIR
RIGHT STANCE ON BEHALF OF
TRIPLE P. AND OCEAN IN SUPPORT.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
THIRTY EIGHT ARE YOU MUTED. ONE
MORE TRY ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GETTING NO RESPONSE WILL
MOVE ON THE LINE THIRTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
SURE JOHNSON CLAIMED HALF OF
THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO SCRIPT
SELF IN SUPPORT. I NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DOMINIQUE
THE NAY REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
HAWAII STATE AND THE POLICE PP
AND COMPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AS A FINAL REMINDER ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN AND
LINE ONE OH NINE YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TEN
NOTHING HEALTH NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
ONE HUNDRED CAN YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAVID IBM WITH A RP CALIFORNIA
IT AND THE COURT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE FORT
ONE HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD ONE FOURTEEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
ETHYLENE SHAW ON THE HAVE- THE-
SORRY. ON BEHALF OF THIS VIDEO
SANTA MONICA THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTIES AND YOU BUT LARRY YOU
NAPA AND THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
ACCUSED NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING VERONICA THE A
LEVELS CREWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT ACTION FUND IN
SUPPORT. I AMATEUR WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION I HAD TO- PRIMARY
WITNESSES IDENTIFIED- MARK
GRAHAM AND JOANNA FINNEY. AND
BY ZERO TWO BERNIE. YES IN
OPPOSITION BUT THEY WERE
IDENTIFIED SO THEY GET THE
THREE MINUTES AFTER YOU HAVE.
SURE IT'S A SUPPORT OF AMANDA
JUST TEETERING ON OPPOSITION
BUT SOME SERIOUS FISCAL
CONCERNS BUT SUPPORTIVE MENTOR
SO IDENTIFIER YOUR ORGANIZATION
MY APOLOGIES BERNIE RUSCA WITH
A CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED AGAIN
SOME SERIOUS FISCAL IMPACTS IN
THAT BILL BUT WE ARE STILL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE
OPPOSITION. HELLO AGAIN
HONORABLE CHAIR PORTANTINO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JOHANNA
FINNEY OF THE NEVADA COUNTY
TELECOM PUBLIC WORKING GROUP.
THANK YOU FOR TIME TO SPEAK
TODAY MANY OF THIS YEAR'S STATE
BROADBAND BILLS INCLUDING AB
FOURTEEN UNNECESSARILY
SUBSIDIZE SUBSIDIZED THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY EXPANSION. WE
ALONG WITH MANY OTHERS SUPPORT
THE INTENTIONS OF THIS BILL
LISTED IN SECTION ONE THE BILL
INTENDS TO CREATE A FIBER OPTIC
NETWORK FOR MIDDLE MILE
BROADBAND SERVICE DEPLOYMENT.
AMBAC CALL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WITH
RELIABLE INTERNET CONNECTIVITY.
THE PROBLEMS ARE IN THE DETAILS
THE ALLEGED TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY BETWEEN WIRED AND
WIRELESS SERVICE. THERE IS NO
REAL EQUIVALENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO WIRELESS OF ANY G. IS CHEAP
THIRD RATE BROADBAND SERVICE
FAR INFERIOR TO FIBER OPTIC OR
CABLE SERVICE DIRECTLY TO
HOMES. WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
IS NOT RELIABLY FAST ENOUGH AS
AN AND NOT SYMMETRIC THE
DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY AND
THERE JUNE TWENTY ONE OF
FUNDING RECOMMENDS REQUIREMENTS
FOR BROADBAND CORONAVIRUS
RECOVERY FUNDS. STATES THAT
WHAT IS NEEDED FOR FEDERAL
BROADBAND FUNDING IS ONE
HUNDRED MEGABITS DOWN ON WHAT
WE RECEIVED AND ONE HUNDRED
UPLOAD WHAT WE STAND THIS IDEA
WAS ALSO SUPPORTED ON JULY
EIGHTH. BY THE GENERAL
ACCOUNTING OFFICE WIRELESS
BROADBAND FROM WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN'T MEET THE
STANDARD PERIOD ACCORDING TO
CLASS SPEECH CHECK IN PC
MAGAZINE. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIVE G. IS NO FASTER THAN FOUR
G. AND IT'S A SYMMETRIC UPLOAD
SPEEDS ARE A SMALL FRACTION OF
ITS DOWNLOAD SPEEDS WIRELESS
USE USES MICROWAVE RADIATION
THROUGH THE AIR. A PROVEN
CARCINOGEN NEUROTOXIN AND
IMMUNO SUPPRESSOR TO SEND AND
RECEIVE DATA BY CONTRAST FIBER
OPTICS USES VISIBLE LIGHT
THROUGH A CABLE TO SEND AND
RECEIVE DATA. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WIRELESS AND FIBER
OPTIC FREQUENCIES ARE SIX
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE OR ONE
MILLION TIMES THIS MEANS FIBER
OPTICS CAN CARRY OVER A MILLION
TIMES MORE DATA. THE WIRELESS
CAN. LET'S ELIMINATE THE
LOOPHOLES THAT FAVOR LAST MILE
WIRELESS SERVICE IN AB FOURTEEN
BEFORE PASSING IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS. MR GRAHAM HERE.
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE LEFT. GOOD
MORNING SIR MEMBERS MARK GRAHAM
ON BEHALF OF KEEP CELL ANTENNAS
AWAY- THE THING THAT REALLY
APPLIES TO NOT ONLY THIS BILL
BUT ALL THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
BILLS IS THAT'S THERE HAS BEEN
AN ACCOUNTING- I'LL CALL IT A
SCAM GOING ON THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA IN THE NATION
WHEREBY THE BIG
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN PURCHASE SPENDING
MONEY. ON IT ESSENTIALLY NON
REGULATED SERVICE AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THEIR ACCOUNTING
THEY'VE BEEN. CHARGING IT TO
THE LOCAL SERVICE WHILE WHICH
IS REGULATED IN OTHER WORDS THE
STATE PUBLIC TELECOMMUNICATIONS
UTILITY SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THAT WE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
HAVE ALREADY PAID FOR THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO MAKE AND THE OTHER
BROADBAND BILLS THERE ARE
CURRENTLY BEFORE- THIS
LEGISLATURE SEEKS TO MAKE AND
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY SHOULD
COME FROM TO- TO PAY FOR IT. I
HAVE A BRIEF EXPLANATION HERE
WRITTEN FORM AND I'M GOING TO
HAND IT TO YOUR STAFF I'D LIKE
FOR YOU TO MAKE THIS PART OF
THE RECORD. IN A REALLY ASK THE-
TO COME TO HAVE STAFF IF. THE
FEEL FREE TO CONTACT ME IT'S SO
YOU CAN REALLY. WHERE THIS
FINANCE ACCOUNTING SCAM WENT ON
THERE WAS A CASE CALLED THE A
REGULATORS ANXIOUS FCC THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
THANK. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM NOW IS THE TIME TO
JUST SAY YOUR NAME IN YOUR
POSITION. WE'VE EXCEEDED OUR
THREE MINUTE TIME FRAME. YOUR
NAME AND YOUR POSITION IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION WE'RE NOT SADDAM
FORMER CITY COUNCILMEMBER MEREB
NEVADA CITY CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
REPRESENTED ABOUT A CITY
TELECOM SAFETY COMMITTEE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE HERE NO MOVING HONORING
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS ARE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE TO AB FOURTEEN. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR AB FOURTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. POINT FOURTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN- SKEWS ME LINE- NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH YES.
SACRAMENTO RESIDENT AND
OPPOSING THIS BILL. I JUST MAKE
YOU ALL WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
ONLY AND THIS IS A REMINDER
WITNESSES PLEASE NOTE YOUR
PHONES WERE NOT SPEAKING THANK
YOU AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
OH EIGHT I MEANDERED ANSWER I'M
I'M OPPOSED AND IT SEEMS TO ME
YOU COULD EXTEND THE COURTESY
OF PEOPLE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. FOURTEEN.
AND NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN. BERMAN
FINANCE. IF I'M A SIX YEAR. WE
HAVE NO FILE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN GOES TO SUSPENSE FOR
ME ON A. B. FORTY FIVE BY
AGUIAR-CURRY ON INDUSTRIAL
HEMP. IN THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION FOR THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OF A RIGHT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY- TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI FORTY FIVE. BY
PRESSING ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AN ONLINE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. I REMEMBER AGAIN SAID THE
CARPETING THERE ON BEHALF OF
CHARLOTTE'S WEB IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE A COUPLE OTHERS QUEUING
UP FOR BODY ELSE GOING AT ONE
ZERO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
FORTY FIVE AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. EXACTLY
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR AND
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION- J. WAIT
THIS STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION WILL TAKE IT NOW.
THANK YOU DOCUMENTS OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AB FORTY FIVE WILL
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION
COPPERS KNOCKED ANY NONSENSE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ALL THEY WANT BUT ALSO MOVING
ALONG WILL GO ONLINE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
KILLED BY THE PLAN VISORS
BEHALF OF THE KENNEDY GROWTH CO.
STRONG. WHAT CAN LINE ONE AWAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT OTHER ARE
NO DOUBT YOU DON'T HAVE A WAY
IN A YOU MIGHT OF EXTENDED THE
CURTAIN TO SPEAKER AND I TRUST
WEB BUT I'M OPPOSED TO THIS.
ONE LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT CAN BE A PEDIATRIC
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN A
POST TO AB. FOR FIVE. MISTER WE
HAVE NO I PURCHASE QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. REPORTER OP. WE JUST
GO THROUGH ONE MORE TIME. OKAY
AS A FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ARE
YOU TAKING BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION BUT I'LL I'LL GO TO
THE ROOM HERE LET'S GO TO FORTY
TWO OR THREE OPPOSITION
NOBODY'S HERE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY'S THERE FOR ANYONE
OPPOSED ON THE PHONE LINE AB
FORTY FIVE. EXPRESS OPPOSITION
FOR AB FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. OKAY THANK
YOU- I WOULD HAVE LOVED IT I
COULD- EXPRESSED MY OPPOSITION
ON THE PREVIOUS DAY OUT I'M
STILL OPPOSE INVESTMENT TO.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES SIR
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS WAYNE
BRIDGE MINORITIES PRESENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOUNDATIONS WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN BY IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE THREE MILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT AT THE CDFA INDUSTRIAL
GRANT PROGRAMS- NORDERSTEDT
REFLECTED NEW ANYWAY BECAUSE-
GROGAN ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR GAIN SUPPORT IN A
POSITION. TO JUST NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION NEXT
BEAKER. FIND YOU OPEN. HELLO
EIGHT BY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE MORE CHANCE LINE NINETY
PLEASE ON MUTE YOUR OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS JUSTIN HE- YES MY NAME
IS JUSTIN NEED WITH THE HEMP
FARMERS GUILD I'M A FARMER AN
ORGANIC FARMER FROM BETTER
COUNTY IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL AS WE BECAUSE OF BAD
BUILT FOR THE FUTURE AND
FARMERS AND FARM. IN CALIFORNIA.
NEXT PERSON. THANK YOU I NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. TRY ARE
YOU FROM THE OTHER POLICY
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE AT THE
PUBLIC OP INSTITUTE I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. Y. AND ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LISA
BROWN A CALIFORNIA HAMPL ARMOR
I AM OPPOSED TO AB FORTY FIVE
DUE TO THE ADVERSE IMPACT IT
WILL HAVE ON CALIFORNIA FARMER
NOT A WRITER NEXT MERSON FLOWER
BAND. LINE ONE OH EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. YOU DON'T HAVE LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
UNITING THESE PEOPLE. THE
POPULAR KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR AGAIN ITS
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
IF YOU GO OFF ON TANGENTS WE
ARE GONNA SHUT YOU DOWN. GOING
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU WE ANTICIPATE PUBLIC HEALTH
WILL REQUIRE SEVENTEEN
POSITIONS AND TWO POINT FIVE
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
INDUSTRIAL HEALTH AND RIVER
ENROLLMENT IN OVERSIGHT FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THREE POINT THREE FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING I
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS FUND HAS
YET TO BE ESTABLISHED WHICH
WOULD CREATE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. AGRICULTURE REQUIRES
A HUNDRED SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M CALLING.
ADDITIONALLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA KNOWS THE SCOPE OF
THIS PROGRAM AS ENVISIONED IS
FAIRLY EXPENSIVE AND THEY COST
YOU SEE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
ESTABLISH SUCH A PROGRAM AND
ADEQUATELY FUND STUDIES. WITH
ANOTHER TO THE EXTENT THIS IS A
NEW LINE OF RESEARCH THAT IS
AUTHORIZED BUT NOT SUPPORTED BY
THE FEATURE EVENT FUNDING MODEL
IS MY RESULT IN THE UC USED.
APPLICABLES GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS APPROPRIATIONS TO
SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
STYLE. LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL SITES MINOR
CIRCLE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE STOCK. ALL RIGHT HAVING-HEARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FORTY FIVE GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON A. B. SIX FOURTEEN
ALSO BY A YEAR CURRY ON
WILDLIFE HABITAT- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CAN EIGHTY OTHERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX
FOURTEEN IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE SAYING NO ONE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SINGLE IN THEIR
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FOURTEEN. TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE AWAIT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS NOT A TANGENT TO
HOUSE PEOPLE SPEAK LOUDER
INTERNET SPEED CALL THAT GOOD
GOVERNMENT. AND I MISTER CHAIR
THERE'S NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WELL NOW
GOOD OPPOSITION TO AB SIX
FOURTEEN SAYING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. IN SUPPORT OF AFFECTION
ME OPPOSED AB SIX FOURTEEN WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MONTEREY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB SIX FOURTEEN.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB SIX
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO MY NINETY FOR YOUR OPEN.
HI THIS IS LIBERTY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LIBERTY.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
OH WAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
KNOW OUR THE TANGENT PORTANTINO
WE'RE GOING TO RECALL YOU NEXT.
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS- PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION TO I WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
A FILE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE DEPARTMENT OF. TO MAKE
COSTS RANGING FROM TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING. TO POTENTIALLY FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER FROM THE
ACCOUNT. I WOULD KNOW THAT THE
ADDITIONAL FEE OF TEN DOLLARS
IN PERCENTAGE DUNCAN UPLAND
GAME BIRD VALIDATION THIS BILL-
AND ASSUMING SALES REMAINED THE
SAME LEVEL REVENUE DIRECTED TO
THIS ACCOUNT IS ESTIMATED AT
TWO POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. OUR DEPARTMENT
ADDITIONALLY ASK. PROXIMALLY
ONE DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO
LANDOWNERS ONCE THE PROGRAM IS
RUNNING AT FULL CAPACITY WITH
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY AGREEMENTS
ANNUALLY AFTER ABOUT THREE
YEARS. FINALLY THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD ESTIMATES NO
COST YEAH DISPELS. ALL RIGHT WE
HEARD FROM FINANCE WE HAVE
MISTER Y. CASKEY YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR FINANCES THE
NESTING BIRD HABITAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. CURRENTLY EXISTS IS
THAT BEING FUNDED THROUGH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY OR
FISH AND WILDLIFE. SENATOR
ACTUALLY THIS BILL ACTUALLY
ESTABLISHES THAT PROBE AT
ACTUALLY SUGGEST THAT COUNT TO
SUPPORT THIS IS AN EXISTING
PROGRAM THIS BILL ACTUALLY
CREATE. A SEPARATE ACCOUNT TO
SUPPORT THE EXISTING PROGRAM
RIGHT TO SUE THE INCREASE THAT
YOU WERE- TALKED ABOUT THAT
POSSIBLY WOULD BE ACTUALLY FOR
FILLING THE ROLE THAT THIS THE
PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
PROVIDING ALREADY. MINISTER
THAT THE BILL ALSO MAKES
AMENDMENTS TO THE EXISTING
PROGRAM. OKAY COSTS SOME IN AP
NOTE IN YOUR ANALYSIS THAT THAT
YOU WERE GOING TO DEVELOP-
EXECUTE INDIVIDUAL AGREEMENTS
SO I PRESUME THAT THE SOME OF
THESE AGREEMENTS. OUR YOUR
SPECIFIC YOU'VE ALREADY ENTERED
INTO RIGHT OR THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE HAS. I GUESS I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF THIS
PROGRAM ALREADY EXISTS AND YOU
REACHING TEN DOLLARS YOU COULD
GET TWO MILLION WHAT WOULD BE
ALL THE ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES ON IT OTHER THAN THE
NORMAL COURSE OF FINDING THESE
PEOPLE TO LEASE THEIR LAND AND
ENTERING A CONTRACT THAT
ALREADY EXIST AND JUST CHANGE
THE NAME AND THE DATE. YES WE-
YES WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS AND ACTUALLY THE
REVENUE IS ESTIMATED AT TWO
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WHICH- WHICH CURRENTLY
EXCEEDS. THE COSTS THAT THE-
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ASSESSED. THE ESTIMATED RANGE
OF COSTS DEPENDING ON HOW THEY-
THE CONTRACTS WHETHER WAS
CONTRACTING WITH A PARTNER OR
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IT- WITH
EACH LANDOWNER INDIVIDUALLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WE- TAKE IT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND QUESTIONS FACING
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
FOURTEENTHS WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WE WILL MOVE ON.
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY THREE
AGUIAR-CURRY ON CALIFORNIA
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARDS
PROGRAM TO SUSPEND CAN'T
SUSPENSE CAN MAKE OTHERS WAY
PRESENTATION GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FOUR THREE.
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AB
EIGHT FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL I WANT TO EAT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE RE QUEUE ME I'M
OPPOSED. SHOWS AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. FOR AB EIGHT FORTY THREE.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION AB EIGHT
FOUR THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THIS NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED EIGHT FOUR THREE. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR EIGHT FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOR- ONE
FILED BY ZERO. MY NINETY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. YES THIS IS
DELIBERATING I AM OPPOSING THIS
BILL THANK YOU LIBERTY THANK
YOU I WON ONLY. AND WE'RE GOING
ONE AWAIT STRUCTURE. WHY ONE OH
EIGHT THIS OPPOSITION A YEAR
CURRY- AND I MEAN HER BILL.
MONDAY OPPOSED TO HER SHE CART
RIGHT NECK BEAKER. YEP- THERE'S
NO OTHER BODY ELSE CUED UP AT
THIS TIME CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'VE
FROM SO NAPA OF A EIGHT THREE
OF. WELCOME UTILITIES AS THAT
WOULD. FOR POSITIONS AND CREATE
AN ONGOING FISCAL IMPACT OF
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT. REVENUE
FROM THIS ACCOUNT COMES FROM A
SURCHARGE ON UTILITY BILLS AND
EACH RATEPAYER COULD PAY ABOUT
NINE CENTS PER YEAR TO COVER
THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS. ALL
RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCING OF
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FORTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B. TEN
EIGHTY SIX BY AGUIAR-CURRY ON
ORGANIC WASTE IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANADA AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION- RIGHT TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR.
SUPPORTERS NOBODY HERE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MINORIES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN EIGHTY SIX. JUST FIND
SUPPORT FOR A BI- TEN EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH THE LINE ONE OH EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. WHAT THE AUTHOR THERE
THIS IS SO CONFUSING HAVE TO
PRESENT THEIR BILL DON'T YOU
FLYING THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. POSTED TO MEMBERS JUMPED
IN THE ABOUT TO THE K. COMPOSED
COALITION IS SUPPORT OF. AB TEN
EIGHTY. THANK YOU. THE FINAL
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI TEN EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN EIGHTY SIX
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX. YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR TEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE ONE ONLY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS WAS THE
GARDASIL BILL HEY GRANNY IS
STILL BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO
FILL IN ALL THE KIDS. AND AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE
ZERO EIGHT SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. M. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THE START HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
ROOMS THAT WILL GO TO FINANCE
THAT ONE I APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING MY NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT SHOULD I
AND I AM HERE SO PLEASE TAKE MY
NUMBER I AM IN OPPOSITION. NO
ONE ZERO EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR GOD OVER THE
HOUSE IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR. FIVE FINANCE. THANK YOU
WHERE NATURE AS IT IS YOUR OF
THE AFTER AND RESULTS IN A CHEN
FUND FUNDS COST PRESSURES CAL
RECYCLE ESTIMATES THE ORDER
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME FROM THE INTEGRATED
WASTE MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT AND
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING.
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
ESTIMATES THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES A COST OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME FROM THE ENERGY
RESOURCES PROGRAM ACCOUNT
FINALLY THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING FOR THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL SUCH. ALL SINGLE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX. COSTA SUSPENSEFUL AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED MAGYAR CURRY.
COMMUNICATION SERVICES DISASTER
REPORT TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE PRESENTATIONS BEEN WAIVED.
THE RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT.
OF MOVES TO TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OVER
THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI ELEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FILED BY JUDICIAL SUPPORT FOR A
BI ELEVEN HUNDRED. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WATCH TODAY BY GRANNY GARDASIL
YES WE'RE WATCHING AND THE
PEOPLE. SECURES NOBODY ELSE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
OF AB ELEVEN HUNDRED WE HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE ROOM GO AHEAD.
BUT SHE TERM MEMBERS BERNIE
ROSCOE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO BILLS TO
CURB DUPLICATIVE AND
UNNECESSARY. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE NO ONE ELSE MOVING
HONORING TWENTY FORTY. NOBODY
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. S. OPPOSITION FOR AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY EXCELLENT AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NINE ONE EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. I OPPOSE THIS AND
ANYTHING BY ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
JUMP START A BIGGER. SURE
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
COST OF FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
FROM THE C. P. C. UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT. REVENUE
FROM THIS ACCOUNT COMES FROM
SURCHARGE ON UTILITY BILLS AND
HE TRIPPING REPAIR REPAIR ABOUT
FIVE CENTS PER YEAR TO COVER
THESE ADDITIONAL COSTS. ALL
RIGHT WE FOR FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER
THREE OF US ON. THREE OF US ON
HOMES HOMELESS CHILDREN AND
YOUTH UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THROUGH
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION OF A
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY BY PRESSING ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN.
AND WILL BEGIN WITH ONE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN SENATOR
PANEL AGAINST WEAPONS DURING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. EXES
NINE ONE AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE Q. ME I'M OPPOSE CHEESE
ON THE FORCE TO SHOCK RAIN AND
WIND ONE- FOR YOUR OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE REPRESENTS
AMERICA ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
DIVISION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME I ORDERED OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS OPEN TWENTY FORTY
PLEASE COVER ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TWENTY
SEVEN. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY SO OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN BY HITTING ONE
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
AWAIT YOUR OPEN. IF THIS
LEGISLATOR CARED ABOUT HOMELESS
CHILDREN. NEXT PERSON NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY
FOUR. EXCELLENT DUE TO
CELEBRITY HERE ANYTHING. FOR
LOTUS. OPPOSITION THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU ONE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR OPEN. I CALLING FOR
SUPPORT WHEN AB ONE DOUBLE OH
THREE AND AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR
SO I WENT RIGHT ON THOSE BILLS
RIGHT ABOUT THANK YOU. THE
SHARES NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
SEVEN AND SUPPORT AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED. BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH. FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS ARE
LIKELY AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT AN
ALLOCATION OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR UP TO
THREE COUNTIES OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. IT IS UNCLEAR SOME
OF THE FUNDS MIGHT BE UTILIZED
FOR THIS PURPOSE WE'RE SUPPORT
OTHER WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE. THE BILL NOTES
POSSIBLE FUNDING SOURCES SUCH
AS MCKINNEY VENTO HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE ACT FEDERAL FUNDS
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS
STATE GENERAL FUND OR A
COMBINATION OF FUNDING SOURCES.
NAY THIS BILL COULD CREATE.
STATE MANDATES AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CONCERNS ARE WE RECOMMEND A
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL AND-
EASTERN MINISTER AND ANNUAL
HOUSING QUESTIONNAIRE BE
CONTINGENT UPON RECEIPT OF
FUNDING PROVIDED UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT.
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF HOMELESS
INCLUSION OF A SUNSET DATE FOR
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS ESTABLISHED BY THIS
BILL TO ALIGN WITH THE
AVAILABILITY OF GRANT FUNDS
PROVIDED UNDER THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOL EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
FINANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY SEVEN GOES
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB FORTY
SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUESTS
ON CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
ACT SUSPENSE CANADA AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT TO
SUPPORT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SAYING NO ONE HERE. OR
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO
ONE THEIR MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY SIX. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI FORTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND LINE ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU LINE ONE
OH FOR YOUR OPEN. VIDEOBOARD
AMERICAN GETTING OF PEDIATRICS
SUPPORT. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLY A
GOOD THING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. PLEASE COVER ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
FORTY SIX. SHOP ADDITION FOR AB
FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I WANNA WAIT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA HAD
STRUM I'M STILL DISPLACED BOTH
FARMER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE PHARMACY CARE. NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY SIX. WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. LIVING ON YOUR
NEXT BILL WHICH IS AB EIGHT
BUCKS ME FIVE EIGHT FIVE BY
FAMILY MEMBER RIVAS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE THIS IS A
SPEND CANADA OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE SO MANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MATTER ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE EIGHT FIVE. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EVEN AT THE TO PREPARE
KEY OLDER ADULTS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO OUR LONGER HOTTER
SUMMERS WE CAN'T WAIT ANY
LONGER FOR THE PASSAGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM PLEASED ONE FOLLOWED BY Z.
FOR. FIVE EIGHT BY. AND WE HAVE
ONE AWAIT WILL WAIT TILL THE
NEXT ROUND HERE. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE EIGHT
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIVE EIGHT FIVE.
CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE AWAIT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S NOT ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE FIRE POWER MONEY AND
CHECK OUT BRANDON RITTMAN IN
LINE ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MAYBE IF YOU GUYS
ARE PLAYING HARD. DANIEL WOULD
NOT HAVE ALL THESE FIRES IN
AMRITSAR. MR SURE NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO PARTMINER
FINANCE. THE OFFICE IS PLANNING
AND RESEARCH ESTIMATES THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FUND ANNUALLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR ON GOING OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH ESTIMATES
AN ANNUAL COST OF EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
GRANT PROGRAM. WHO NOTED THE
BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
SPECIFICATIONS AS TO THE SIZE
OF THE PROGRAM WHICH COULD
RANGE ANYWHERE IN THE MILLIONS
TO. TENS TO HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE BILL
ESTABLISHES NEW FIND. SUCH
APPROPRIATION TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM BUT DOES NOT IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC REVENUE SOURCE AND AS
SUCH IT CREATES A GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES- I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM FINANCE AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FIVE EIGHT FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS ON SCHOOL NURSES
CREDENTIALING. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO RIGHT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT ONE FIVE. JUST SUPPORT
FOR AB EIGHT ONE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE'RE GONNA LINE SIXTEEN YOU
ARE OPEN. ONE THEY TOOK CARE
UNIT. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DIRECTLY FROM THE
INVESTIGATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN
SUPPORT OF ET SIX MONTHS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO OR SO SUPPORT FOR A BI.
EIGHT FIFTEEN. I AND GETTING
ALL THE PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
NUMBER IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB EIGHT FIFTEEN. WHAT
THE VISION FOR AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE ONE AWAIT YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO I'M OPPOSED THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD MEDIA ONE
REPRESENTING- YES HELLO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN. Q. WHY NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. STRONG
BAD TO AID THE A FIFTEEN AND
LOWERS. THANK YOU FIND HUNDRED
AND THIRTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THIRTY. BY ONE DURING. GO
AHEAD WHAT HI IS THIS I'M SORRY
I'M LOOKING FOR AB ONE DOUBLE
THREE IN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
FOUR NOT YET RIGHT WE'RE ON AB.
EIGHT FIFTEEN. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IT'S
IMPORTANT OPPOSITION AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL GIVEN IT WILL LIKELY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
POTENTIAL SCHOOL NURSES HOWEVER
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL IS
LIKELY TO RESULT IN ONE TIME
AND ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS.
PRESSURES IN THE SEVERAL TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT
USED TO OFFER A SCHOOL NURSE.
SCHOOL NURSE CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ESTIMATES
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A ONE TIME TEACHER
CREDENTIALS FUND COST FOR. EACH
NEW NURSE CREDENTIALING PROGRAM
APPLICATION PROCESS. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN TESTIMONY WE HEARD
FROM FINANCE WE SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE THREE OF US FROM
CHILD CARE TO A LANGUAGE
LEARNERS SUSPENSE CAN EIGHT
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WITHOUT PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE. EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. SOMEBODY'S QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE AND LINE NINETY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. YES AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE AM I
CORRECT. SILOES STILL RAMOS
JOHN CAN DO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS
STILL OPPOSITION. NOBODY ELSE
IS QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. EDUCATION ESTIMATES
ONE TIME COST OF EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND NOT ONGOING
COST OF FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
WORKLOAD IN THE SYSTEM WOULD BE
MINOR AND CIRCLE. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WILL
MOVE ON TO MR KING'S STARTING
WITH AB THIRTY THREE- HIGH
ENERGY CONSERVATION THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WITH THE RIGHT
TO SUPPORT. SOMEBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- WE WILL GO TO- THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
THREE. SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WHINE ONE AWAIT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY AND WHAT WAS
YOUR QUESTION TO ME. ALL RIGHT
NEXT. PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY FOR ANYONE IN THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THIRTY
THREE. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB
THIRTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND ONE NINETY
FOR YOUR OPEN. DELIVERED IN AB
THIRTY THREE STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MOVING ALONG ONE
AWAIT YOUR OPEN. PANDARIA HAD
STRUM STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIRTY THREE I'M STILL A
DISPLACED GOAT FARMER. I AM
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION GO TO PARMA FINANCE.
THANK YOU THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL WOULD
BE. ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY THREE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. AB FIVE SIX
ONE- BY MR TANG ON- HELP
HOMEOWNERS ADD NEW HOUSING
PROGRAM ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT
FINANCING. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATIONS WILL MOVE RIGHT
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WISHING FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY. AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE EXCUSE
ME SUPPORT OF S. A. B. FIVE SIX
ONE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE
SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND LINE ONE
THIRTY YOUR OPEN. STE I SUPPORT.
AND MIX WE WILL ALIGN ONE AWAIT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE AWAIT YOUR
OPEN PORTRAYED THE. FIVE SIX
ONE. ONE MORE TRY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY ONE AWAIT. I'M MOVING
ALONG WITH GOAL LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
BIRDS WILLIAMSBURG ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
CALIFORNIA YIMBY- THE SAN
FRANCISCO PLANT BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION HONEST BURKE AND
THE COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS
AND DEPART THANK YOU. WINDS
ABOUT ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING PAUL YOU
ARE BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE SIX ONE.
AND ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. ZURCHER THIS IS BOB NEAL
REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD AND
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
FIVE SIX ONE. MISTER NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE SIX ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FIVE SIX ONE.
THE EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO FIVE
SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETY FOUR. CELEBRITY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO FIVE SIX
ONE. Y. AND ONE OH WAIT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I WANT TO WAIT YOU
ARE OPEN. M. THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE ESTIMATES COST OF SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER TO
ESTABLISH AND ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
ALSO ESTIMATES ADDITIONAL
UNKNOWN COSTS FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES AND
ADDITIONAL STAFFING AS IT
FINALIZES THE PROGRAM STRUCTURE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
CMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
JUST BILL RESULTS IN TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE SIX
ONE COAST TO SUSPEND. MOVING ON
TO AB FIFTEEN FORTY BY LIFTING
ON CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
RESENTENCING. DISPENSED
CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COMPANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY.
ELECTORS EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
A BI FIFTEEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ONE
ONE A WEEK YOU ARE OPEN. BUT
WAIT PLEASE ON MUTE. MOVING
ALONG. IN THE WRONG PLACE RIGHT
NEXT PERSON. ONE MOMENT WE'RE
GETTING THERE LINE NUMBER WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE TWENTY
SIX. ALKALINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES I'M IN PORT. THANK
YOU THE FINAL REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR FIFTEEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. NO ONE ELSE ALL RIGHT
WHAT OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
FORTY. COME ON UP STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. GOOD MORNING SURE
PORTANTINO MY NAME'S TOM GAVIN
WERE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE VERY
WHERE ON APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH
SOME KIND OF PROCEDURE POSSIBLY
CRIMINAL HAPPENED ON THE EIGHT
PROCESSING OF AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN INVOLVING MR CHAN WE
WANTED TO PUT THAT THE RECORD
THANK YOU WE FUNDS THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE HERE
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THE PROPOSAL NO ONE THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FELT FOR YOU ON THIS
ONE. ALL RIGHT STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION WE'RE NOT SEND THEM
FORMING ABOUT A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND MAYOR- NEVADA CITY
TELECOM SAFETY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WELL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE
HERE AND NO ONE AROUND TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE OPPOSED.
ON THE PHONE LINE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB
FIFTEEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FINE ONE
AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM GIVE
TESTIMONY NEXT PERSON NINETY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. OKAY WHAT
ONE SPEAK AT A TIME AB FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN CELEBRITY FROM
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER AUTOMOBILES
EXISTING FORTY AT THIS TIME
STRUCTURE PLEASE GO AHEAD
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA PARTMINER
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE
STATE AND COUNTIES AS A RESULT
OF REDUCE REDUCE YOUR
CORPORATION TERMS HOWEVER WE DO
KNOW CONCERNS OF THE BILL
CREATES FORECLOSURE THE TRIAL
COURTS TO HOLD THESE HEARINGS
FOR THE PETITIONERS AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WEBER
SENTENCING IS DENIED. OR
DEFENDING CLAIMS. ERROR IN THE
SENTENCING. THAT APARTMENT OF
JOE JUST BECAUSE OF. THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING TO
RESPOND TO APPEALS. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ESTIMATES THE
BILL COULD HAVE A FISCAL IMPACT
BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND I'M
GOING FOR THE TRIAL COURTS TO
PROCESS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SIX HUNDRED PETITIONS FOR
RESENTENCING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATES THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS DUE TO
REDUCTIONS IN THE TROUBLED
TERMS START BY INDIVIDUALS.
REFERRED TO SHORT TO THIS BILL.
AND LASTLY THE BILL COULD
REDUCE. JUSTICE RELATED COSTS
AS A MODIFIES THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR COURTS TO SENTENCE
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN FORTY GOES
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE IN AB THIRTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN ON
ELECTIONS VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION.
REPUBLICAN MINUTES IMPORTERS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVEN.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB- THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND ONE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. REGARDING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES AND CORK. THANK YOU
ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLYURETHANE
HALF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. AND LINE
ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DONNA THANK YOUR
BEGINNING A LOT YOU HANDLE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THE
STRUCTURE WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY SEVEN. COMMON UP MY
FRIEND YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR POSITION BACK
AT YOUR PORTANTINO MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGANN WITH A CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE ACUTELY AWARE OF THE
DOMINION SOFTWARE ON ANY OF
THESE VOTING MACHINES HAS BEEN
HACKED AND ACTUALLY CANNOT BE
RELIED UPON WE UP WE SUPPORT
VOTING BY. PAPER ONLY THANK YOU.
I WOULD STIPULATE THERE IS NO
PROOF OF THAT ALLEGATION JUST
FOR THE RECORD. NEXT PERSON. HI
EVEN AT SEVEN FOUR- FAIR AND
TRANSPARENT ELECTIONS JUST LIKE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MARICOPA
COUNTY ARIZONA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT MOVIE HONORING
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THERE. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. THIRTY SEVEN. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR SB THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO BY NINETY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. IT'S. SB THIRTY SEVEN
THERE IS NO PROOF SHOULD NOT
INVESTIGATE THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE STRONG OPPOSITION. AND
NOBODY ELSE IS GIVING UP THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AT THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE MAN.
R. AS A NEW PROGRAM OR HIGHER
LEVEL OF SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED
BY LOCAL AGENCIES RELATED TO
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT PROCESS
SEES. THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
MANDATE EXPOSURE IS UNKNOWN BUT
COULD BE SIGNIFICANT. WE KNOW
THAT THEIR TIME OF THIS
ANALYSIS TO SECRETARY OF STATE
AND NOT PROVIDED FISCAL
ESTIMATE BUT WE NOTE ANY
POTENTIAL COSTS ASSOCIATED ARE
ANTICIPATED TO BE MINOR
STORABLE. SINCE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE IS ALREADY DEVELOPED
AND IMPLEMENTED THE BOOK BY
MAIL TRACKING SYSTEM REQUIRED
TO BE USED BY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. THANK YOU. SEEN OUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTIONS SB
THIRTY SEVEN. CLOSE THIS IS US.
MOVING TO AB SEVEN I SIX. AND
VOTER REGISTRATION NEW
CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM. BY MISTER BERMAN THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC HEARING IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN NINETY SIX. PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
SUPPORT TO SEVEN NINETY SIX BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO AND LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
AGAIN ON THE ADDRESSING WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES AND THE COURTS. FIVE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING THIS IS KINDA TRICKLING
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA HEARING SUPPORT.
STRUCTURE WILL KNOW THE
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN NINETY
SIX. COMMA NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. YES YOUR FORTY MY
NAME IS PAUL GAVAN WERE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ACUTELY
AWARE WITH AFFIDAVITS AT THE U.
S. SUPREME COURT RIGHT NOW THAT
ONE VOTE PER PERSON DID NOT
HAPPEN IN TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS
FRACTIONATED SON GOT MORE THAN
ONE VOTES ON GOT LESS THAN ONE
VOTE THIS IS PROVEN. THANK YOU
WE OPPOSE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE OF THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THING NO ONE THERE WILL
GO TO THE MODERATOR. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN NINETY
SIX. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR A. B.
SEVEN NINE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO LINE NINETY
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. TO NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AB
SEVEN NINETY SIX WE'RE GOING TO
SIT WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FILE MISTER CHAIR-
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN NINETY SIX.
CLOSE THE SUSPENSE FOR EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY EIGHT ON STUDENT
TRANSFER TREATMENT REFORM ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BY MISTER
BERMAN IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE ON HIS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. NUMBER IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY PUBLISHER. WE'LL
GO TO MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. NINE TWENTY
EIGHT. EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
A BI NINE TWO EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KATRINA LONDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB. NINE TWENTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU ONE MOMENT MISTER SURE WE
HAVE ANOTHER ONE CUED UP.
QUEUING UP FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE ZERO. AND WEBER
LINE. TWENTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING JENNIFER GONZALEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE TEN
THE GOVERNOR LET ME GONNA LOCK
IT IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT SEE NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE. IN A ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. AB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT. CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR A BEER NINE TWO EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AT ONE MOMENT MISTER SURE
WE HAVE A COUPLE ACUNA QUEUING
UP. THE BODY ELSE GOING AT ONE
ZERO FOR THE OPERATOR CAN I
GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD MORNING SIR- ROB COLLINS
OUTGOING CHAIR ARGUES ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERSEGMENT FULL
COMMITTEE OF ACADEMICS AND IT'S
WE ARE CLOSE TO EIGHTY NINE TWO
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MY ONE FORTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU TYLER I DO ARE TO BE
OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HOW ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE QUEUING UP.
ONE ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK THIS MIGHT BE A
LITTLE DELAY I'M ACTUALLY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF- OUR AID
BE FIFTEEN FORTY. THANK YOU.
I'M BEING. IT UP BUT TIME NO
ELSE IN OUR OF NINETEEN EIGHT
WILL GO TO APARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALTHOUGH BETTER ALIGNMENT OF
TRANSFER PATHWAYS AMONG
SEGMENTS IS A LAUDABLE GOAL AN
ATG PATHWAY PUT AT EIGHTY T.
PATHWAYS PLAY AN INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS A
BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS. IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
MILLIONS TO LIVE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS- HOWEVER
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED
THIS BILL. COULD POTENTIALLY BE
OFFSET BY ONGOING- AND
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS IF THE BILL WERE TO
RESULT IN REDUCED ACCESS UNIT
ACCUMULATION AND IMPROVED TIME
2 DEGREES AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ADDITIONALLY IT'S UNCLEAR
CONSOLIDATING LOWER DIVISION
GENERAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
FOR ALL TRANSFER STUDENTS.
IRRESPECTIVE OF THE STUDENTS
SCORES A STUDY ONE ABLE
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
GENERAL EDUCATION COURSES. AND
EACH COURSE WORK IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND COST EFFECTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. BECAUSE SOME G.
COURSEWORK MAY ALSO BE SERVING
AS PREREQUISITE COURSES ARE
OTHER AT T. A POSSIBLE COURSE
WORK. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT. VERSUS
FENCE. IN AB ELEVEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN ON POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE COUNTY OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATIONAL RIGHT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN. EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN ELEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO POINT ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. FINAL CALL FOR LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MOVING ALONG WITH THE LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN KATRINA
LYNDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY INSTRUCT THE COURT.
THANK YOU ONE ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY TWENTY
THREE PLEASE- YOU YOUR PHONE.
OPENING A LONG LINE EIGHTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SERGEANT RECALLED THE VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE SENATE KAPERNICK ME
COLLEGES. AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. YEAH MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT OVER OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WENT BACK I WAS HAVING PHONE
PROBLEMS OR MAYBE YOU ARE RIGHT
IT DOES X. PERSON. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
OKAY BY NINETY FOUR WOULD YOU
PLEASE EVERY PROMPT. BY NINETY
FOUR PLEASE RE PROMPT. I NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF
ELEVEN ELEVEN WILL GO TO THE
PARTMINER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ESTIMATES ONE TIME LOCAL
ASSISTANCE COST BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ONE MILLION DOLLARS
PER COLLEGE TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. THAT
WOULD RESULT IN A STATE WIDE
RANGE OF ROUGHLY TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION. FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND. 510015 DEGREES
GRANTING COLLEGES. WOULD NOTE
THAT TO THE EXTENT A CONCOURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM REDUCES ACCESS
UNIT ACCUMULATION FOR STUDENTS.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN COST
SAVINGS OFFSETTING THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION IN ADDITION TO
HELPING STUDENTS COMPLETE THEIR
PROGRAMS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
WOULD KNOW THAT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FOR
WORK GROUP THAT SUPPORTS THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF A SYSTEM WIDE COMMON COURSE
NOT. AND REQUIRES ANY FUNDS NOT
EXPENDED ON THE WORKGROUP TO BE
USED TO IMPLEMENT SUCH A
NUMBERING SYSTEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN ON AIR POLLUTION SMALL
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES. A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IN
PRESENTATIONS BEEN WAVE OF ALL
RIGHT TO SUPPORT- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX SEEING NO
ONE C. KNOWN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
FUNDRAISER ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX. TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
LINE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARE ROCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF GLENDALE AND STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. ONE ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ALAN ABS WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
WINE ONE FORTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
FORTY NINE YOU MIGHT BE MUTED
PLEASE ON MUTE. ONE MORE CALL
FOR LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND WE HAVE NOBODY
ELSE Q. IT WELL WE'RE JUST
GETTING ONE MORE ONE MOMENT. I
MISTER CARE THEY'RE JUST WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE SECOND PLEASE.
AND WILL I WON FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND ONE FIFTY SIX
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT TO Q. I WAS
AT THE LAST ONE. THAT WAS THE
LAST ONE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX COMMON UP SIR YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN GERMANY'S
PUBLIC AVENUE WE ARE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA TWENTY TWENTY CLEAN
ATMOSPHERE ACT WHO KNOWS THE
FROM AUGUST THIRTEENTH OF THIS
YEAR WE CAN ELIMINATE ONE HUGE
SOURCE OF POLLUTION
RADIOFREQUENCY MICROWAVE
RADIATION ABOVE SIX THOUSAND
MEGAHERTZ THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
ON FRIDAY THANK YOU WE OPPOSE
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. YOU KNOW
SHE'S GOING THE OTHER WAY WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX. EXPRESS OPPOSITION
FOR THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME LINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. M. A.
R. TAKE THEMSELVES I THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS AFRIKA WORSE FOR THE
NATIONAL LANDSCAPE ASSOCIATION
WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AND MY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EXCELLENT YOU GUYS PROBABLY
SHOULD MAKE THE ACCESS CODE
WORDS WORK FROM THE GET GO I AM
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS CUTE OKAY WE'LL
GO BACK TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY ONE
IT'S FUNNY HOW WE FLIP IN RIGHT
AT THE LAST SECOND WHEN YOU
LEAST EXPECT IT RIGHT NEXT
PERSON ON. IT NOBODY ELSE IS
CUTE MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF YOU
WOULD STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE YOUR
POSITION ON THE RECORD. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION GO TO FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. YES OF THE
COST AND FROM THE PROVISIONS OF
YOUR- STORABLE WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE BILL MAY CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AS
REQUIRES A NEW PROGRAM OR
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE TO BE
PROVIDED BY LOCAL AGENCIES.
MORE SPECIFICALLY AT THE BILL
IMPLEMENTS REQUIREMENTS OF THE
FEDERAL STATUTE OR REGULATION.
BUT IT APPEARS THE ACTIVITY
SIXTEEN THE MANDATE IN FEDERAL
STATUTE. THANK YOU WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN INCREASED
EXPENDITURES TO MAKE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR COMMERCIAL
REBATES OR SIMILAR INCENTIVE
FUNDING TO LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS. IN OUR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICTS
OUR- EXPENDITURES IS UNKNOWN AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM FINANCE AND SEE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B. FORTY
SEVEN HUMAN SERVICES
COORDINATOR. THIS IS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IT IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- REYES WHO IS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF FORTY
SEVEN WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE BUT-
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SEVEN. YOU SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI FORTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT FOR AB FOUR
SEVEN. WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY SEVEN
SEE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM SCENE
OF ANY MOVIE TWENTY FORTY IS
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FORTY SEVEN. SPECIAL
OPPOSITION FOR AB. FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE. FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FELL BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
OPPOSE. I MANDATE HEDSTROM I'M
STILL A GOOD PLACE TO GO WINE
ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM WILL
CLOSE I AM SURE ALL THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS ALL RIGHT AND
FOR THE HOUSE AND SENATE ALLOWS
YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU THIS BILL
CREATES SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES ACCORDING%
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES BASED ON THE SCOPE OF
SERVICES AND THE AUTHORS
ESTIMATE OF THE SEPARATED
FAMILY POPULATION. THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN COST UPWARDS OF
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. THESE COSTS WOULD
BE ON GOING BUT NOT IN
PERPETUITY AS IMPACTED
POPULATION IS NOT EXPECTED TO
GROW GIVEN THAT THE POLICY IS
NO LONGER IN EFFECT. HAVING
HEARD FROM FINANCING A
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FORTY SEVEN GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB FOR. TWELVE BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ON
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE IN THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
AND SUPPORT THE FAMILY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
FOR TWELVE. EXPRESSLY OF
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOW WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF AB FOR
TWELVE COMMA NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND POSITION. MY NAME'S PAUL ME
DEVIN AND WE'RE WITH CALIFORNIA
TO RECOGNIZE WE HAVE IN
ALIENABLE RIGHTS GIVEN TO US BY
GRANTED BY OUR BIRTH BY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION NO
COMMISSION IS NEEDED TO DEBATE
THE TOPIC. WE'VE ALSO BUILT.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE KNOW WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WATER IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FOUR TWELFTH.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB.
FOR TWELVE. ONE FILED BY ZERO
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR AB. FOR
TWELVE. AND NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE HAVE A FILE ON AB FOR
TWELVE YES MISTER CHAIR
ALTHOUGH WE'RE SENSITIVE TO THE
GOALS OF THE COMMISSION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE AS IT
COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN. WE KNOW THAT ALTHOUGH THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION WOULD
SERVE WITHOUT COMPENSATION THE
BILL CREATES SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES POTENTIALLY UP TO THE
LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. WE KNOW THAT THE NEW FIND
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL IS
ALLOWED TO COLLECT MONEY BE A
GIFT REQUESTS DONATIONS ARE
GRANT FUNDS HOWEVER THE BILL
COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
PRESSURE- TO EXTEND THE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO THE SOURCES. ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB FOR TWELVE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. AB FOUR SIX
NINE MY FAMILY MAJORITY NEITHER
MAJORITY LEADER RAMOS. I'M
PUPIL INSTRUCTION FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION. OF A RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FOUR SIX NINE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOT ANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOUR
SIX NINE. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR AB FOUR SIX NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR SIX NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FOUR SIX NINE. TO-
TRANSITION FOR AB FOUR SIX NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THIS ARTICLE. AND WE WILL
GO LINE FORTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. MY APOLOGIES AS A SUPPORT
TEACHER ALLEGED ON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR THE CLIENT. THERE'S
A- AND THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
COULD WE DO OPPOSITION. NO ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION TO FOUR SIX
NINE OF IT IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN ROOM TWELVE FOUR TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FOUR SIX NINE. IT'S
JUST. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR AB
FOUR SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
FARMING FINANCE. THANK YOU BOTH
THE- COMMISSION AND THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION AT.
ESTIMATED THOSE VERSIONS WOULD
BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE BUT NOTE
THAT AB ONE THIRTY TWO CHAPTER
ONE FORTY FOUR OF THIS YEAR ARE
THE HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL INCLUDE STATUTORY
PROVISIONS TRIPWIRE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO CONFIRM
THAT ALL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
COMPLETE THE FASTER. OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCING OF QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTIONS AB FOUR SIX TIME AGO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. ALSO BY
SEVEN MAJORITY LEADER RAMOS ON
ALTERNATIVE RENEWABLE FUEL AND
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. ON THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE THERE'S NO ONE HERE
IS GOING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MURDERS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE YOUR MAPS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. ONE
LINE IN Q. X. LINE ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
DEFINITELY OPPOSED TO THAT I'M
IN THE WRONG PLACE PLEASE READ
TO ME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED HIS
OR ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY KNOW.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU TO SHARE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO. THE FIRST TO LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO. ONE
THIRTY USER DEVICE ON MUTE.
SOME OF THE LONG CLIMB ONE
FIFTY ONE. ANNERY HAVE STRONG
OPPOSED. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. PROPOSITION
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WITH A
SUPPORT OPPOSITION ABOUT A
FINANCE. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND HIT DISSIPATES
THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR THIS BILL FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUND. AS
A RESULT OF CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM. THE CLEAN TRANCE.
DESTRESS LADDER MILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL FUNDING FROM THE
VEHICLE AND BEST VESSEL
REGISTRATION FEES. VEHICLE
IDENTIFICATION PLATE FEES SINCE
ROBIN VIS AND SUPPORTS PROGRAMS
THAT DEVELOP CLEAN VEHICLE
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB FORTY
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT. KINETIC
ENERGY PROJECTILES AND CHEMICAL
AGENTS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
SUPPORT. OF AB FORTY EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FORTY EIGHT. JUST SUPPORT FOR A
BI FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
PHONE THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WHAT ONLINE SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILLIAM UPTON BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE HAVE LINE.
SIXTY ONE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CANNOT CHECK FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND LEARN THE
COURT. AND WE HAVE LINE. ONE
FIFTY ONE- PLEASE RE QUEUE ME
I'M IN THE WRONG PLACE IT'S
RAINING GONZALEZ FELL BECAUSE
I'M DEFINITELY OPPOSE DIVIDEND
MODERATOR. OKAY MONOLOGUE
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINES IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION AB FORTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. AND IT WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. UNITS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. BLOODLINE.
ONE FIFTY ONE. ARE YOU
REPRIMAND THAT MODERATOR HE'S
JUST DOING HIS JOB NEXT PERSON.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
BILL IS ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN
COST OF APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ON
GOING. TO COST VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION THANK YOU. RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FORTY EIGHT LOGO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB SEVENTY FOUR BY
GONZALES AND COMMUNICATIONS.
UNIVERSAL SERVICE LIFELINE
PROGRAM THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OPPOSITE WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO
MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
FOUR. WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. FOR INSTANCE FOR
SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THERE NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY
FOUR HAMANA MY FRIEND. MONNING
SHERMAN PORTANTINO UPON THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE ACUTELY AWARE AND NOTE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION CAN MAKE PRICES.
BETTER FOR EVERYONE BY USING
TITLE TO REGULATION IT'S A
STRATEGY NOT BEING SHOWN HERE
IT CAN BE DONE AND CAN SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM WE OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
GOING ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOBODY
THEIR MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE AND SUPPORT ACTUALLY
MEAN OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY
FOUR. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE HAVE LINED. ONE
FIFTY ONE. ANDREA HAD STRUM
OPPOSED. NO OTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCIER ON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL CREATE
A FISCAL IMPACT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE UNIVERSAL
LIFELINE TELEPHONE SERVICE
TRUST FUND FOR STATE OPERATIONS
THIRTY MILLION TO ONE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
INCREASE AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
COSTS. IF LIFELINE OR TO REACH
WE CERTIFICATION RIGHT SIMILAR
TO THE FEDERAL LIFELINE
PROGRAM. THE FUND SUPPORTED BY
A MONTHLY SURCHARGE APPLIED TO
THE TOLD ME CATION BILLS OF THE
STATE'S APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SIX
MILLION TELEPHONE USER LINES.
SO THE SURCHARGE APPLIED TO
EACH LINE MAY BE INCREASED BY
ABOUT APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THREE
CENTS TO TWO DOLLARS AND FIFTY
CENTS PER YEAR. TO GENERATE
ADEQUATE REVENUE TO COVER THESE
COSTS. WOULD NOTE THAT THE COST
OF THIS BILL MAY EXACERBATE AN
EXISTING STRUCTURE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WITHIN THE LIFELINE
TELEPHONE SERVICE TRUST FUND.
WHICH HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
CONSISTENT YEAR OVER YEAR
DECLINE IN SURCHARGE REVENUES
THAT SUPPORT THE FUND. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS SEEING NINE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB SEVENTY FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B.
FOUR FIVE ZERO FIVE FAMILY
MEMBER GONZALEZ ON PARAMEDIC
DISCIPLINARY REVIEW. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANADA OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIVE ZERO.
THE STATE'S SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FOUR FIVE ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN
THAT SUPPORT FOR A BI. FOR
FIFTY. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
LINES AND KEEP. ALL RIGHT-
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR FIVE ZERO NO ONE'S IN THIS
ROOM. NO ONE'S IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- AND ANYONE ON THE PHONE
NINE OPPOSED AB FOUR FIVE OH.
THE STATE OPPOSITION AB FOUR
FIVE OH ME PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE. NOW WE HAVE LINE
ONE FIFTY ONE. ANDREA HAD
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINE TO Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE NEW BOARD WOULD BE FOUNDED
UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE FROM THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES PERSONNEL FUND
WHICH IS SUPPORTED BY LICENSURE
FEES WHILE THE AUTHORITY MAY
INCREASE PARAMEDIC LICENSURE
FEES TO CARRY OUT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL IN ITS
ENTIRETY WE WOULD NOTE THAT
GIVEN THE RECENT FEET.
INCREASED BY THE AUTHORITY IT
IS UNLIKELY THAT THE AUTHORITY
WOULD FURTHER INCREASE FEES
WHICH WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ONGOING. IS
ALREADY WOULD REQUIRE SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND ONGOING DEPLOYMENT
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THE
AUTHORITY ALSO NOTES THAT THE
BILL COULD CREATE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS THE
DEPARTMENT FOR INVESTIGATORS
AND LICENSING PROGRAM FUNCTIONS
IN ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD IS
CREATED BY THE BILL. ALL RIGHTS
EMAIL QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. FOUR
FIVE ZERO GOES TO SUSPENSE. A.
B. SEVEN OH ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. ON A. B. SEVEN A ONE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NUMBER IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN A ONE. SHARE SUPPORT FOR
A BI SEVEN ALL ONE THE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO WE DO HAVE ONE
LINE IN Q. WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE ONE SIX
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY
NAME IS CAROLINE STAPLETON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE LABOR
COMMITTEE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN NO
ONE THANK YOU. WE ALSO HAVE
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANY GONZALEZ STILL TODAY
ACTUALLY A BUSY LITTLE BEAVERS.
RIGHT KNOWING THE LINES IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WELL NOW BUT OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN A ONE. COME ON UP STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
YOUR POSITION. MISTER REMEMBERS
JOHN LATIMER ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS OPERATE
NUMEROUS DISTRIBUTION WAREHOUSE
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA MUCH LIKE
OUR STORES WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE THESE CENTERS OPERATE ON
A ROBUST BODY OF LABOR LAW
ALREADY WE SEE THIS BILL AS
INCREASING COSTS AND LIABILITY
RISKS WHEN THE BILL DOES COME
UP ON THE SUSPENSE FILE WE WERE
TOP PERCH OPPOSITION AT THAT
TIME THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED IN THIS ROOM NOW
MOVING ON ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEE NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB SEVEN
A ONE. THE STATE OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN OH ONE ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FREE HELPLINE
ONE FIFTY ONE. WARRANTED OR NOT
DAMAGE WITH EIGHTY FIVE. THAT
FELT. NO OTHER LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHTS APARTMENT FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ANTICIPATES TOTAL
COSTS BETWEEN TWO POINT SIX
MILLION AND TWO POINT EIGHT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR
FROM VARIOUS FUNDS DURING THE
INITIAL TWO TO FOUR YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD OF THIS
BILL FOR ENFORCEMENT AND
REGULATORY DEVELOPMENT. IN
ADDITION. BECAUSE OF THE
PROXIMITY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS STRAWBERRIES
FUNDS ONGOING FOR ENFORCEMENT
ONCE THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH STANDARDS BOARD'S
REGULATIONS ARE IN PLACE. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WEAVERVILLE
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN I
WANNA GO TO SUSPENSE. AB
THOUSAND THREE ON WAGE THEFT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL WRITE
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
YOU COMING UP TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. TELL ME YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
HI GOOD MORNING NOT SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GAIL STEWART ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER STEPHAN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE KNOW WILL MOVE DURING
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
THOUSAND THREE. THE STATE
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE THOUSAND
THREE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE HAVE LINE. ONE
THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY
OKAY A GOOD BATTING COMING MY
NUMBER I AM- CALLING TO THINK
MARANDA GONZALEZ IS A WATERSHED
MOMENT FOR WAIT STAFF I. OFFER
MY SUPPORT OF THE RAGE THAT
AFFECT THEM THANK YOU FOR
WAITING TWO AND A HALF YEARS
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION. MARK NEXT PERSON.
WE HAVE LINE ONE FIFTY ONE.
VERY STRONG. THANK YOU KNOW FOR
THE LINES THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE THOUSAND THREE. WE ALREADY
YEAH AB OPPOSITION NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB ONE
THOUSAND THREE. STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE THOUSAND
THREE ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
LINES AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION-DON'T ANTICIPATE A SIGNIFICANT
FISCAL IMPACT FROM THIS BILL.
BUT WE WOULD KNOW THE POTENTIAL
COSTS AREN'T CLEAR BECAUSE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT WOULD BE
DETERMINED BY MULTIPLE FACTORS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE CHARGING DECISIONS OF
PROSECUTORS JUDICIAL DISCRETION
THE PART CRIMINAL HISTORY OF
EACH DEFENDANT. THE BILL COULD
LEAD TO AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS SENTENCED
TO STATE PRISON OR COUNTY JAIL.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS DOES NOT
ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT FROM
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM THE PARTMINER
FINANCE. AND ALSO FROM. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ENCINO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB ONE
THOUSAND THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL'S. BILL STARTING
WITH AB SIXTY ONE. TO SUSPEND
CANDIDATES ON BUSINESS PANDEMIC
RELIEF I NEED TO A
PRESENTATION. OF OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU THE
STATE SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. WE HAVE ONE
ONE FIFTY ONE. THE REAL EARLY
FOR YOUR PEOPLE PERSON. THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION. OF AB SIXTY ONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN HIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WATER IS THERE ANYONE
OPPOSED ON THE PHONE LINE AB
SIXTY ONE. THE STATE OPPOSITION
AB SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
ESTIMATES THAT WILL RESULT IN
MEINEM SEVERAL COSTS TO PROCESS
ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY CATERING
AUTHORIZATIONS AND ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE RELATED. TO THE
EXPANDED AREA. WOULD KNOW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INDICATES THAT WILL NOT HAVE A
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE DEPARTMENT.
ALL RIGHT- SENIOR QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB
SEVENTY SEVEN. WITH A PLAN
ABOUT PLANNING AND ZONING AND
HOUSING ELEMENTS. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
CASF MONEY TO SUPPORT. SOMEBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ON. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
TO SHARE SUPPORT FOR AMY SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THAT'S ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
AND WE HAVE LINE SEVENTY SEVEN.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS WILLIAM MUNSON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING-
CATALYST IN SUPPORT I HAD THE
PROBLEM SIR AND SPUR IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME ABOUT
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY SEVEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE MM ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO PARMA
FINANCE. THANK YOU. IN OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATE COST OF
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUNDING
ANNUALLY- AND ADDITIONALLY
NOTES ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
POSITIONS MAY ALSO BE REQUIRED
GIVEN THE OVERALL DEPARTMENTAL
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD. WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS A RESULT IN STATE
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO CALLING STILL QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL ON
HOMELESS. PROGRAM DATA
REPORTING IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AB NINE EIGHT
NINE SEVEN SEVEN ON HOMELESS
PROGRAM DATA WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
CINNAMON HERE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- MODERATOR THERE'S
NO ONE THERE WILL GO RIGHT TO
YOU WAS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE SEVEN SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL. SURE SUPPORT
FOR A BI NINE SEVENTY SEVEN I
MEAN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AT THE
MICROPHONE IS THE MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN THREE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK%
YOU THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNCIL ESTIMATE
ONGOING COST OF ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. IN A SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OF FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN ONGOING COST OF THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT INDICATE
ANY COSTS RESULTING FROM THE
SPILL OF THE MINOR STUMBLE.
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU WE'VE
HEARD FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. NINE
SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVE ON AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. GABRIEL ON
RESILIENCY THROUGH ADAPTATION
ECONOMIC VITALITY AND EQUITY
ACT. SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO TO-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. SO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. SURE SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AND
MATERNAL LINES IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR.
THE SHARE OPPOSITION TO AB ONE
THREE EIGHT FOUR ONE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOU'RE NOT
OPPOSITION TO ONE THREE EIGHTY
FOUR. WE DO HAVE A LINE OF AN
OPERATOR CAN BE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. LINE. THIRTY THREE
THREE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
ASHLEY OVER HELP ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS FOREVER WE SUPPORT THE
OVERALL ITENTION OF EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE
INTERCONNECTION OF RELATED
BILLS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN AND WHETHER
THE SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA
PLAN AT THE TO BE EFFECTIVE
TURNING STATEWIDE STRATEGY TO
REGIONAL ACTIONS AND PORTABLE
TIMETABLE. THIS MAY NOT BE OF
MUCH STRICTLY SESSION TOTAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. FOR UP AS-
OUR- DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH ESTIMATES
OF ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. COST INITIALLY AND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING TO THE BILL.
LASTLY THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT
ALL STATE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES SHOULD BE SUFFICIENTLY
RESOURCE TO ADEQUATELY IDENTIFY
PREPARE FOR RESPOND TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHICH
WILL LIKELY CREATE ONGOING COST
PRESSURES. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING HEARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO ON HEALTH FACILITIES
A CRITICAL CARE UNIT THAT
DESIGNATION FLEXIBILITY. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WITH
ALL RIGHT TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. OF AN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI U. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO IN A
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO WE
HAVE LONG LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME I ORDERED OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED OF
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
MINORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO. EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO YOU
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. ONE
ADELINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BURKE BUT MINE
REMOVED HIMSELF SO AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES NEW
SPECIAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST OF TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND ON
COMEY. ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO GHOSTS
TWO SUSPECTS. THIRTY NINE TO A
REDUCED FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY SEVEN MEMBER GABRIEL AND
SENTENCING CONSIDERATION OF
COST. THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION. OF A
RIGHT TO TEST MONEY SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SUPPORT
OF A SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOR ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
USING YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE HERE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FIVE OR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. SURE OPPOSITION
TO AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR IN
A PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE HAVE AN ONLINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION. OF AB THAT WAS
OPPOSITION I'M SORRY. PARTMINER
FINANCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS REPORTS
MINORSEVERAL COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THE WORKLOAD
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
WHEN ANALYST OFFICE WOULD
LIKEWISE BE MINORS DOUBLE WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
THE COST OF WHICH ARE UNKNOWN
IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE PROCESS
OF PROSECUTORS AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS IMPLEMENTED TO
PROVIDE THE REQUIRED
INFORMATION TO THE COURT. ALL
RIGHT WE HEARD FROM FINANCE WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING THE
AB SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ON COASTAL
RESOURCES. THE SUSPENSE ACCOUNT
EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WAY
PRESENTATION WE ALL RIGHT TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. SUPPORTING AB SIXTY SIX
OR SEVEN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
VOTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY
SIX. SURE SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIXTY SIX NGUYEN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE NOT TO ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE A LINE IN Q. LINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
JOHNSON PLANNED OUT OF THE PART
OF IT SAN DIEGO THE CITY
INDONESIA SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
AB. SIXTY SIX. THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRED TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR
COMPLETION OF THE STUDY
DEVELOPMENT OF THE DEBATE A BIG
DATABASE AND THE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE- WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THE AN APPROPRIATION OF TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CORPORATION RESEARCH AT. THE UC
IS INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT AND THAT
NO ADDITIONAL COSTS ARE
ESTIMATED BEYOND THIS
APPROPRIATION. LAST THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY IDENTIFIES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
BILL. ARE I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
FIANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY SIX WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB ONE
SEVENTEEN ALSO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH ON AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. THIS IS A-
CANDIDATE ME ON HIS WAY
PRESENTATION- WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE ONE
SEVEN. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
AB ONE ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CAN SUPPORT AB ONE ONE
SEVEN ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE DO HAVEONE LINE WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN MARC
WATTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
SEVENTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO MANY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY HIS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB ONE
ONE SEVEN. THE STATE OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE ONE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THANK YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A
LEARNING QUEUE IT'S LINE ONE
TEN ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
APOLOGIES FOR MISSING KEY
SUPPORT BUT HE DAVID I'M TO BE
A WITHIN YOUR P. CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE SEVEN
THANK YOU. ALL RE PROMPT AGAIN
IF ANYONE LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL AB.
ONE ONE SEVEN. KERN ONLINE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF AB
ONE ONE SEVEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU YOUR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES THE
BILL REQUIRES ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN 202-122-3002
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AN ON GOING. TO ESTABLISH
THE PROJECT SELECT A PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR AND CONDUCT
ONGOING PROGRAM EVALUATION
WOULD KNOW THAT THE BUDGET ACT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE INCLUDES TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ELECTRIC BICYCLE INCENTIVES
PROJECT ON A ONE TIME BASIS. OF
THIS BILL DOES CREATE FUTURE
POTENTIAL COST PRESSURES TO THE
GENERAL FUND WHERE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
WHICH IS FUNDED STEVE EUROPEAN
PRIVATE PRIOR YEARS BY STASHING
THIS PROJECT INSTRUCTIONS. ALL
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE SEVENTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SO IS BILL
STARTING WITH AB SIXTY EIGHT ON
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. HOUSING
PLAN IT'S A SUSPENSE CAN EIGHT
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT
SUPPORT. IS NO MANY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY EIGHT. SURE
SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WOULD
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTY EIGHT
VOTER THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATE VERY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB
SIXTY EIGHT. I STATE OPPOSITION
AB SIXTY I MEAN PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ZERO AT
THE STATE OPPOSITION SB. SIX
EIGHT. AND WE HAVE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS A RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. ARMINA HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COST OF SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. I ANNUALLY FOR THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. ESTIMATES THAT IT
WOULD WORK. WOULD RESULT IN
MINOR AND SEVERAL COSTS. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
I SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SIXTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB THREE
SIX TWO ALSO BY FAMILY MEMBER
WORKS SO- ON HOMELESS SHELTERS
SAFETY REGULATIONS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANADA OFFERS WAVE.
COMPANY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. DURING THE
PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MYERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX TWO. THE SHARES
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A LINE IN Q. AGAIN
IF ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE SUPPORT FOR AB THREE SIX
TWO YOU MAY ALSO PRESS ONE.
ZERO. ME JUST A MOMENT AS A
BROUGH. RECLAIMED OUR LINE
NUMBER TO THEM. BY NINETY ONE
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE FOR SEEMS TO BE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY HERE.
HELLO MY NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. HI
MY NAME IS ALYSSA WASHINGTON ON
BEHALF OF STRONGER WOMAN UNITED
AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NORTHERN LINE TO QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WELL GOOD OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE SIX TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM. WISHING TO SPEAK
THERE'S ONLY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB THREE SIX
TWO. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION AB
THREE SIX TO ME PROMISED ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
YEAH THAT'S ONE ZERO. FOUR
OPPOSITION THE AB. THREE SIX
TWO. AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD APARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF BOTH
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY ESTIMATED ANY
COSTS RESULTING FROM THIS BILL.
WOULD BE MINOR. TESTING
RESOURCES. WE KNOW THAT
ALTHOUGH- WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT THE ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
ARE REQUIRED IN THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE. THE BILL'S ANNUAL
REPORTING ACTIVITIES MAY CREATE
A MANDATE. BECAUSE REQUIRES A
NEW PROGRAM OUR HIGH LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. THANK YOU. RIGHT WE
HAVE TAKEN OUR TESTIMONY FROM
FINANCING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE SIX TWO WITH
A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB EIGHT
SIX FIVE ALSO BY QUICK SILVA
AND CHILD CARE SERVICES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CAN EIGHT AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NO MANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SIX FIVE. THE SHARES SUPPORT
FOR A BI EIGHT SIX FIVE MILLION
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO SURE SUPPORT.
HELLO FIRST ONLINE ONE NINETEEN
ONE ONE NINE ONE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NICOLE BROWN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE TEMA
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION BUT BONSER
AND IT'S FROM COURT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK FIVE THE BILL WILL
CONTINUE IN PERPETUITY
REIMBURSING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THE STATUS NOW. AS
THEY ARE CURRENTLY REIMBURSED.
IN THE BUDGET ACT THANK YOU.
BUT ONLINE ONE SEVENTIES. ONE
SEVEN SIX. GOOD MORNING I THINK
I THAT ON ON BEHALF OF CHILD
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATE CONTINUE
GOING STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE THANK YOU. NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WELL NOW THAT OPPOSITION OF
EIGHT SIX FIVE AND THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY ON IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT SIX FIVE.
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION AB EIGHT
SIX FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
THAT'S WHAT I'M AND THEN. ZERO
THERE ARE NO LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ESTIMATES ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO PAY
PROVIDERS AT THE MAXIMUM
CERTIFIED HOURS. AND KNOWS THE
SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT ACCOUNT
FOR THE INCREASED NUMBER OF
CHILD CARE SLOTS RESULTING FROM
FUNDING AUTHORIZED EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY ONE. THAT WAS ENACTED
THIS YEAR. ACOSTA REMOVE THE
AUTHORIZATION AUTHORIZATION FOR
A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO ALTER RATES FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDREN AND THE
CONDITION THAT CD IN THIS FIRST
VERIFY THIS GOVERNMENT CATION
BEFORE CONTRACTORS CAN REQUEST
DIRECT DEPOSIT SERVICES ARE
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB EIGHT SIX FIVE OR GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE A. B.
TEN SEVENTEEN ALSO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
PUBLIC RESTROOMS RIGHT TO
RESTROOM ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MOTORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN. SURE
SUPPORT A BI TEN SEVENTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN SEVENTEEN. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THE FAMILY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY DOLLARS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN SEVENTEEN.
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED. IT RESULT IN A
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE LIKELY AND
LOW TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND IT IMPOSES ON BUDGET
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR THANK
YOU. A CLEAR SIGNAL QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO MINIMUM
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY. SURE
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU KERN ON LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION AB
SEVENTY THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB. SEVENTY
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVENTY ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YOU HAVE A
FILE. YES MR CHER WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD-
CREATES NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH THEY WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
ADDITIONALLY FUTURE REVENUES TO
SUPPORT THIS FUNDER UNKNOWN IN
ME. HOUSE AND PRESSURES. BUT
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
INDICATES THE BILL RESULT IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS A FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. WHICH RESULTS IN
TOTAL START COST OF FOURTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
ONGOING COSTS OF FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS WILL BE
FINANCED BY REVENUES COLLECTED
FROM THE FEES AND PENALTY
ASSESSED. PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPEND. MOVING ON AB ONE OH
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
ON LICENSURE. VETERANS AND
MILITARY SPOUSES. THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE OH SEVEN. SURE SUPPORT FOR
AB ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES IN Q. OUR FIRST LINE
IS LINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
SYLVIA SO EACH SHOT ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE COUNTIES OF KERN AND HE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR. ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTRY'S YOUNG COURSES
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SANDY
GRIFFIN WE ARE DEFINITE SUPPORT.
LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO. YES
CHAINING ALL CO CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA DEPENDS COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE AND FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL EARHART
THERE AGAIN I AM A DOCTOR OF
ORIENTAL MEDICINE CERTIFIED IN
NEVADA AND THE MILITARY SPOUSE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
SEVEN. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH SEVEN
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWELVE FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THEM. ZERO WE
HAVE LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS CALL
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN SUPPORT
THIS IS FRAN PEACE DEAL
MILITARY LIAISON COUNCIL
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
ONE OH SEVEN THANK YOU. IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER LINES THAT
WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION A AB ONE
OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT FROM A
FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES COST APPROXIMATELY.
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ON GOING TO VERY SPECIAL
FUNDS TO INDIVIDUAL BOARDS TO
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. BERMAN ALSO ESTIMATES
ADDITIONAL COST OF TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO VERY
SPECIAL FUNDS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION SERVICES
TO MAKE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES. ARE THAT IMPLEMENT THE
NEW TEMPORARY LICENSE TYPES AND
UPDATE THE WEBSITES OF VARIOUS
PROGRAMS. ALL RIGHT SAY NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE OF
SEVEN GOES TO SUSPENSE AB THREE
EIGHT THREE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS SOME BEHAVIOR HEALTH
OLDER ADULTS IT'S A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION OF
ALL RIGHT TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR SUPPORT OF
THREE EIGHT THREE. SURE SUPPORT
FOR AB THREE EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN SUPPORT FOR A BI THREE
EIGHT THREE PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO LINES IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THREE EIGHT THREE.
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AND THERE ARE NO-LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MR CHER
NO FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE EIGHT THREE
GOES TO SUSPENSE AB SEVENTY TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
COASTAL ADAPTATIONS PROJECT
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
SEVENTY TWO. SURE SUPPORT FOR
AB SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY TWO IN A PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WOULD
OPPOSITION AB SEVENTY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY HERE ASSEMBLY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ONE
OPPOSED AB. SEVENTY TWO. THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. THIRTY ONE MARCH STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTY TWO
ONE NUMBER ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE AN ONLINE TO KEEP. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO PARMA FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE BILL
DOESN'T CURRENTLY IDENTIFIED
FUNDING SOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
INTERAGENCY EFFORT REQUIRED TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL HOWEVER ACCORDING TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN
CONSULTATION COSTS THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
RANGING FROM TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
DEPENDING ON THE AMOUNT TYPE
AND EXTENT OF COORDINATION
REQUIRED IN ADDITION AGENCY
ESTIMATES THAT COSTS WOULD
LIKELY BE IN. THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
TO REVIEW REGULATORY REVIEW AND
PERMITTING PROCESS HE'S FOR
COASTAL ADDED ADAPTATION
PROJECTS. RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM FINANCE REVENUE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVENTY
TWO GOES TO SUSPENSE AB ONE TEN
ALSO BY PETRIE-NORRIS ON
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
BENEFITS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
KATIC OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION
RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TEN. SURE SUPPORT FOR AB
ONE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN IT'S
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE TEN IN PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION AB ONE TEN NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO ONE TEN. STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TEN YOU
MAY ALSO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE ZERO THE STATE OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FILE
THIS YEAR- FILE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ONE TEN
GOES TO SUSPENSE TO BE TEN
FIFTY SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS ON
FIREARMS IT SAYS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WAY PRESENTATION WITH
ALL RIGHT TO TEST MONEY TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NO MANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN. SUPPORT AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN THIS PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. S. A.
B. TEN FIFTY SEVEN. WE HAVE AN
ONLINE THANK YOU ARE NOT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THIS COMING TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO TEN
FIFTY SEVEN. FOR OPPOSITION OF
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO THE STATE OPPOSITION. KERN
ONLINE SECURE AT THIS TIME
MISTER RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTELLO
THOUSANDS TO TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY TO PROCESS ADDITIONAL
FINGERPRINTS AND MAKE
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES TO ONE
FIREARMS DATABASE. WITH
ADDITIONALLY NOTE THE BILL
COULD INCREASE COSTS TO ENFORCE
AND PUNISH THE CRIME OF
VIOLATING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER WHICH IS
EITHER A FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'VE
HEARD FOR FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A
P. TEN FIFTY SEVEN GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. ON ALCOHOLISM AND
DRUG RECOVERY OR TREATMENT
FACILITIES THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS IS WAY
PRESENTATION- RIGHT TO SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO MANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT. EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. INDEX PRESS FOR AB ELEVEN
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NO PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR ONE FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I
AM SURE NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE OF THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD IT REQUIRES
CREATES NEW ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES COST OF SIX
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR IN FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
TWENTY FIVE AN ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WAS UNABLE TO IDENTIFY THE
DIRECT COST OF THIS BILL. BUT
KNOWS THE POSSIBILITY OF
DOWNSTREAM GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU KNOW QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB EIGHTY NINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER A
PEACE OFFICER'S MINIMUM COST OF
QUALIFICATIONS. THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOTHING TWENTY FORTY. FIVE OR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY
NINE. DESKSIDE SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
ALIGN NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THERE WAS AN
OPERATOR APPARENTLY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE NOW THEY'RE BACK WELL I
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T NEED TO NAY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY STATE
CONFERENCE PLEASE REPEAT POINTS
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER.
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTY NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
I'M IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB EIGHTY NINE. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THE COMMISSION
ON PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING OR POST ESTIMATES THE
NEED FOR APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONGOING TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT THE COMPONENTS OF
THIS PROGRAM. I WOULD NOTE THAT.
OPPOSE ALSO ANTICIPATES A
FISCAL IMPACT OF ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. TO DEVELOP THE
REQUIRED LIST OF BASIC
CERTIFICATION COURSES AND
ESTABLISH A MEDIA CAMPAIGN AS
WELL AS FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ANTICIPATES AN IMPACT OF
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING FOR THE ACADEMIC SENATE
AND FACULTY TO COLLABORATE WITH
POST ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COURSES TO INCLUDE AS
REQUIREMENTS. ADDITIONALLY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ANTICIPATES
ONGOING COST PRESSURES AFFECTED
ONE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO REPORT
POLICE OFFICER POLICE ACADEMY
STUDENTS WITH ASSOCIATES DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER INSTEAD OF A
CERTIFICATE OF ACHIEVEMENT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ANTICIPATE THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ONGOING SUPPORT INCREASING
ITS RECRUITMENT EFFORTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS RECREATION
ESTIMATES THE BILL COULD RESULT
IN COST UP TO ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND. TO PAY
DIFFERENTIALS FOR PEACE
OFFICERS SEVEN EIGHTY ASSOCIATE
OR BACHELOR'S DEGREE CONSISTENT
WITH EDUCATION STANDARDS SET
FORTH IN THE STILL. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
ANTICIPATE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING.
TO TRANSFER TRANSITION ITS
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING ACADEMY
THE POST CERTIFIED ACADEMY.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHTY
NINE WILL GO TOSUSPENSE.
MOVING ON EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE BY JONES SAWYER ON PEACE
OFFICERS. CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER IN EXPOSITION PARK IT'S
A SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
HOW MANY ROOMS TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ON ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT THREE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOUR EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WHATEVER NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUE
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO A PROPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
NOW BEING TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
OPPOSED. TO FOUR EIGHT THREE.
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NUMBER EVAN LOW
PARTICIPANTS Q. WHAT MISTER
KALRA DEPARTMENT FINANCE. YES
OF THE EXPOSITION PARK
MANAGEMENT ESTIMATES THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE ONE POINT EIGHT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COSTS AND- AN
ONGOING ANNUAL CONSTITUENCIES
TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. WE NOTE THAT THE
EXPOSITION PARK IMPROVEMENT
FUND IS STATURE LORD
STATUTORILY APPROPRIATE SOURCE
FOR THE EXPENDITURES REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL HOWEVER THE IMPACT
OF CODE NINETEEN ON PUBLIC
EVENTS HAS GREATLY REDUCED THE
FUND'S REVENUES IN THE CURRENT
BALANCE IS INSUFFICIENT TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL COST AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVE A GOOD FOR
FINANCING OF QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTY THREE
WITHOUT ASSISTANCE. EIGHTY FIVE
NINE NINE JONES SAWYER PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS IS
THIS CANDIDATE MR JONES FOR HIS
WAY PRESENTATION WITH ALL RIGHT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
TWENTY FORTY. WATER IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE NINE NINE.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
BOTH PROUD CO SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
LIVE NEXT IS LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AIRMAP THE
LEAD COUNSEL WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE OF THE PRODUCT CODE
BONTA AB FIVE NINETY NINE AND
MARK STRUCK THE PORT THANK YOU.
AMATEUR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING
UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION OF FIVE NINE NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED. SOMEBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO FIVE
NINE NINE. IT'LL SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR AB FIVE NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANT
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIRMAN ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. THE BILL CHANGES THE
CRITERIA FOR SCHOOLS IDENTIFIED
FOR WILLIAMS REVIEW WHICH COULD
RESULT IN NEW ACTIVITIES AND
ONGOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS TO CONDUCT REVIEWS. I
SHOULD THE COMMISSION ON STATE
MANDATES TO DETERMINE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
EXCEED REQUIREMENTS UNDER
EXISTING LAW IT'LL CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE. AND
NOT THAT ANY NEW REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE COSTS WOULD LIKELY BE
ADDED TO THE KEY THROUGH TWELVE
MANDATE BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY WE- SEVERAL
PROPOSITIONS NINETY EIGHT COSTS
JEFF DID THE CRITERIA FOR
SCHOOLS IDENTIFIED FOR WEIGH
INS REVIEW. TO INCLUDE SCHOOLS
IDENTIFIED FOR COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT AND IMPROVEMENT AND
ADDITIONAL TARGETED SUPPORT AND
IMPROVEMENT. LASTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES ONGOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS
APPROXIMATELY NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND WE ANTICIPATE
THESE COSTS WOULD BE OBSERVABLE
WITHIN EXISTING DEPARTMENTAL
RESOURCE. ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM FINANCE WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FIVE NINE NINE GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON A. B. SEVEN FIFTY BY
JONES SAWYER. ON CRIMES PERJURY
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE HE'S
WAY PRESENTATION- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
FIVE ZERO. TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI SEVEN FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. SURE SURE
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION. OF AB
SEVEN FIFTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ASSEMBLY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB SEVEN
FIFTY. US SHOW OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN FIFTY PLEASE PRAY. SKEWS
ME PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP THE
STRUCTURE ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
FINANCE. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL JUST
A MINUTE SEVERAL COST BILL. ADDITIONALLY
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION DEPARTMENT
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND
DEPARTMENT PARKS RECREATION
ALTON ON ANTICIPATED FISCAL
IMPACT WITH THE STILL. ALL
RIGHT REFERRED FOR FINANCE WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN FIFTY GOES
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THIS AB
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT JONES SAWYER
EMPLOYMENT HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IT'S A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAYPRESENTATION GOD
BLESS YOU. WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN FORTY TWO OH THREE-
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOT
ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A BI EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. JACARE NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS LOVELY
AND FUNNY FORTY MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED EIGHT. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY GEORGIA OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. AND WE
HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE- AND COST NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS INTO SPACE
COST OF THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
THREE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ON GROWING FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
FUND. DEPLOYMENT THE ANTI
RETALIATION PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH OPERATES ACUTE
CARE HOSPITALS DID NOT PROVIDE
A FISCAL IMPACT ASSESSMENT FOR
THE SPELL. ALAS THEY WOULD KNOW
THAT THE BILL COULD LEAD TO
COST PRESSURES LOCAL IMPACT
HOSPITALS RESULTING FROM
INCREASED TIME TOIMPLEMENT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND POTENTIAL
LITIGATION. R. I. C. NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO AB ONE OH
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
ON GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
ETHNIC STUDIES. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF.
AB ONE OH ONE. SHOWS FOR AB ONE
OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO LIVE SIXTY ONE WE THOUGHT
THAT. CAN A CHECK FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR OPEN. I NEEDED
ONE PLEASE UNTIL. FINAL OUT
PATERNITY- TO SHOW SUPPORT LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. OKAY I
WASN'T SURE ABOUT THE NUMBER-
HI MY NAME IS JOBS AND GOOD
THOUGHT I NEEDED BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE CAN
OPERATE ME COLLEGE AND WE
STRONGLY THE COR AB ONE OH ONE
THANK YOU. AND LINE ONE FIFTY
NINE YOU ARE OPEN. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE BILL GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS LANDMARK MEASURE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AMATEUR WE
ARE BY NO OTHER PART WHAT SKEWS
ME WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. MISTER CHAIRMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS HANNAH QUICKLY AND I'M
REPRESENTING PROJECT HE'LL
WHICH IS NATIONAL. EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION WE URGE YOU TO
PLEASE THE AFFIRMATIVE ON THE
BALLOT THANK YOU. AMATEUR NO
ONE ELSE'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
BUT I DO KNOW WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY SPEAKERS ON THE QUEUE.
ARE THEY THERE LAURIE MYERS AND
RICHARD SANDER. YES I'M HERE
ALL RIGHT BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU GOT THREE MINUTES. OKAY
I'LL GO FIRST- MY NAME IS
RICHARD CENTER I'M A PROFESSOR
OF LAW AT UCLA AND ECONOMISTS.
I'M ALSO A PHONE NUMBER CRAFTED
THE FATHER OF A NINTH GRADER AT
JOHN MARSHALL HIGH SCHOOL. BUT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE FOUR POINTS
BUT IF YOU WANT TO ONE. A FIRST
I THINK THE- BUT YOU KNOW SUS
IS VERY GOOD AT- IT PROVIDES A
REALISTIC ESTIMATE OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX BILLION
ANGLE COSTS. WHICH IS AN ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE HIGHER THAN THE
COST ESTIMATED IN THE ASSEMBLY
REPORT- THIS IS A OBVIOUSLY A
VERY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT THAT'S
GOING TO INVOLVE REAL TRADE
OFFS AND CHOICES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ALSO SOMEWHAT
PERVERSE BECAUSE MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL FUNDS THIS YEAR AND-
AND THEY ARE BEING ENCOURAGED
OF THOSE FEDERAL MANDATES TO
EXPLORE COURSES LIKE ETHNIC
STUDIES. SO THIS BILL SHIPS. OF
SORT OF A FEDERAL FISCAL
OPPORTUNITY INTO A STATE
ONGOING RESPONSIBILITY. WE ALSO
NEED TO LOOK AT THE- THE
BENEFITS COMING FROM THOSE
COSTS AND- OVER A HUNDRED
SCHOLARS HAVE SUBMITTED THE
LETTER WHICH AFFORDED TO STAFF
ABOUT THE- THE EFFECTIVENESSOF
THIS CURRICULUM AND THEIR
COLLUSION IS THAT- THE
EFFECTIVENESS IS NOT BEEN
SHOWN. SO I THINK THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS FOR THE SOCIAL
WORK. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT DO
WE HAVE MS MYERS. YES THANK YOU
I'M LAURIE MYERS AT EDUCATORS
FOR QUALITY INEQUALITY A LARGE
GRASSROOTS GROUP OF CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS WE ASK THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
REPORT OF EDUCATION GET THE
BEST PRACTICES FOR CURRICULUM
ADOPTION YOU START WITH MANY
NOW TO A FEW SELECT ONE WITH A
FOCUS ON TRANSPARENCY. RIGHT
NOW WE CAN'T FOLLOW THESE BEST
PRACTICES THERE WAS ONLY ONE
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM BEING
MARKETED TOWARD DISTRICT AND
ONE PRODUCT IF NOT MAKE FOR
COMPETITIVE PRICING OR QUALITY.
WHAT'S WORSE IS THAT THE ONE
CURRICULUM IS BASED ON THE
REJECTED FIRST DRAFT OF THE
ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM
THE ONE THAT GOVERNOR NUISANCE
THAT WOULD NEVER SEE THE LIGHT
OF DAY. THE ONE ABOUT WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
SENATOR PORTANTINO BOTH
EXPRESSED THE CONCERNS. THIS
QUICKIE WON ADVOCATE AGAINST
TRANSPARENCY LITERALLY TELLING
TEACHERS TO QUOTE FLY UNDER THE
RADAR EACH THEIR OWN POLITICAL
AGENDAS AND AVOID OVERSIGHT.
FOR A QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS
IS THAT WHAT WE WANT. OUR
ETHNIC STUDIES LIKE IF YOU
COULD BE. AB ONE OH ONE MANDATE
SCHOOLS ETHNIC INTO TWENTY. IF
YOU JUST HAVE ALREADY ENGAGED
THE KOCH. GROP IN. HAYWARD IN
SENATOR WEEK HEALTH NEEDS OWN
DISTRICT. LEADERS HAVE
CONTRACTED TO PAY THIS GROUP
CONSULTANT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN LACK OF OPTIONS
ALLOW PRICE GOUGING. THEY ARE
QUITE DISTRICT WINTER USE YES
STUDIES MODEL CORRECT WELL. YOU
CAN CAME THREE BUT IF SOMEONE
NOT A CURRICULA. DISTRICT THE
ONLY TO TURN IT INTO A
TEACHABLE CURRICULUM BUT MANY
ESPECIALLY WORLD DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO CREATE FOR OUR
STUDENTS GIVE COMPANY BUILDING
AT THE COMPANY'S CURRICULUM
SOME FOR FREE TRYING TO
COMPLETE THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS TO OUR DISTRICT. HAS
MANY TO CHOOSE FROM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE OPPOSED STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO A.
B. ONE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE AB THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR MEMBERS. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE A ONE EIGHT
ZERO. ONE NINE ONE NINETY-
SKEWS ME THERE WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE GOT A FEW
WITH AN OPERATOR ACTUALLY
MISTER CHAIR. PLEASE BEAR WITH
US FOR A SECOND HERE. BY ONE
NINETY YOU ARE OPEN. I TELL YOU
ARE VOLATILE CAPITAL REPORT.
THE ONE ON. ONE FIND ONE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF
LEVINE AND I LIVE IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY I'M LOOKING WITH A
LARGE GRASSROOTS. OF ALL
DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHAT OPPOSED AB ONE
ONE A ONE BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
PROFIT. THANK YOU. OE ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. ROSS
CONVENTION DIRECTOR OF ALL
KINDS AND COORDINATOR OF A
COALITION OF SIXTY CIVIL RIGHTS
AND EDUCATION ORGANIZATIONS. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE A NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO FORMER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS IT COULD
CREATE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS. MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL ARE DETERMINED TO BE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. BUT
ALSO NOTE THAT WHILE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES
SEVERAL SIGNIFICANT INITIATIVES
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THE
CODE NINETEEN IMPACT PANDEMIC.
AND HELP SCHOOLS BETTER SUPPORT
MULTIPLE STUDENTS. AND ENDEMIC
IS NEGATIVELY IMPACTED THE
ABILITY OF MANY STUDENTS TO
MEET EXISTING MINIMUM
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. AND
FURTHER INCREASING HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS WILL
CREATE SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AT A TIME WHEN
SCHOOLS ARE UNDERGOING A- ANY
CHANGES. TO ASSIST STUDENTS AS
THEY RETURN TO FULL TIME IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE OH ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. AB NINETY SEVEN
MEDINA PUBLIC PUBLIC
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. WE WILL
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION AND WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI NINE TWO SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL GO LINE NINETY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUST HARD TO TALK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
JARVAN FOR THE BY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE KIM SENATE THE
CONCRETE ME COLLEGES AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GOING- GOOD AFTER MANY
HERE REPRESENTING OF THE-
COMMITTEE COLLEGES VERY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTISAN QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITE OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY TO FOUR TWENTY ONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB NINE
TWENTY SEVEN. SHOP ADDITION AB
NINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NOBODY'S GOING UP
THIS TIME MISTER ALL RIGHT
FORMER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL BUT NO CONCERNS
REGARDING THE ON GOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
MEASURE. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE INDICATES THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHOOSING TO OFFER
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES COULD
FACE LOCAL COST PRESSURES.
BECAUSE OF COSTS INCURRED TO
OFFER AND SUPPORT THESE
PROGRAMS THAT WE- ORANGE
DISTRICTS AWARDING THESE
DEGREES THEY RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
STUDENT FEE REVENUE THAT MAY
OFFSET THOSE COSTS. IN ADDITION
DISTRICTS PROVIDED A PORTION
AND FUNDING AND STUDENT CENTER
FUNDING FORMULA FOR STUDENTS
AWARDED ABOUT GLORIA DEGREES AT
THE SAME RATE AS FOR STUDENTS
AWARDED ASSOCIATE DEGREES. WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED TO
DISTRICTS AWARDING DEGREESTO
STUDENTS RECEIVING A PELL GRANT
WORTH FEE WAIVER. THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
STATE OPERATIONAL COST OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. AT THE STUDENTS
ENROLLING IN THESE DEGREE
PROGRAMS QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL
AID NDER UNDER THE STATE'S CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS. WE WERE NOT THE
BILL COULD INCREASE NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
STUDENTS WOULD OTHERWISE
ATTENDED A DEGREE PROGRAMS AT
AN INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
TUITION FEES. THEREFORE
RECEIVING HIGHER CAL GRANT
AWARDS THIS BILL COULD RESULT
IN NOT PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. SAVINGS TO THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. ARE RIGHT
REGARD FROM FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN GO SISI'S
FAST. MOVING ON TO AB. ONE
TWENTY FOUR BY NOW SENATOR
KAMLAGER ON CRIMINAL PROCEDURES
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PRESENTATION
OR PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE TWENTY FOUR. TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AB- WE
HAVE SOMEBODY IN THE ROOM HERE
SIR HOLD ON. ELICITED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS GUY HIS IMPAIR SONOMA
LEGISLATIVE SPEAKER
REPRESENTING CLUBS TRIED. ON
BEHALF OF MY TEAMMATES WHO
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T BE HERE BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD TO ADVOCATE FOR AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR. TODAY I STAND
BEFORE YOU IN DEEP ADVOCACY OF
AB ONE THREE FOUR. WHOSE GOALS
ARE TO SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALONG WITH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THE BILL
MEET THESE GOALS BY PROVIDING
TRAUMA INFORMED CHARGING.
SENTENCING AND RESENTENCING
RELIEF AS WELL AS TRIAL
ADVOCACY CONSIDERATIONS. BUT
THIS BILL REQUIRES MONEY AS
WELL AS RESOURCES. THIS WOULD
ALLOW FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO PUT
THESE RESOURCES INTO THE
SPIRITS COMMUNITIES. THAT NEED
IT THE MOST. I WOULD LIKE TO
QUICKLY SHARE STORY ABOUT
SYRACUSE AND- HE WAS HUMAN
TRAFFICKED AT THE AGE OF ELEVEN
YEARS OLD. IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
SYRACUSE AND WAS CONVICTED OF
THE FIRST DEGREE MURDER OF
GEORGE GEORGE HOWARD GILBERT.
WHO GROOMED HER INTO THE SEX
INDUSTRY AT A VERY YOUNG AGE.
SHE WHOSE ONLY A CHILD WAS
VILIFIED AS A MURDERER. IT WAS
NOT UNTIL THE PUBLIC APPEAL FOR
CLEMENCY IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
THAT HER CASE IS RE EVALUATED
AND SHE WAS SET FREE AT THE AGE
OF THIRTY FIVE. OTHER RESEARCH
HAS BEEN AVAILABLE FOR HER
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT AND TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION FOR THESE
VICTIMS. SANTA CRUZ AND MAY
HAVE NEVER LANDED IN PRISON.
AND FOR THESE REASONS I
STRONGLY FROM THE PASSING OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY FOUR.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS MONEY SO JUDGES
CAN IDENTIFY VICTIMS OF ABUSE
SO THAT THEY DON'T GET STUCK IN
THE SYSTEM. WE SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE TWO FOUR. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB ONE TWO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A NINETY TWO YEAR OPEN.
TEN YEARS GOOD AFTERNOON. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME. I DON'T HAVE.
DONNA THATCHER BEGINNING A LOT
CANDLE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO OH ONE EUROPE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH JOURNALING THREE
PUTTING ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS ALL IN
SUPPORT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND ALSO THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER
OF THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
FOR WOMEN ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU AND
WE WILL LINE TWO HUNDRED YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IS THE PART THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP MISTER
CHAIR. ALL RIGHT WILL NOT
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR. SEE NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
KNOW ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE.
IN A POP OPPOSITION ONE TWENTY
FOUR. CHAU OPPOSITION. AB ONE
TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND ONE MOMENT. AND WITH AN
OPERATOR. EVERYBODY ELSE GOING
AT ONE ZERO. M. LINE FOURTEEN
YOUR OPEN. THANK. FOURTEEN
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY LEVER WITH
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S IN
Q. ALL RIGHT- MISTER OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU HAVE
A FILE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST BETWEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WORKLOAD TO
DISPEL. THE DIGITAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATES THE BILL WOULD CREATE
ANNUAL WORKLOAD COST BETWEEN
600-100-0800 THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. THREE
SENTENCING. AND WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE A FISCAL ESTIMATE. WE
BELIEVE IT MAY RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS DUE TO
REDUCTIONS IN THE TOTAL TERM
SERVED BY INDIVIDUALS REFERRED
PURSUANT TO THIS BILL. LASTLY
THE BILL COULD REDUCE STATE AND
LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE RELATED
COSTS AS REQUIRES COURTS TO
SENTENCE. TO SENTENCE A RECENT
DIVISIONAL STROLL OR TERM
INTERMENTS INDIVIDUALS TO
PETITION A COURT TO HAVE THEIR
RESCUE COMMISSION SET ASIDE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM FINANCE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE TWO FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB
THREE THREE THREE ALSO BY
SENATOR KAMLAGER. PARTICIPATION
IN CRIMINAL STREET GANG
ENHANCED. TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB THREE THREE THREE. SHE ALSO
FOR A THREE THREE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP MR
TRUMP'S SKEWS ME. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF THIS RIGHT NW AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS MADELINE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO ONE SECOND PLEASE ONE ONE
SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MELISSA CARLSON AND I'M
IN SUPPORT. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION IS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THIS
COMPANY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
THREE THREE THREE. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THREE THREE
THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FOURTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
HI THIS SEVEN LAMBERT
REPRESENTING CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. M.
LINE TWO HUNDRED TEN YOU ARE
OPEN. TWO TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS PATRICK OF BRAZIL
THE GENERAL COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
TO EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE. I
AND THERE IS ONE MORE WITH AN
OPERATOR. PLEASE BEAR WITH US
FROM ONE MOMENT. WHAT EIGHT AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO. AT FINE. ONE
SIXTY TO YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE SIX TWO. THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. ONE SIXTY
TWO IF YOU DID THAT ON PURPOSE.
WE ARE IF YOU DIDN'T DO THAT ON
PURPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN. YOU
MIGHT IS IT ONE ZERO AGAIN. AND
THEY ARE NOT RE QUEUEING
RESEARCHER. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURES THAT WILL RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
PRESSURES ON THE PORCH JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ESTIMATES COST OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
BIFURCATING RELATED TRIAL COURT
PROCEEDINGS INTO TWO PHASES
CONSISTENT WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL. TO
THE EXTENT THE BILL RESULT IN
MORE TARGETED ACT APPLICATION
OF GANG ENHANCEMENTS AND LEADS
TO A REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS. SEN WHEN THE
LENGTH OF THEIR TERMS THE BILL
COULD RESULT IN SOME LEVEL OF
COST SAVINGS. FOR COUNTIES AND
STATE THE MAGNITUDE OF ANY
POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS IS
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE
THREE THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AB THREE
THREE SIX NINE MY CENTER COLUMN
WATER. MEDIC CAL SERVICES THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION. WITH A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIX NINE.
SO SUPPORT FOR AB THREE SIX
NINE. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN THIS
IS KINDA CHECK CALLING FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN TWO ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONLY A
GOOD THING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
ONE TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
THANKS REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIX NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ON MY TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR YOU ARE UP.
BUSH CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS PAUL
YOUR ME OUT OF THE KERN COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AMATEUR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS
NOW BEING TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO THREE SIX NINE.
YOUR POSTER AB THREE SIX NINE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS GOING UP THE
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT FROM THE
FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES COST OF
FORTY POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TWENTY POINT SEVEN
MILLION OF WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND FORTY SIX POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS AFTER WHICH
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
THEREAFTER. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE SIX NINE GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AB TWO EIGHTEEN.
CHANGE OF GENDER AND SEX
IDENTIFYING. IT'S BY SOME
REMEMBER WARD- TO SUSPEND
CANDIDATE HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. BUT A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
EIGHTEEN. SUPPORT FOR AB TWO
EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. BY ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARTIN RADAKOVICH ON
BEHALF OF MAY ROUTE PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT-
OTHER PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUED
UP MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB TWO
EIGHTEEN. THAT'S ONE ZERO. IF
YOUR POST AB. TWO EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND NOBODY OF
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. IF YOU WERE NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL BUT NO CONCERNS AT
THE POTENTIAL FOR INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF COURT SERVICES
RESULTING FROM A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN CASELOAD- INCREASE
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL INDICATES THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE HOW
MANY CASES WOULD ARISE RELATING
TO THIS BILL BUT DO NOTE
SIGNIFICANT DEPARTMENTAL STAFF
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
DEVELOPING AND PROCESSING THE
RULES OF COURT AND REQUIRED
FARMS TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TO A TEAM WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO A. TWO TO THREE ON
WILDLIFE- TAKING A POSSESSION-
THIS IS A- SUSPENSE CAN IT
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN. FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TO THREE. EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
TWO TO THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OUT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER FERRIN
OFFERING SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDEN
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMING TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWO TO THREE. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR TWO TO THREE.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT
EFFICIENT ONE LIFEESTIMATE NO
COST FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL AS THE DEPARTMENT
ALREADY CONDUCTS AND THIS TYPE
OF ENFORCEMENT I WOULD KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT AND MADE TEN CASES
THAT HAVE GONE TO PROSECUTION
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS. AND
PENALTY REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON
THE NUMBER AND VALUE OF THE
ENFORCEMENT CASES THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWO TO THREE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB FIVE HUNDRED BY
MISTER WARD AS WELL. LOCAL
PLANNING COSTA DEVELOPMENT
PORTABLE HOUSING IT'S A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION WITH A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COMING TWENTY
FORTY. TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
HUNDRED. SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
FIVE HUNDRED ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALBANY IS
QUEUING UP. OUR ORDER
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB FIVE HUNDRED. CHAU
OPPOSITION AB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NO ONE IS QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO- BERMAN
FINANCE. CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION ESTIMATES COST
BETWEEN FIFTY THOUSAND AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH PRODUCING A
REPORT. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE HUNDRED WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO MISTER
DALY AB TWO TO FOUR DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS BUREAU
HOUSING GOODS AND SERVICES.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION OF A
PUBLICCOMMENT THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO BEING
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO FOUR.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A B. TWO TWO
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FELL BY. ZERO
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR I REMOTE
OPPOSITION IS NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. FULL IF YOU'RE OPPOSED
TO AB TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
GIVING UP ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE
AS IT WILL INCREASE ONGOING
COST PRESSURES ON HOUSEHOLD
WOULD RESPOND AND ADDS COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES ONGOING COSTS OF FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE HOUSEHOLD
RESPOND. ESTIMATES ANNUAL
REVENUE LOST TO THE FUND
RANGING FROM TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AS A RESULT OF A
REDUCTION TO BOTH PERMITS
ISSUED AND CITATIONS
TRANSPORTERS THAT WOULD NO
LONGER NEED TO BE PERMITTED.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO TO
FOREGO SUSPENSE AB SEVENTY ONES
MR DAILY ON FLOOD CONTROL
PROJECTS. DISPENSED KENNEDY'S
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING IS NOBODY HERE.
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB SEVENTY ONE. EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SEVEN EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND ONE MOMENT THERE'S ONE
WITH AN OPERATOR MISTER CHAIR.
AT ONE THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
SHOP ONE THIRTEEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY THE NEAREST. HI
OTHERS NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
GEARED UP I WOULD OPPOSITION OF
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN EIGHTY ONE.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SEVEN
EIGHTY ONE. PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE THANK
YOU WE WOULD NOTE THAT
HISTORICALLY SUBVENTION FUNDING
HAS BEEN PROVIDED THROUGH
EXISTING BOND FUNDS SUCH AS
PROPOSITION ONE IAN OXYGENATED
FOR HOWEVER PROPOSITIONS
HOWEVER BOND FUNDING HAS NEARLY
BEEN EXHAUSTED FOR EXISTING
OPERATE PROJECTS IN ADDITION OF
MORE PROJECTS TO THE
ELIGIBILITY LIST WILL LIKELY
REQUIRE GENERAL FUND. THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ESTIMATES FUNDING CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED PROJECTS REQUIRE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
ALL RIGHTY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SEVEN ANYONE GOES THE
SUSPENSE MAYBE FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE DALY ON HOUSING PROGRAMS
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING. THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE HE'S WAY
TWELVE AND A PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SO MANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE ONLINE
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR OPEN. AS OF MARCH
THE IRISH OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
AND NO ONE ELSE IS GOING ON I
WOULD OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE. CHAU OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS GOING UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES A GENERAL
FUND COST OF FIVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TREATING YOU FINANCING SYSTEM
AND PROCESS OUTSIDE. FINANCING
STRUCTURE I WOULD KNOW THAT ANY
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE SUBJECT TO REVIEW
AND APPROVAL FOR THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
GOES TO SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY BY DALY ON DISTANCE
LEARNING IT'S A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE
YOU HERE FOR THIS SERVICE-
AHEAD. AFTERNOONS CHAIR CENTER
BATES BURNING OROZCO CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF AB FIFTEEN SIXTY A GREAT
SOLUTION TO GET KIDS CONNECTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO ONE
ELSE HERE WE'RE GOING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. MODERATOR ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SIXTY.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI FIFTEEN
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WOULD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
BUT COME ON HURRY UP. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTANTINO THIS BURKE
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE SYMMETRIC. INTERNET SERVICE
HUNTER MEGABITS UP AND DOWN IS
WHAT IS NEEDED FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING NOTHING SHORT OF THAT
WIRELESS CAN'T DO IT BUT FTTP
AND CABLE COMPANIES CAN WE NEED
TO LET THEM DO IT THANK YOU WE
OPPOSE THE BILL ALL RIGHT. NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN SIXTY.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WELL THE BILL IS
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COSTS OF UP TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND I WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO UPDATE CAL PASSED
TO COLLECT THE DATA REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL. ADDITIONALLY THE
APARTMENT ESTIMATES UP TO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR STAFF AND
OTHER RELATED COSTS TO COLLECT
AND MANAGE THE DATA REQUIRED BY
THE STILL. FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES ONGOING
COST PRESSURES OF AN
ANNOUNCEMENT. IN AMOUNTS TO
PROVIDE COMPUTING DEVICES TO
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE'S. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ESTIMATES ONGOING COST OF SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND TO MANAGE TO
PROPOSE PROGRAM AND AS
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL COSTS MAY
BE INCURRED DEPENDING ON THE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPATING FAMILIES. LASTLY
THE BILL COULD ALSO CREATE AN
ONGOING REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATES AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN SIXTY GOES
TO SUSPEND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS AB TWO TWO SIX CHILDREN'S
CRISIS PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT IT IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IS I MEAN
TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TWO TO SIX.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR TWO TWO
SIX ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND ONE MORE MISTER
CHAIRS WE HAVE A COUPLE WITH
OPERATORS. TWO ONE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO NINE YOUR CAN YOU
THERE'S. TWO ONE NINE. WHEN I
WANNA GET OUT. GO AHEAD GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES KRAUZE SPONSOR AND
INTO COURT THANK YOU. AND
EXCELLING GROWING ONE EIGHTY
NINE. MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S REBECCA
COOPER I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF OUR LOS ANGELES CHILD HELD
CAPTIVE ON HERE AND WE HAVE
OTHER VOLUNTEERS CALLING IN AS
WELL. RIGHT THERE IS IN THE
CURRENT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND IN FACT WE HAVE MORE IN
THIS STATE THAN ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY SO ON BEHALF OF
OUR VOLUNTEERS AND OUR BOARD
MEMBERS AND SO LONG THIRD
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWO TWENTY
SIX AND IN ADDITION TO ADD
ANOTHER VOLUNTEER TO BE HEARING
FROM YOU HAVE A LTTER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN FROM MY CONSTITUENTS.
MY FIFTEEN YOU ARE ALL. THIS IS
KERRY AND BERYL HINES CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THIS TO DEL MAR
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO SIX. NO ONE ELSE WAS QUEUED
UP THIS TIME MISTER SHERMAN
ROAD OPPOSITION AB TWO TWO SIX
OR SOMEBODY IN THIS ROOM IS NOW
BEING TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. AND LINE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN YOUR OPEN. NINE TO
SEVENTEEN. HI THIS IS JENNY
REXRODE FROM CALIFORNIA LINE
THE CARE GIVERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOBODY ELSE WAS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION TO TWO TO SIX
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWO TWO
SIX. YOU ARE POSTED AB TWO TWO
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE WON WITH AN
OPERATOR.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE- NINETEEN ONE TO NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOBBLING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WANT ONE
MORE IS WITH AN OPERATOR.
SECOND PLEASE. GO TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS PATRICIA EDWARDS AND I
MISSED MY OPPORTUNITY JUST TO.
A VOICE MY SUPPORT SO I'M GOING
TO DO THAT NOW I'M A NATIONAL
BOARD MEMBER VOLUNTEER FOR
CHILD HELP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWO TWO SIX. MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOU HAVE A LETTER OF SUPPORT
SENT TO YOU ENTERED BATES IN
YOUR OFFICE NUMBER FIVE ON
TEARS THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
I'M FROM CENTER DEBATE WILL
LOOK AT YOUR LETTER THANK YOU.
NEXT PERSON. THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QW JOHN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION RIGHT. YEAH ALL
RIGHT FINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE ANTICIPATE THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN THE ANNUAL COST
OF TWO MILLION DOLLARS HALF OF
WHICH WOULD BE GENERAL FUND TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ADDITIONALLY THE
PARTNER SOCIAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES ARE NOT GENERAL FUND
COSTS LIKELY IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TRACK
PLACEMENTS MANY FACILITY TYPE.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO TWO
SIX COSTA SUSPENSE AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE RAMOS CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES INDIAN TRIBES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC COMMENT A. B.
FIND ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY AROUND TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI EIGHT SEVEN THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
EIGHT SEVEN THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IS CLOSED.
PAN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOUR AB. EIGHT
SEVEN THREE. NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR R. I.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU WE ESTIMATE COST OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION OF WHICH WOULD BE
GENERAL FUND ONGOING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. ADDITIONALLY
ELIMINATING THE TRIBAL SHARE OF
COSTS FOR INDIAN TRIBES
ORGANIZATIONS EXTORTIONS I
WOULD RESULT IN COST OF ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY BASED ON
THE EXISTING BUDGET
METHODOLOGY. LASTLY THE BILL
RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES NINE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO COVER
TRIBAL ATTORNEY FEES AND YOU
TALK ABOUT FACT SHE SAYS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE GOES TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON A. B. NINE FOUR FIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ON
PEOPLE'S ADORNMENTS AT SCHOOL
GRADUATIONS. THIS IS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FOUR FIVE. YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB NINE FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
NINE FOUR FIVE NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION THE NINE FOUR FIVE.
SHOP ADDITION FOR NINE FOUR
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOBODY'S CUED UP ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ESTIMATES THE BILL COULD CREATE
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS NOT. IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS ANNUALLY FOR TWO YEARS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHINO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. NINE FOUR FIVE GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB TEN FIVE FIVE.
RAMOS ON FOR FOSTER YOUTH TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S SOMEBODY HERE.
WITH A TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE SIR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FIFTY FIVE. YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
STAR FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILED BY ZERO SKEWS ME ONE FALL
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF TEN FIVE FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
IS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TEN FIFTY FIVE. YOUR
OPPOSED TO TEN FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU WE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE BUT
DO NO CONCERNS THAT THE- OKAY
CHAPTER OUT RECENTLY ENACTED
LANGUAGE REFLECTED IN THE
EDUCATION OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY. ADDITIONALLY
JUST BILL COULD CREATE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED AS FOSTER
USE. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN FIFTY FIVE
ABOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE EIGHT
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY RAMOS.
CALIFORNIA DOES DESERT
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE. WILL MOVE TO TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THEIR MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. SUPPORT OF.
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. SURE I WAS
IN MY MUTED THERE FOR SECOND TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUED
UP I OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE.
IF YOUR POST ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOBODY IS KILLING UP
ALL RIGHT FINANCE. WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD ESTIMATES
COST OF FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ON GOING TO MAKE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD
ANNOUNCED NEED FOR ANNUAL
FUNDING. TO VISION- BY THIS
BILL AND ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS WHICH CREATES
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE. ALL RIGHT
SENIOR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
GOES TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THE
TWO SIXTY BY MR STONE. ON
GUARDIANSHIPS IT'S A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION-
SEEING NO ONE HERE AND FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SIX ZERO.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWO SIX
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY WHAT ONE
ONE IS KEEPING UP WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
BILL WITH US ONE SECOND MISTER
CHAIRMAN. BY TWO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WALTER FROM
LINCOLN FAMILIES BUT PROVIDE
PREVENTATIVE SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT DISRUPT THANK OF THE
POVERTY AND TRAUMA IN ALAMEDA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY ALLEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE OVER
THREE HUNDRED RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS WE SERVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY TWO SIXTY
THANK YOU. AND NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
TWO SIXTY. THE SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR TWO SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S
GIVING UP THE STRUCTURE ALL
RIGHT FINANCE THANK YOU WE
ANTICIPATE A GENERAL FUND COSTS
IN THE LOW TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE FUNDED
CAN GAP. ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE UNKNOWN COSTS TO
DSS TO MAKE NECESSARY
AUTOMATION CHANGES WHICH LIKELY
COULD NOT BE COMPLETED UNTIL
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY THREE WHICH
WILL RESULT IN THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
POTENTIALLY IN THE LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. TO PERFORM MANUAL
WORKAROUNDS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT FINANCES DONE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. TWO SIXTY COAST TO SUSPENSE
AB TWO TWO NINE TWO STONE
CORRECTIONS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE NOBODY IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN MODERATES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT. OF TWO NINE TWO. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF TWO NINE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
TO KILL YOU'D LIKE TO REACH YOU
AT PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THEY'RE
NOT RE QUEUEING. ALL RIGHT
RENTALS OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TWO NINE TWO. YOUR
OPPOSED TO TWO NINE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. NOBODY AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHARLES BERMAN
FINANCE. DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
ESTIMATES THE FISCAL IMPACTS OF
THIS BILL ARE UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT BOTH
COSTS AND SAVINGS THE ESTIMATED
STASHING NEW PROCEDURES
ENTITLEMENTS PROTECTIONS WOULD
LIKELY REQUIRE A COST IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY. AS WELL
AS A SIGNIFICANT COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
CUSTODY SUPPORT FOR EXPANDED
PROGRAMS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADDITIONALLY THEY ANTICIPATE
OFFSETTING SAVINGS DUE TO THE
EARLY RELEASE OF SOME
INCARCERATED PERSONS ARE DUE TO
THE INCREASING CREDIT RATING
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT IS UNABLE TO
ESTIMATE THE IMPACT OF THIS
CHANGE. BERMAN OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS. THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE LEGAL
SERVICES REVOLVING FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB TWO NINE
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ONTO AB THREE FIFTEEN BY STONE
VOLUNTARY STREAM RESTORATION
PROPERTY OR LIABILITY TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE. NOBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THREE FIFTEEN. YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FIFTEEN
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I'M ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRIAN SIXTY FOR YOUR
OPEN. ARE YOU MUTED. NOBODY
ELSE IS QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT OVER
OPPOSITION'S THREE FIFTEEN NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM NUMBER IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. IF YOUR
POST AB THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
HAVE NOBODY QUEUING UP OUR
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND TO KEEP THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN A POTENTIALLY STICK. AFTER
THE STATE THROUGH INCREASED
FINANCIAL LIABILITY FROM ANY
CLAIMS OR LITIGATION MAY ARISE
AS A RESULT OF INDEMNIFY
LANDOWNERS. THAT VOLUNTARILY
PROVIDE LAND FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE HABITAT PROJECTS. ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THREE FIFTEEN. GO TO
SUSPEND THIRTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
STONE PRIVATE STUDENT LOAN.
COLLECTIONS REFORM ACT TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE. THE
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO FOUR TWO FOUR. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB FOUR TO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE FIFTY THREE
YOU ARE OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON IN DANIELLE CANDLE
CUTTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. AND
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP MR
TIME ABOUT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. THE
FOUR TWO FOUR. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO FOUR TO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE ONE RESTAURANT
GREATER. THE RAILS PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NON THE QUICKNESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION AND WE
THINK THE AUTHOR. PARKER FOR
THE CONVERSATION GLACIATIONS
THE POP UP BAR. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT IN ORDER TO FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE
IT CREATES COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION ESTIMATES
COST OF TWO HUNDRED THIRTY. THE
FINANCIAL PROTECTION FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
HUNDRED NINETY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING. ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A BEFORE TWO FOUR
GOES TO SUSPENSE. COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY IS FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX SUPERIOR COURT. BUT TATIAN
ROOMS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX. YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. ONE
MORE CHANCE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
YOU LIKE GO AHEAD. YES RIGHT
SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN DISTRICT NINE
IT SUPPORT. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT OVER OPPOSITION- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO
MEAN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX. YOUR POST
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS GOING UP. ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. DO YOU COUNCIL
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST BETWEEN
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
MODIFY EXISTING FACILITIES TO
ALLOW ATTORNEYS AND OTHER
OFFICERS OF THE COURT TO ACCESS
LACTATION ROOMS ADDITIONALLY
THE JUST COUNCIL ESTIMATES ONE
TIME COSTS FOR CURRENT AND
FUTURE TRIAL COURT CONSTRUCTION
TOTAL. I AM DOLLARS OVER THE
FIRST TWO YEARS AND ONE TO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THEREAFTER.
WOULD KNOW THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S ESTIMATE IS BASED ON
A CONSERVATIVE ASSUMPTION
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND 30% OF
THE EXISTING CORPUSCLE EASTWOOD
NEED MODIFICATION. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FIFTY SEVENTY SIX
COSTA SUSPENSE AB TWO SIX TWO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S HOW MANY
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWO
SIX TWO. YOUR SUPPORT OF TWO
SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OUR
OVERALL POSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY AND ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWO SIX
TWO. YOUR POSTED TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
PUBLISHED QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE-
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE IS
INCREASE WORKLOAD FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS. THAT MAY NOT BE
OBSERVABLE AS WELL AS GENERAL
FUND COST ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IN ADDITION THE
CDCR WOULD INCUR COST TO
TRANSPORT PETITIONERS TO AND
FROM THEIR COURT PROCEEDINGS.
ALL RIGHT TINA QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO SIX TWO
GOES TO SUSPENSE AB NINE NINE
THREE BY PATTERSON. MANAGE OUR
RELATIONSHIPS DISPENSED
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. IN SUPPORT
COME ON UP. THANK YOU SHERMAN
PORTANTINO AS A PARENT WHO HAS
AN OPEN ADOPTION OF A WONDERFUL
CHILD I SUPPORT THIS BILL WHOLE
HEARTEDLY IT'S BEEN A GREAT
EXPERIENCE BEING CONNECTED TO
THE BIRTH FAMILY AND ALL THE
SIBLINGS THANK YOU WE SPOKE
ABOUT. THANK YOU SAYING NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR NINE NINE THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY'S GOING UP ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. YOUR POST TO A NINE
NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO FINANCE FILE
THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
NINE NINE THREE GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB TWO EIGHT FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS ON
THE CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX- THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANADA
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF TWO
EIGHT FOUR. IF YOUR SUPPORT OF
TWO EIGHT FOUR ONE FILED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YEAH WE DO I
WANT TO WORK. I THINK THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT TO KILL. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION IS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWO EIGHT
FOUR. YOUR POSTED TO A FOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR I DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YOUR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS COST
OF IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND FOUR HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. ADDITIONALLY THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY ESTIMATES. IN
TWO THOUSAND TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL UND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWO TWO TWO EIGHT FOUR GOES TO
SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN TEN. IS ON
ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC HEARING HEARING
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN TEN BY ROBERT RIVAS. IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TEN WITH
ONE FALL BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
TEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
HAVING TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN TEN- OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE DON'T
WON WITH AN OPERATOR MIGHT BE.
IN SUPPORT IN THE QUEUED UP
RIGHT AT THE END THERE. WITH A
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON TEN
ANYBODY. THEY ARE STILL WITH
THE OPERATOR I APOLOGIZE. WELL
I MEAN. ANYBODY ELSE ONE FALL
BY ZERO. AND WE DID GET THE MAN
AND IT'S LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR OPEN. HI OUR COURT OF THE
FLOOR BONY. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WE'VE TAKEN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. EDITOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES COSTS OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX DEPLOYMENT
AND ADMINISTER THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATE
DANIEL SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
COST OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD NOTE THAT.
IT'S BEEN PREFERENCES RESULT IN
THE SELECTION OF HEARTBEAT COST
OVER LOWERED COSTS. OF
REQUIRING THE CONTRACTS TO BE
NOT MANDATORY WILL REDUCE THE
STATE'S LEVERAGE LIKELY
RESULTING IN HIGHER FLEET
ACQUISITION COSTS FOR STATE
AGENCY. WOULD NOTE THAT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED DEVELOPING
THESE PROCUREMENT AGREEMENT
INVOLVED PURCHASERS OBSERVERS
WOULD DEPEND ON THE SCOPE AND
SPECIFIC NEEDS. RECOMMENDATIONOF THE OMBUDSPERSON. AND CANNOT
BE PREDICTED AT THIS TIME- AS
SUCH THAT PROVISION OF THE BILL
CANNOT BE. ESTIMATED WITH A
SCHOOL AT THIS MOMENT. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN TEN GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB TWO NINE
THREE BY KALRA. ON FUNERAL
ARRANGEMENTS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S I
MEAN TEN FORTY. TO ME TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWO NINE
THREE. IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
TWO NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. I WON
TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN. HI IF
I'M ONE TWENTY FOUR I'M CALLING
FOR A BI FOUR ONE SIX. OKAY
THAT'S THE NEXT BILL BUT GO
AHEAD AND TELL US YOUR POSITION
TO LOG. OKAY THIS IS JUDY MAN
COUSTEAU SPONSORS SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT SORRY ABOUT THAT
NO PROBLEM FOR SIXTEEN SHOOTING
UP MODELING MAKE TOO SO ALL
RIGHT ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF TWO
NINE THREE. IN SUPPORT OF TWO
NINE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NOBODY'S GOING OUT MISTER%
CHAIR ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWO NINE THREE. POSTED AB TWO
NINE THREE ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE PARTICIPANTS QUEUING
UP SIR ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE.
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
ESTIMATES COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
AND FIVE HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND
ANNUALLY ON CALLING TRUMP
ANYTHING PROPERTY FUND
ADDITIONALLY THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE STATES THAT WOULD
GENERATE UNKNOWN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE TO THE
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY FUND. THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
INDICATES CEMETERY AND FUNERAL
FUNERAL BUREAU WILL INCUR COSTS
OF THREE HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN EARLY TO
INCREASE DUE TO INCREASED AUDIT
ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD WOULD KNOW
THAT THIS THE BEARS FUND IS
CURRENTLY. OPERATING UNDER
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO NINE THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB FOR
SIXTEEN. I KALRA ON CALIFORNIA
DEFORESTATION THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING FORTY
TWO OR THREE. NOBODY HERE THIS
COMPANY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR SIXTEEN WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM JUDY MAKE-
SO ANYBODY ELSE. TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR SIXTEEN ONE FILED
BY ZERO AND ALIGN. WELL ONE
MOMENT THERE WAS AN OPERATOR.
BY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NICHOLAS
JACKET UP REPRESENTING PIZZERIA
MOLD IF USING. AND TWENTY
YEARS- COSPONSORS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED
UP MISTER CARRIED OPPOSITION
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN ANYBODY OPPOSED.
TO FOR SIXTEEN. IF YOU'RE POST
TWO FOUR SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR FOUR SIX ONE SIX
ONE FILED BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT.
M. LINE ONE NINETY NINE YOU'RE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY NINE- FROM. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE MAKE YES YES
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON NOVEMBER
FOREST PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OF
CANADA I RESPECTFULLY PROPOSE
AB FOUR ONE SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE WON WITH
AN OPERATOR MR CHER ONE MOMENT.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN YEAR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE KATHY LANCE
REPRESENTING A LARGE COALITION
OF TRADE ASSOCIATIONS AND
BUSINESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
FILED A LETTER EXPRESSING OUR
FISCAL POLICY CONCERNS THANK
YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO FINANCE.
BERMAN GENERAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND. THAT WE KNOW
THAT BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
INCUR ANOTHER COSTS RELATED TO
RECEIVING AND INVESTIGATING
REPORTS OF VIOLATIONS. THE
ENTITIES LASTLY ANY INCREASED
COSTS CONTRACTORS STEMMING FROM
SELF CERTIFYING AND
ESTABLISHING AND MAINTAINING
SUCH A POLICY WOULD LIKELY BE
PASSED ON TO THE STATE IN THE
FORM OF HIGHER CONTRACT COSTS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOR SIXTEEN GO TO SUSPENSE AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX. ON WORKER
STATUTE EMPLOYEES INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IT'S FROM KALRA.
BOB THE PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY
TWO OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES. IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN OH
SIX. SHOW SUPPORT FOR FIFTEEN
OH SIX ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. M.
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP AGAIN ONE FALL BY
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. YEAH
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE NINETY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUST AN
ARKANSAS COMPANY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN OF SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANALYZE WELL THERE
ARE STILL CAN OPERATE ONE
MOMENT. TWENTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
ARE STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG. YEAH
YEAH. THANK YOU I AM MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA POSITION
IS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ONLINE
OPPOSED. TO FIFTEEN OH SIX. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT FINANCE. THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY ANTICIPATES UNKNOWN BUT
UNOBSERVABLE COST RANGING FROM
SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO OVER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COLLECT PROCESS AND
ANALYZE TEMPLATE DATA REQUIRE.
IN ADDITION AGENCY DOES NOT
CURRENTLY COLLECT THE STATE AND
DOES NOT HAVE THE STAFF OR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY RESOURCE
TO DO SO. CREATING ANOTHER
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURE TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL. FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ARE ESTIMATED AT THIS
BILL DOES NOT INCREASE THEIR
WORKLOAD. ALL RIGHTS SENIOR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO AB THREE
THIRTEEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA CIVIL
SERVICEMEN AN EXAMINATION. TO
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO. TO TWENTY. THIRTEEN IN-SUPPORT OF THREE THIRTEEN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE SIXTY ONE
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
CANNOT SHARE AND I AM WITH WILL
BE RIGHT CALIFORNIAN WITH EIGHT
CRACKERS BUNCH OF THE DORM BEER
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND THERE'S ONE OTHER ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. RIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT
EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
RALPH BLACK WITH THE OF
SOCIALIZATION OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE STATE EMPLOYEES WITH
DISABILITIES- IN SUPPORT AND
SPONSORING AB. THREE THIRTEEN.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUTE ON MOVING ON
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED THE THREE THIRTEEN. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO THREE
THIRTEEN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP MR WRIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. STILL RESULTS
IN UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
AND THE BILL IMPACTS MULTIPLE
DIVISIONS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HUMAN RESOURCES AND REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT. RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE THIRTEEN
GOES TO SUSPENSE AB FIVE A ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA. ON HUMAN REMAINS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE FORTY
TWO OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FIVE A ONE. YOUR SUPPORT OF
FIVE OR ONE ONE FILE BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NOBODY'S COMING OUT
MISTER CHAIR I OVER OPPOSITION.
HURRY UP. THANK YOU SENATOR
FORTUNATE WE ARE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE NOT VERY COMFORTABLE
WITH- HYDROLYZING AND TURNING
INTO LIQUID HUMAN REMAINS THIS
DOES SEEM TO BE PRETTY
AGGRESSIVE AND WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT THIS ATTACHED TO ANY
AGENDA TO KILL A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE HERE SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
TO TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE. THAT
IS SUPPOSED TO FIVE OH ONE UP
THERE YOU ARE SO I HAD NOT
SENT- FORMER CITY COUNCILMEMBER
MERIT ABOUT A CITY I THINK THE
TIMING OF THIS BILLS
EXTRAORDINARILY BAD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE IT IN LIGHT OF
COBIT PANDEMIC THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANYBODY. ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO FIVE OH ONE. IF
YOUR POST A FIVE OH ONE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO NOBODY'S
GOING UP MISTER SHARON FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES STARTED COST OF ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND THE
ONGOING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE MEASURE WOULD BE COVERED BY
AN APPLICATION FEE. THE
CEMETERY AND FUNERAL FUNERAL
BUREAU ESTIMATE THAT WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
FACILITIES REQUIRED REQUIRING
LICENSURE UNDER THIS BILL. AND
ESTIMATES REVENUE OF TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS- WOULD
KNOW THAT THIS BILL MAY CREATE
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE BY
CREATING A NEW PROGRAM OR
HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE-
AGENCIES. ALL WRITING NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION FIVE
ONE GOES TO SUSPENSE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE ON SPOUSAL RAPE.
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFERS
WAY PRESENTATION OF OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
SOMEBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. IN SUPPORT. OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE. YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE- AB ELEVEN SO ONE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE'LL GO
TO ONE SIXTY TWO YEAR OPEN. I
WANT FIFTY TWO YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT OF Q. O. EIGHT
EIGHT ONE ZERO AGAIN. HE'S BACK
OR SHE'S BACK PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL HI THIS IS GAIL YOUR ON
BEHALF OF SUMMER STEPHENS IN
THE AGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH ALL THANK YOU TO THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
YOURLINK STAPLETON IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE FOR
THE FOLLOWING. OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR
WOMEN. AND PROFESSOR MICHELE
DAUBER WHO IS THE- JUROR OF
ENOUGH VOTER PROJECT THE RESULT
TODAY AND COULD NOT BE HERE I.
AM VERY VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF%
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CAROLYN ANYONE ELSE.
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JENNIFER
GONZALEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE LEARNING A LOT IS-
CALIFORNIA SENATE GOVERNOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS
QUEUED UP MISTER CHAIR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOT BE TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE.
SECURE POST TO ELEVEN SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL BETTER FINANCE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE AND WE
KNOW THAT BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATE ANY
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO STILL BE
MINOR ANSWERABLE ALL RIGHTY NO
QUESTIONS THAT OBJECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ONTO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. AB THREE FOUR SEVEN
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE SLEEP STEP
THERAPY IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND HE'S UP WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND I MANY TWENTY FORTY ANYONE
ON. THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF THREE FOUR SEVEN. SHOW
SUPPORT FOR THREE SEVEN ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. WHAT
INSTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
CROHN'S AND COLITIS FOUNDATION
A CO SPONSOR THE MEASURE AS
WELL AS THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN IS JUST NINE AND A
CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. NINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE TERM MEMBERS TO
MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE WE ARE ALSO A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY
TWO THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE UP.
EVEN STROKES FROM THE ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION THE THIRD COOPER
PROUD CO SPONSOR. WE'RE NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE THAT MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO
THREE FOUR SEVEN IS NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. YOUR POSTER THREE
FORTY SEVEN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES
COSTS TOTALING TWO POINT TWO
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
MANAGED CARE FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
TWO POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES. ONE TIME
COST THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
INSURANCE FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. ALL RIGHT NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THREE FOUR SEVEN GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB SIX HUNDRED BY
ARAMBULA ON HATE CRIMES- WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SIX
HUNDRED. IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
BY ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GAIL YOUR ON BEHALF OF
SUMMER SEPTEMBER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIX HUNDRED THANK
YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SIX
HUNDRED. YOUR POST AB SIX
HUNDRED ONE FILED BY. ZERO I
KNOW ONES QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT FINANCE. HE WAS
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT FURTHER
COMPLICATES SENTENCING BY
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF A
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT THAT COULD
INCREASE THE STATE PRISON IN
COUNTY JAIL POPULATION AND
ASSOCIATED COSTS. ALL RIGHT
SENIOR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX HUNDRED COSTA
SUSPENSE AB SIX TWO FIVE EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA. ON
PUBLIC DEFENDER IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE AT FORTY TWO OH
THREE NOBODY HERE NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY. ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX TWO
FIVE. SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
TWO FIVE ONE FALL BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. DON'T QUEUING UP THE
STRUCTURE. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
SIXTY FIVE. ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO
SIX TWO FIVE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP. HE SAID THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP ALL RIGHT FINANCE. THAT WAS
ENDING THE MERITS OF THIS
MEASURE- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
FOR THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
AND THE RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
COST PRESSURES DEPENDING ON THE
FINDINGS OF THE REQUIRED
REPORT. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SIXTY FIVE GOES TO SUSPENSE AB
SIX NINE FIVE BY ARAMBULA ON
ELDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S SOMEBODY THERE.
MODERATOR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SIX NINE
FIVE. YOUR SUPPORT OF US SIX
NINE FIVE OR SIX TWO FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. MY SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ACTUALLY I DO
APOLOGIZE IS THE SIX NINE FIVE
SIX TWO FIVE. SIX NINE SEVEN MY
MISTAKE. SIX NINE FIVE PERFECT
I DIDN'T CONNECTION CALLING
FROM THE ARE CALLING WITH BILLY
WRIGHT CALIFORNIA IMPORTS THANK
YOU. AGAIN I APOLOGIZE IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT FOR SIX NINE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO POINT TWO HUNDRED YEAR
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MODELING COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ALSO.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP MISTER
CHAIR IRON OPPOSITION THIS X.
NINE FIVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPENING TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SIX NINE FIVE.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SIX NINE
FIVE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP FINANCE. IS YOUR
CHAIR WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF
ITS PROVISIONS ARE DUPLICATIVE
OF CHANGES INCLUDING THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT BECAUSE
NEW REQUIREMENTS RESULTING COST
PRESSURES NOT REFLECTED IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET. ALL RIGHTY NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SIX
NINE FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE AB
TEN NINETY FOUR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RANDY LAW ON SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY. IT IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TEN NINETY FOUR. IF YOU'RE A
SUPPORTER TO NINETY FOUR ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AND WILL BEGIN
WITH LINE TWENTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. TWENTY THREE PLEASE
CONTACT IT. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER LAWRENCE CALLING ON
BEHALF. BURKE THANK YOU. AND
ONE TO THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN.ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY FOUR.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
NUMBER INTENT TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO
TEN TWENTY AT TEN NINETY FOUR.
YOUR POSTS ARE TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOBODY AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
THANK YOU WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ESTIMATES TOTAL COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL AT ONE
POINT THREE. FIND OVER THREE
YEARS. THANK YOU NINETEEN NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
MAYBE TEN NINETY FOUR GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN OH SIX BY
ARAMBULA. HEALTH PROFESSIONS
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT. THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY FORTY IS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT AT THIRTEEN OH SIX.
SHOW SUPPORT FOR THIRTEEN OH
SIX ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL ALIGN FORTY SEVEN. BRENT
SPENCER BEHALF OF C. H. E.
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
AND NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM NO NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN
OH SIX. IF YOU OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN THAT ARE THIRTEEN OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP ALL
RIGHT FINANCE NO FILE MISTER
JACK. ALL RIGHT NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY ARAMBULA AND PUBLIC SCHOOL
SERVICES. THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY. ANY COMMENTS ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX. TO SHARE
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME I ORDERED OPPOSITION
IS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY
IN. TWENTY FORTY THREE TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. THE THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX. TO OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX YOU MAY ALSO PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. FINANCE.
WELL MISTER CHAIR- FINAL
QUESTIONS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX WITHOUT OBJECTION WITH A
SUSPENSE AB. THREE FIFTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA PLUTA IT'S
AGRICULTURAL- FILMY ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE TO SUSPEND
CANDIDATE WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO MAIN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FIFTY. SURE
SUPPORT FOR IT AB THREE FIFTEEN
A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE HAVE A LINE IN Q.
X. LINE TWO OH FOUR TWO HUNDRED
FOUR. MISTER MEMBERS PAUL
YOU'RE A BEHALF THE MADERA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT THANKS. ALL RIGHT. NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. OVER
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THREE FIFTY. STATE
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE FIFTEEN
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE FIFTY.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE.
ADMINISTERED NEXT CULTURE
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRED TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR THREE YEARS TO
MINISTER OF FUTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. WE WILL NOTE THAT THE
ALSO CREATES ONGOING GENERAL
FUND PRESSURE TO PROVIDE GRANT
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM. ALL
RIGHT TINA QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THREE FIFTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. THE FOURTEENTH
SEVENTY ONE BY THE ABUJA. ON
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSIONS IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
FOR SUPPORT. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. HI PAUL MCGANN FROM WIRE
AMERICA WE SUPPORT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION RALLY
DOING THEIR JOB AND GETTING
GREAT HEARD OF REPRESENTATION
FROM ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL WE APPRECIATE ALL
THAT BUT WE DO NEED TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT TELEPHONE
CORPORATIONS AND ONLY ALLOW
ACTUAL PROVIDERS AND TELEPHONE
SERVICE IN THAT CATEGORY WE
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON THE TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE THIS PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. BUT SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO LINE TO GET THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE. GRUPOS AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. GEN ONE
ZERO. NO ONE'S IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE WILL GO TO FINANCE. PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION
ANTICIPATES THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME YOU SEE
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT COSTS TO
HIRE CONSULTANTS THE PHARMACIST
OF A POTENTIAL MOVE OF THEIR
HEADQUARTERS BUT IS IT ANY MOVE
WILL RESULT IN SUBSTANTIAL COST
IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. LASTLY THE REVENUE
FROM THIS ACCOUNT COMES FROM A
SURCHARGE ON BILLS IN EACH
REPAIR WOULD PAY ABOUT THREE
CENTS TO COVER THIS ADDITIONAL
COST. ARETINO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
GOES TO SUSPEND TV THREE SIX
FOUR. RODRIGUEZ ON FOREIGN
LABOR CONTRACTOR REGISTRATION
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE'S
NOBODY FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IT'S SUPPORT OF THREE SIX
FOUR. THE STATE'S SUPPORT FOR
THREE SIX FOR ME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE THAT'S
ONE ZERO. TWO NINE TWO Q. ONE
TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HELLO TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WE CAN HEARING OF.
BERMAN DECLINED ONE SIXTY TWO
ATTORNEYS. WELL I WON SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR DIFFERENT
DEAL YOUR AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALAMEDA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF EIGHTY THREE SIX FOUR AND WE
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KNOW OTHER LINES
IN SUPPORT BUT OF THE
NONPRODUCTIVE ANISE ROAMING
OVER. THIRTY THERE'S NO DOUBT
ONE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THREE SIX FOUR. GOOD
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE LINE
OPEN IT'S NOT. SORRY TO STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WHICH
IS A. B. ONLY SIXTY FOREIGN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE OPEN OPPOSITION. ONE
ZERO. BORDERLINE TWO THIRTY
NINE TWO THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I GOT IN THE WRONG QUEUE
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE IN SUPPORT.
AB THREE SIX FOUR OR FOR THE
FOLLOWING OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE SIX FOUR. PUT THAT THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. I'M GONNA FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THAT
PROVIDED THAT EXISTING
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
APPLICATIONS CAN BE USED AT THE
BILL RESULT IN COST OF SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND SIX HUNDRED
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
TO EXPAND APPROACH. WE KNOW
THAT THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
ABLE TO CHARGE REGISTRATION
FEES TO COVER THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM AND THEREFORE INCREASED
REVENUE COULD OFFSET ONGOING
PROGRAM COSTS. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THREE SIX FOUR VOTER SUSPENSE
AB FOR SEVENTEEN MCCARTY.
RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK
DISPENSED CANDIDATE WILL OPEN
UP PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. AND NO
ONE'S HERE I WAS IN TWENTY
FORTY SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOUR
SEVENTEEN. EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
SEVENTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
MADELINE IN Q. IT'S LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE LET'S GO AHEAD.
MANY BILLS REPRESENTING THE SAN
JOSE EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT AURORA
POSITION OF FOUR SEVENTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO POSE FOR SEVENTEEN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. YES WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE AS ITS
PROVISIONS GOVERN THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS PROVIDED
FOR THE RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK
PROGRAM IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. WHICH INCLUDED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
ACTIVITIES AND SERVICES
PROVIDED. BY THE NETWORK. ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOR SIXTEEN GOES
TO SUSPENSE. AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE MCCARTY ON FIREARMS TRACING
ITS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAVE
WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. HOW MANY TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. THE STATE'S SUPPORT
FOR ELEVEN NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THANK YOU
NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT FINE
YES OR NO TO ME OPPOSITION NO
ONE'S IN THIS ROOM NO ONE'S IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO ELEVEN
NINETY ONE. STATE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ELEVEN NINETY ONE ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NONBINDING
Q. R. AYE FINANCE AND JUSTICE
JUST MAKES ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
TO MEET THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPEND CB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
MCCARTY ON REAL PROPERTY
DISCRIMINATORY RESTRICTIONS.
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX.
SUPPORT FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX IN
THE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AND WE HAVE NO LINES
IN Q. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSE. THE FOURTEENTH SIXTY
SIX. THANK MISTER KIRK OPPOSE
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX AND YOU
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO LINES INTO IT IS
ALL RIGHT FINANCE. BERMAN OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND COST OF THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
MAKE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH WE COLLABORATE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES
MY- OSTS. ALL RIGHT SIGNAL BOB
JUNCTION AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO MCCARTY COUNTY OF
YELLOW SECURED RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN FORTY TWO.
STATE SUPPORT FOR FIFTEEN FORTY
TO ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE ONE THEN
THEY'RE ALL. ON THE LINE TO
TWENTY ONE TWO TWO ONE GO AHEAD.
I COLOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS FOR AT FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX-
TO SAY YOUR NAME. OKAY
WILLIAMSBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FORTY SIXTY SIX APOLOGIES
FOR THAT NO PROBLEM. ORDER
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO NOW. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. TWO HUNDRED. DR
TRIMMERS NATOLIN COOPER FROM
THE YELPING LOOKS MORE IN
BEHALF OF YELLOW COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT RIGHT
OPPOSITION. SAY NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM SAYING NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN FORTY TWO.
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN
FORTY TO ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE A LINING
CUTE PLAN SIXTY ONE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THIS
IS CANNOT SHIP FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA HEARING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NOT FOR
THE LINE TO Q. FRIDAY NINE
HANDS. BERMAN OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ANTICIPATES COST OF A
HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE DECLINED
TO ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AFTER
THE END OF THE PILOT PERIOD. WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL DOES SPECIFY
TREATMENT PROVIDED THROUGH THE
PROGRAM IS REIMBURSABLE UNDER
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT IT IS UNCLEAR
WHETHER THE TREATMENT AS
PROPOSED WOULD BE COVERED UNDER
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO
CLOSE TO SUSPENSE AB FOUR FOUR
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES.
RECREATIONAL WATER USE IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE AND-
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. I'M IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF FOUR FOUR ONE.
SURE SUPPORT FOR FOUR FOUR ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LANDING GEAR AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION FOR ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO FOUR FOUR
ONE. OPPOSITION FOR FOUR FOUR
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE ONE ZERO
PROPOSITIONS. NO LINES INTO AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER SURE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND
IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SPENDING PLAN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIRES NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND PER YEAR
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE OR THREE YEARS
TOTALING TWO HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ADDITIONALLY
THE DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES AN INCREASE
IN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN
RESOURCES ASSOCIATED WITH
CONDUCT. TIONS IN A DRESSING
JURISDICTIONAL CHALLENGES FROM
OWNERS AND OPERATORS OF THE
STUDENTS. ALL RIGHTS SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOUR FOUR ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FOUR FOUR SIX MAYES
ELECTIONS POLITICAL FIVE PARTY
QUALIFICATIONS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMON IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOT MANY TWENTY FORTY.
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF FOUR FOUR
SIX. SURE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
FOUR FOUR SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q.ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION FOUR FOUR SIX.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOTING
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO FOUR
FOUR SIX. SURE OPPOSITION FOR
FOUR OR SIX YEARS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
THANK YOU WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE IT WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN AN ELECTION RELATED
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AND
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE MANDATE
EXPOSURE IS NOT UNKNOWN BUT
LIKELY WILL BE SIGNIFICANT. ALL
RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS AB FOUR
FOUR SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION MAYBE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON ON INCOME TAX LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN
A PUBLIC COMMENT IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NOBODY THERE- MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR FOUR SEVEN.
SURE SUPPORT FOR FOUR FOUR
SEVEN PM PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
OVER LINE ONE THIRTEEN- MARC
SUMMERS THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. WE ALSO
HAVE LINE. FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIELLE CANDOR
CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
KNOW FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THE TIME ABOUT OPPOSITION OF
FOUR FOUR SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S SOMEBODY TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FOUR FOUR SEVEN.
STATE OPPOSITION OF FOUR FOUR
SEVENTEEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION BINANCE. STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
CALIFORNIA HOUSING AGENCY.
ESTIMATE THIS BILL HAVE NO
FISCAL IMPACT ALL RIGHTS SEEING
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FOUR FOUR SEVEN GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SIX OH TWO GRAYSON
DEVELOPMENTAL FEES. IMPACT FEE
NEXUS STUDY IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS COMING TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SIX OH
TWO. THE STATE SUPPORT FOR SIX
OH TWO THIS PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. YOU HAVE A
FEW LINES OPERATORS AGAIN SURE
SUPPORT FOR SIX OH TWO YOU
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WELL THE FIRST IN LINE TO
TWENTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHEN NOTHING
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS.
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND A
CALIFORNIAN BE AS PROUD
SPONSORS OF THE BILL- AND
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX HOURS.
NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWO THIRTY
SIX. MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS
BOB NEAL REPRESENTING FEELS
DEAD AND COMPANY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SIX OH TWO. WE
HAVE TWO MORE WE'LL GO TO LINE.
TWO FORTY SIX- HIGH- NO I'M I'M
HOLDING FOR- ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THREE SEVEN ON MY- YES SIR I
JUST REPEAT THE COMMAND AT THAT
TIME. OKAY THANKS. WITH THAT MR
JOURNAL FOR THE LINES AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSES
OPENING TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SIX OH TWO. STATE
OPPOSITION THE SIX OH TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
DON'T MIND IN QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COST OF SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR THREE
DOLLARS AND- A HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING.
ALL RIGHTY NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX OH TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB ELEVEN OH FOUR
GRAYSON AIR AMBULANCE SERVICE.
THE SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAVE
WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
HERE AND THERE'S NOBODY IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. ELEVEN OH FOUR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT. THESE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THREE FOUR.
TWO HUNDRED YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER FROM
THAT CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR
ELEVEN OH FOUR AND LIKE TO
EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- I WAS. IN Q. FOUR AB SIX
OH TWO TWO OPPOSE AND I DIDN'T
GET THAT. SO I'M INTERESTED IN
STATE YOUR NAME ON WILL TAKE UP
TO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND NEXT BUT THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR
OPPOSITION THERE ANY WITNESSES
HERE OR PEOPLE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN OH FOUR.
HI LET'S LOOK GO TO THE- A ROOM
TO AT. TWENTY FORTY I SEE NOW
WITH THIS IS THAT THERE. CAN WE
NOW MOVE ON THE WITNESSES
TESTIFYING VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHARACTERS OBSERVATION
TO AB ELEVEN OH FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME FOR GOOD LET'S CHECK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE MISS.
ONE OF THEIR- TO HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. FILE MISTER CHAIR
OKAY- SEEING THEIR MEMBERS-
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN-
FORCED ME TO SUSPEND CALENDAR
NEXT UP IS AB FOUR SEVEN ONE
BUT THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR ADMINISTRATIVE CITATIONS
AND SAFETY INSPECTIONS. IT IS A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE AUTHORS
WAVE PRESENTATION WILL MOVE
RIGHT TO PUBLIC SUPPORTER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN SUPPORT
OF- AB FOUR SEVEN ONE WHO'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY SEEING THEN WAS
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO WITNESSES READY TO
TESTIFY THERE SO. MODERATOR IF
YOU WILL PROMPT WITNESSES THE
POP AND THE PUBLIC WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND
SUPPORT. ON AB FOUR SEVEN ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOUR SEVEN ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE TO TWENTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILLIAM MARTIN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF WORLDWIDE
ENVIRONMENT PRODUCTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND ALL OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- WHICH
THAT TESTIFY HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOUR SEVEN ONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MACHINES HAS FIVE C. NINE SO
MODERATOR LET'S- MOVE ON WITH
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. FOUR SEVEN
ONE. CALL THEM. I'M SO SORRY I
HAD MY PHONE MUTED OUT MISTER
CHAIR AND TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR AB FOUR SEVEN ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY- IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME RIGHT NOW WILL CHECK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE ZOOM LINE MISS. ON A DIRECT
DO YOU HAVE ANY FILE IN THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
BECAUSE IT ENHANCES CONSUMER
PROTECTION BUT I DO KNOW
CONCERNS THAT THE BILL CREATES
A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS CHOOSES TO IMPLEMENT AN
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY UPDATES
TELEPHONICALLY TRANSMITS YOUR
TICKETS COMPLIANCE. ISSUE BY
LAST. OF MOTOR VEHICLES. IN
ADDITION IF THE DEPARTMENT
DETERMINES IT'S FEASIBLE TO ADD
FUNCTIONALITY. TO EXISTING
DATABASE SYSTEMS TO SUPPORT THE
CHARGING OF FEES AND ISSUANCE
OF TRACKING OF CERTIFICATES OF
COMPLIANCE. THIS COULD FURTHER
ADD TO THE COST PRESSURES OF
THE BILL- WELL SEEING HANDS OF
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FOUR SEVEN ONE THIS MOVES TO
THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR. NOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW HAS AB FIVE
SIX TWO. UNTIL THE NINETEEN
PROVIDER MENTAL HEALTH
RESILIENCY ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I'M HE IS WAIVED- THE
PRESENTATION THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE SIX TWO. I'M LOOKING
IN ROOM- TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO. ARE WITNESSES THEY
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF.
AB FIVE SIX TWO AND SEE NONE.
SO MODERATE TO LISTEN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN- SEE
IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE NEED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SIXTY PLEASE
QUEUE THEM. THANK YOU- TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO OH
FOUR YOU ARE OPEN GO AHEAD.
TOOL FOR COMMUTERS. GO AHEAD
AND SAY UNION MEMBERS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE A
MAY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY SEVEN. TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REGARDING THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES A PROUD COSPONSOR AND
A STRONG SUPPORT. I NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER HAVING HER FROM
SUPPORTERS FROM FIVE FILE THE-
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE FOR
OPPOSITION. FIVE IF YOU'RE ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE NEW QUESTION
TO TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF AB
FIVE SIX TO COME FOR DIRECT
PRICE HI MY NAME IS PAUL ME
DEVON AND WE'RE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
THE BEST THERAPY FOR COVERED
NINETEEN IS THE TRUTH. AND
YOU'RE ACTUALLY HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE VERY GOOD
TREATMENTS AVAILABLE FOR COPD
IN NINETEEN STARTING WITH THE
WORD IVR AND HYDROXY AND THAT
CAN EASILY FOUND ON THE
INTERNET THAT WOULD BE YOUR
BEST OPPORTUNITY HERE WE OPPOSE
THE BILL THIS MCGOVERN. C. NO
OTHER WITNESSES- HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THROUGH TRYING TO
ROOT OUT WITNESSES WHEN THE
TEST PLAN ROOMS TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NONE- SO MODERATOR ET'S
TURN TO WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IF YOU WILL. IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. FIVE SIX TO
CALL THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY.
IF YOU ARE AND OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE SIX TWO ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOBODY IS GOING UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAS MOVED TO THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCIER PRESS ON A
DOOR HAS HE FILE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES-
NOTWITHSTANDING THE MERITS OF
THE BILL WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AND WOULD REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
FEE INCREASES TO LICENSEES.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THE FEE INCREASES TO MEET THE
TIELINE SPECIFIED IN THE BILL.
LASTLY ADMINISTRATOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROGRAM IS NOT
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
STANDARDS CUT WITH
RESPONSIBILITY THANK YOU.
BURGER KING NO HAN SO BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE SIXTY
WAS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW HAS AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH IS GENDER NEUTRAL RETAIL
DEPARTMENTS HE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION AND THE- AND THE
MEASURE IS A CANDIDATE FOR THE
SUSPENSE CARE. CALENDAR IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO THROUGH. THREE WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR. PLEASE COME FOR MR
MCGOVERN. YES MY NAME'S FORMER
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
REALLY SUPPORT EQUALITY OF ALL
PEOPLE WITH IN CALIFORNIA AND
TO BE ABLE TO PRESERVE THEIR
RIGHTS IN EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
BUT THESE BILLS PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS MONTH VERY GOOD SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES HERE ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL TURN TO ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
WITNESSES TESTIFYING I SEE NONE
SO MODERATE TO LET'S MOVE TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
VIA THE- TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
IN PLEASE CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT. TEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THAT'S RIGHT IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY'S QUEUING
UP PRETTY GOOD LAST FALL THE
SAME- A TEACHER FOR OPPOSITION
OF THE WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TEN EIGHTY FORCING NONE ALL
TURN TO ROOM- TWENTY FORTY I
SEE NO WITNESSES WAS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THERE.
SEMATARY LET'S. GO BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE EVER SINCE IF
THERE'S MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
PLEASE CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO TEN EIGHTY FOUR-
ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS ONE WITH AN OPERATOR. IT
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ANYBODY OUTSIDE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO- CAN EIGHTY FOUR
POINT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
AND MY TO FORTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. THE DALLAS THE CAPITAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU AND
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP SIR
LET'S COULD MISS ON THE DERA AT
PARTNER FINANCIAL FILE AND P.
B. A TEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS LIMIT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
ALL RIGHT SEE NOW HAS UP I'M MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN EIGHTY FOUR SUPPOSED TO
SUSPENSE FILE. NEXT EPISTLE AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR-
CONSERVATORSHIP- BY SEVERAL
MEMBER LOIS'S SPENCE CANDIDATE
IN THE AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH THREE. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO FINDS OF AB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR SEEING NONE OF THE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I SEE NINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR SO MODERATOR
IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
WITNESSES. BE THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR CALL THEM
FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY. THAT'S
WHY IN SUPPORT OF AB L. LEVIN
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY IS
GIVING UP MISTER ALL RIGHT
LET'S FALL THE SAME PROCEDURE
FOR OPPOSITION OF THE WITNESSES
HERE. IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR AC
NONE I'M LOOKING A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY OR OVERFLOW ROOM AND
THERE'S SOMEONE THERE TO. WHICH
THE TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. SO
MODERATOR LET'S GO BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE REPRESENT PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR CALL THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU- MISTER
SURE THIS FIRST ONE MAY BE IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY QUEUED UP
RIGHT WHEN WE WERE
TRANSITIONING. VERY WELL TO
SIGN A NAME AN IRA AFFILIATION
WILL RECORD. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ABOUT ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD MA'AM I
CRIED I SUPPORT OUR
REQUIREMENTS AND FURTHER STEPS
BEFORE ABOUT NAME INDIVIDUAL IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY THANK YOU
OKAY. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO MISS ON THE
DERA WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO HAVE A FILE OF
POSITION. YES NOTWITHSTANDING
THE MERITS OF THIS BILL WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE
THE BILL COULD CREATE
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND FISCAL
PRESSURES FOR THE TRIAL COURT'S
POTENTIALLY IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE WORKLOAD FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES BUREAU.
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE. AND
SEEING NO HANDS UP IN QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOURS MOVED TO
SUSPEND CALENDAR. NOW THE
COMMITTEE OF BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HAS. AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO ON THERE SAYING- IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE NEW
YORK AND THE CHAIR OF THE-
COMMITTEE HAS WAY RESENTATION
SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING FORTY TWO OH
THREE. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO SEEING NONE
I'LL TURN TO ROOM. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY I SEE NO ONE THEY'RE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SO. MODERATOR WE PLEASE QUEUE
UP MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
THE TEST FIVE YEAR OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE FIVE THREE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND WE WILL ALIGN. TO
FORTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. I'M
READY OF ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU KNOW
WHETHER PARTICIPATE QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME MISTER SCHOOL
OPPOSITION THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN A
POSITION OF. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TO. A NURSING. SEEING NONE WILL
GO TO ROOM FOR TWENTY FORTY OUR
OVERFLOW AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WISHING TESTIFIED I SEE
NO MEMBERS THERE SO MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS
WITH SEAT WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO- AND CALL THEM FOR
INDIVIDUALLY. EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION FOR AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
STE AND WE ARE GETTING-
PARTICIPANTS WITHOUT A MISS ON
THE DERA WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ON THE SAME LINE DO YOU
HAVE A ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
OKAY SEE NO HANDS UP FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE FILE THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS ALSO HAS- AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ON
PHARMACY WHICH IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES- THEY AUTHORS WE
PRESENTATION SO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FROM.
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE. SEEING
NONE THERE'S BY THE WITNESS IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEEN AND TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. FIFTEEN THIRTY
THREE SO LET'S. MODERATOR
LET'S. GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
REPRESENT PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE. AND CALL THEM.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SATISFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME ARTLESS MOVED
TO OPPOSITION OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. UP WE SHOULD
TESTIFY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE AND OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE I SEE NONE
TURNING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY C.
NO WITNESSES THERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE SO
MODERATOR LET'S GO BACK TO THE-
WITNESSES WAITING VIA OUR
TELECONFERENCE THERE IS WHO MAY
WANT TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE CALL
THEM FORWARD. IF YOU ARE GOING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND NOBODY'S QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR MISTER ON A
TERRORIST ATTACK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ON THE SAME
LINE TO HAVE A FILE ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU MISTER SURE
YES WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BUT DO NOT A CONCERN
WITH THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
BOARD TO HIRE ITS OWN LEGAL
COUNSEL. WE KNOW THAT WHILE
SOME DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AWARDS ALREADY ARE
REQUIRED BY STATUTE TO HAVE
THEIR OWN LEGAL COUNSEL. OF THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES CENTRALIZED
LEGAL SERVICES FOR EXPORTS AND
GROSS- WE WILL SEE NO COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE HE'S
MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE. THE
COMMITTEE AND BUSINESS
IMPRESSIONS SAYS AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF A
COMMON TREE- MEASURE IT SAYS.
ASSIST CAN WITH. IN THE AUTHOR
IS WAY PRESENT. SO LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE WHO WISH TO. TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR.
I SEE NONE I'M LOOKING IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. FOUR WITNESSES
WHO TESTIFIED SUPPORT FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR AND I SEE NONE. SO
LET'S MODERATE REALIST MOVED TO
OUR TELECOM. SERVICES AND
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR CALL
THEM FORWARD. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR I WAS FOR THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE-
IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR I SEE NONE.
OF THE WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY I SEE NINE SO MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WILLING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR AND CALL
THEM FORWARD PIERRE ARE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE. THANK
YOU EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR.
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOW WE HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP I WAS CHECKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE SAME LINE THIS ON A- ON A
DIRECT YOU HAVE A FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT IN THE
STATE'S LONG TERM FISCAL PLAN
DO PROVIDE FOR THE BOARD'S
CONTINUING BUDGET. HOWEVER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
INDICATES THAT THIS BILL DOES
INCREASE THE LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD FOR THE
BOARD- ESTIMATED COST OF FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE OPTOMETRY FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. AND FOUR HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE THIS BILL.
AUTHORIZES THE- IT'S ONLY A
COUNCIL THE BILL CREATES
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURE. OKAY
SEEING NO WITNESSES OR COMMENTS
BY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR SINCE THE SUSPENSE
COUNTER. THE COMEDIAN BUSINESS
AND FOR PROFESSION SAYS AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE WHICH DEALS
WITH VETERINARIAN- THE MEDICAL
BOARD- AND DISCIPLINA CITATIONS
IT'S SUSPENSE CANDIDLY AUTHORS
WE PRESENTATION. OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE I SEE NINE
I'M TRYING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I SEE. NO WITNESSES THERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE SOME
MODERATE TO LET'S- TURNED TO ME
ANY MEMBER OF THE WAY INS
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE YEAR OUR
TELECONFERENCE REVERSING CALL
THEM FORWARD. YES I IN SUPPORT
FOR AB FIFTY THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
ONE MOMENT. PLEASE WE HAVE ONE
OF THE MODERATOR- OPERATOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO THAT'S
WHY IN SUPPORT FOR A BI.
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE. NOW WE
WILL GO TO LINEONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MEMBERS
JUMPED AT THE COMMAND FROM THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOBODY ELSE IS COMING UP
THIS TIME MISTER JERRY GOOD
LET'S TREND OPPOSITION OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. A FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE I
SEE NONE OF THE WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE- TESTIFIED. IN
OPPOSITION SO MODERATOR LET'S
TURN TO- OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AND ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE AND CALL THEM FORWARD.
THANK YOU TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION AFTER ONE FIVE THREE
FIVE PLEASE TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN PRESS ONE ZERO.
SURE WE HAVE NOBODY QUEUEING UP.
I SEE NO COMMENTS BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HERE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
FIVE IS A MOVE DISPENSED
COUNTER COUNTER CHAIR
PORTANTINO WELCOME BACK RIGHT.
WE WILL GO TO EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY ONE BY TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MILITARY
EQUIPMENT. FUNDING AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY FORTY TWO OF.
ACTION THE TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. SOCIAL SUPPORT
FOR FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NOBODY'S GIVING UP MISTER
CHAIR UP SKEWS ME WE JUST HAVE
ONE LAST SECOND AB ONE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KIND OF CHECK ON DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA THE COURT
THANK YOU. HELLO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS CUED UP SIR.
NOBODY ELSE CUED UP MISTER
CHAIR. WE WILL DO OPPOSITION OF
AB FORTY ONE GO AHEAD MY FRIEND.
PACKAGER POTATOES FARM AGAIN WE
ARE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
AGAINST DECEPTIVE BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT ACTUALLY SAY HEY WE
DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD THAT
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THEN YOU'RE
RIGHT ALL THE RULES LET HIM OUT
IT IS ACTUALLY SHOULD JUST
PROHIBIT THIS FROM HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE END WE OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THE NAME
IS NOT SOMETIME AND I REPRESENT
CITIZENS OPPOSE A VIOLATE THE
POSSE COMITATUS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
FORTY ONE. YOURPOST OF FORTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO NOBODY IS GOING UP
MISTER CHAIR. ALL RIGHT FUNDS
WE WILL GO TO FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
ESTIMATE COST OF SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
FOURTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING TO PERFORM THE
NEW ASSESSMENT APPROVAL
TRACKING AND REPORTING WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL. DUE
TO THE BROAD DEFINITION OF
MILITARY EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD
LIKELY INCLUDE- MANY OF ITS
MUCH OF ITS APPOINTMENT.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THE COST OF. FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND COSTS TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ESTIMATES IT
IS GOING BACK TO FOR HER TO
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING.
AND APARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION ESTIMATES AN
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY SIX
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT
COMPLY WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. ARE LASTLY WE KNOW
THAT THIS BILL WILL LIKELY
IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT NEW WORKLOAD
ON LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE. IN
THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
FORTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
ONE TWO AB FIVE TWO FIVE TWO ON
ENERGY OFFSHORE WIND GENERATION-
IT IS A SUSPEND CANDIDATE WE
HAVE A SPEAKER TO OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM ABOUT AROUND TWENTY FORTY-
THERE'S NOBODY THERE WILL GO
TO- THE PHONE LINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE
TWO FIVE. DURING SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE TWO FIVE THE FIRST ONE
FILED BY ZERO. I WILL BEGIN
TODAY WITH ONE TWO OR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD TOOL FOR.
SHERMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOU ARE
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S. THANK
YOU TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON JENNIFER
GONZALEZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR RUNNING
COLLECTED IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWO FIVE THANK YOU. NOW ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP- ONE
THIRTY ONE. I'M NOT QUITE THERE
ONE THIRTY TO YOUR OPEN. HI
THIS IS CATHERINE DIED
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
SOMEWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANNEX'S LINE TO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT KREMIN
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE
ABOUT PRETTY ENGINEERS SECURITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU M. LINE TWO FIFTY YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NONPROFIT INTENDED TO GO TO
COURT. EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE.
OKAY NO THE ARE QUEUED UP CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT THE DROP. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO FIVE TWO FIVE. IT'S.
IF YOUR POST AB FIVE TWO FIVE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP SIR OUR AYE
FINANCE. THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ESTIMATES COST OF
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE ENERGY RESOURCES
PROGRAM ACCOUNT ONE TIME WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS FUND IS
CURRENTLY IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AND ANY INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURES WILL ACCELERATE
THE NEED FOR AN INCREASE IN THE
STATE RIGHT SURCHARGE ON
ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION. ALL
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH AND THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
ESTIMATE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BILL TO BE A ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
JOHNSON ONE TIME. TO PREPARE
THE STRATEGIC PLAN. ALL RIGHTS
RECEIVE SIGNAL. WE WILL SEND
FIVE TWO FIVE TWO SUSPECTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO HERE WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A BEFORE NINE NINE OUT OF
ORDER. TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. A PLEASE
PRESENT AN OBVIOUS WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT
SO QUICKLY THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOODBYE GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TRANSCEND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION THAT WILL CREATE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
FAMILIES USING REFERRAL
AGENCIES FOR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES. RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES ARE RCF EASE OUR NON
MEDICAL FACILITIES FOR THE
ELDERLY THAT SPECIALIZE IN
HOUSING AND PERSONALIZED
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO INCREASE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE
WHO NEED. DAY TO DAY
ASSISTANCE- FAMILIES ARE OFTEN
THEMSELVES IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE TO FIND
THE CORRECT OUR CFE FOR THEIR
LOVED ONES REFERRAL AGENCIES
PROVIDE EXPERTISE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES AND HELP EXPEDITE THE
LOVE THEIR LOVED ONES BEING
PLACED IN THE CORRECT FACILITY
FOR THEIR NEEDS. DRINKER WE GET
THE CALL THAT NINETEEN REFERRAL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN A CRUCIAL
PART OF PLACEMENT DECISIONS FOR
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT AND
VISIT VISITATION IS EITHER NOT
AN OPTION ARE INFREQUENT
INFREQUENT TO LIMIT THE
EXPOSURE OF RESIDENTS AND
STAFF. THE LEGISLATION IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY WILL ALLOW FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS TO
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS
SEEKING PLACEMENT AT
PRESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES-
AND WITH THAT THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A COUPLE. WHO
GOING TO BE VERY BRIEF SO.
MISTER BERGEN IS MILLER WE GOT
IT. YOU'RE HERE FOR TECHNICAL
ASST IF WE NEED YOU RIGHT.
THANKS MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YEP WE'RE HERE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF WE NEED
YOU RIGHT. YEP THANK YOU IN
DEED BACK WITH- GIVE ME HALF OF
A PLACE FOR MOM ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS THE BILL WE ARE MOST
PLEASED TO WORK WITH CONSUMER
ADVOCATES FOR RCA. HE REFORM
REPRESENTED BY MONICA CREATED
BUILT FOR A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
TO ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO MAKE
AN INFORMED DECISION AFTER SIX
YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
DISCUSSIONS IN SIX MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
A BILL THAT PROVIDES CONSUMERS.
BENEFIT ORIENTED NOTICE WITHOUT
COST TO THE STATE WE WORK
CAREFULLY TO ENSURE THAT THIS
VERSION OF THE BILL DOES NOT
IMPOSE. STATE COST OF WHICH HAD
A HUNG UP PRIOR. OF THE BILL
AND THEREFORE URGE SUPPORT.
RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MILLER REPRESENTING EIGHT AND
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ON THAT WE
REPRESENT CONSUMERS OF THE HAVE
REACHED GREAT AGREEMENTS WITH
THE END OF EVERYTHING THAT THAT
THAT THAT REALLY COULD ALL. BE
PART IN A KNOW HOW TO THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITH AND SO. SAYING NO ONE IN
THIS NUMBER TWENTY FOUR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE. CHAU OPPOSITE- TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR TWO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE. FOLLOWED BY
ZERO OR EXCUSE ME FOR NINETY
NINE I APOLOGIZE I WAS GONNA
OPEN LINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO THIRTY SIX.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR- IN HAVE REPRESENTING
SIX BEDS YOU CAN ASSOCIATION OF
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND ASSISTED
LIVING AND- THE FACILITIES IN
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
WE ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
OPPOSITION KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. YOUR POST PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TWO AB.
FOUR NINE NINE. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ANY COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
RESULTING FROM THE STELLAR
STUDENT ESTIMATED TO BE MINOR
AND SEVERAL. ISRAEL WOULD YOU
CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT THIS IS A DO
PASS WOULD ONE OF YOU MAKE A
MOTION. BY MS. MR SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. FROM A BILL FOR
NINETY NINE A MOTIONS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
YOU KNOW I'D BATES BATES ARE
BRADFORD BRADFORD II JONES
CALLS LOGGER LAYERED CASKEY
THREE VOTES FOR THEM I WE'RE
GONNA PLACE THAT I CALL THE LET
THE CALL ON OUR FOR ITEMS IS
BATES CAN VOTE AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA BREAK A GO TO THE. FOR
OUT OR YOU'RE ON CALL TO ME.
GOING BACK TO THE SENATE SIX
THIRTY ONE BY SEN PORTENT THE
MO IS TO THIS FLOOR SENATOR
BATES. RATES ARE AT SEVEN VOTE
THAT BILL IS OUT OF WE'RE GOING
TO BREAK FOR FORCE. AND READ
WE'RE GOING TO. FOR FOREIGN
THEN COME BACK. BUT- HE SAYS
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL RECONVENE IN SIXTY SECONDS.
WE HAVE ONE WILL ON CALL. WHO
ARE WE READING. ALL RIGHT THE
MEETING HAS RECONVENED STARTING
WITH EIGHTY NINE FIFTEEN TO
SMALL AND DISADVANTAGED BILL
THIS BUSINESS ENTERPRISES- THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND WE
HAVE- GOING TO CONVENE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. OR ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY NO. MISTER
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE AND WISHING TO SUPPORT AB.
NINE FIFTEEN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ON THE PHONE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT A. B. NINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS STAR- ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ON THE PHONE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE YEARS NOW MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO AB. NINE FIFTEEN.
GEN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. ALWAYS AB. NINE FIFTY.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
OUR RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE ON NINE
FIFTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO. AND
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT WOULD
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES.
SERVICE REVOLVING FUND COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AS WELL AS TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. ALL RIGHTS WE HAVE
TAKEN THAT SINGLE QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE FIFTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR HCD MISTER
CHAIR YES BUT I ASK A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE WE REALLY
LIKE WE DELIVER THE CALL. ON
THE RUBIO BILL YES I WAS JUST
WAITING FOR A COUPLE OTHER
MEMBERS. IF THAT'S OKAY YOUR DO
YOU WANT ME TO DO IT ALL RIGHT
WE'LL HAVE TO CALL ON- ON MS
RUBIO'S BILL. WHICH IS. AB FOUR
NINE NINE MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR NINETY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATOR LAYERED BY. SENATOR
WHITEHOUSE SKI HI. BETTER JONES
AND CENTER CABALLERO MISSING SO
THAT'S FIVE FOUR SO WE'LL PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOR THE H. C. D. FROM THE BUS
STILL. AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WE'RE GONNA TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR. AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP I WOULD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO AB. FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. YOU ARE OPPOSED
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT FINE INSTEAD OF A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE AND
KNOW THAT ALTHOUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATE
GENERAL FUND COSTS ABOUT EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS WORK WITH
MEDIA CIRCLE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB FOR NINETY
GIPSON ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY POLICIES. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES WAY
PRESENTATIONWILL OPEN UP THE
ROLL CALL ME WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR NINETY. YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF. FOUR NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL AND WE
HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND THEY WILL BE
WITH YOU SHORTLY AGAIN ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. LOW SUPPORT.
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE WITH
OPERATORS OF IOWA OUR FIRST ONE
IS NINE TO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAN
MEMBERS WILLIAM MUNSON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON THAT
THE CONNECTION WHAT THE BY THE
RED CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THIS COMPANY IN
TWENTY FORTY AND IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO FOUR NINETY. YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO FOUR NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE YOU HAVE A FILE.
YES THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ANTICIPATES COST OF TWO HUNDRED
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS LEGAL
RESEARCH LEGAL SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR DRESS
INCREASED WORKLOAD. WOULD
ADDITIONALLY NO. LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES- RETRAIN
PEACE OFFICERS ON THE NEW
POLICY CREATED BY THIS BILL.
AND SUBMIT ASSOCIATED MANDATE
CLAIMS IT IS POSSIBLE THE
COMMISSION STATE MANDATES COULD
FIND THAT SUCH COSTS ARE
REIMBURSED ON WEDNESDAY. ALL
RIGHTS SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOR NINETY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A. B. SIX
FIVE ONE. MISTER GIBSON
ENDOWMENT CARE. CEMETERY SITS A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION OF A RIGHT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
FIVE ONE. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIVE ONE. AND
WE HAVE SOMEONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE AND AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO EIGHT. PART. AND
WE GO TO LINE FIVE ZERO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M JUDY
WASH BACK I HAVE SIX FAMILY
MEMBERS BURIED IN THE HUNDRED
WITH FIFTEEN YEAR OLD WOODLAWN
MEMORIAL PARK IN COMPTON. I
WOULD LINE'S DEPLORABLE
CONDITION INSPIRED BILL EIGHTY
SIX FIFTY ONE CURRENTLY
REFERRED TO AS JUSTICE FOR
WOODLAWN. EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE
IS A MUCH NEEDED IMPROVEMENT
WHICH WILL HELP MANY CEMETERIES
WE NEED FINANCIALLY SOUND
HOWEVER THANK YOU WRITTEN THIS
BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS WOODLAWN
THANK TO MY CHERRIES LIKE IT
BETTER CURRENT. ALL RIGHT I'M
SORRY BUT YOU WERE NOT ON THE-
LEAD WITNESS LIST AND SO WE'RE
STICKING TO THE- NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. SO
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIX FIVE ONE. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SIX FIVE ONE. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP TIME
OVER OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SIX FIVE ONE. AGAIN
ONE NINE ZERO. YOU ARE OPPOSED.
EIGHTY SIX FIVE ONE. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ESTIMATES ONGOING COST
OF ONE HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE CEMETERY IN
GENERAL FUND ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE TO
THE REQUIREMENT FOR COUNTIES TO
MAINTAIN THE CEMETERY IN THE
ABSENCE OF A TEMPORARY MANAGER
STATE COSTS COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT DEPENDING ON HOW
MUCH MONEY IS AVAILABLE IN EACH
CEMETERIES AND DOWN TRUST FUND.
AND HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
APPOINT A TEMPORARY MANAGER
ONCE THE COUNTY ASSUMES
RESPONSIBILITY. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX FIVE ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE
A. B. NINE FIVE EIGHT GIPSON
PEACE OFFICERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
GANGS- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT A. B. NINE FIVE EIGHT.
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FIVE EIGHT. AND WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN SUPPORT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BYLINE. TO NINETY. GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA THANKS FOR
VISITING LEFT HANDLE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE FIVE EIGHT THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT OVER OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED THE NINE FIVE EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB. FIVE NINE FIVE
EIGHT. AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE OPPOSE AB. NINE FIVE EIGHT.
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ANTICIPATED FISCAL
IMPACT OF FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND NINETY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION IS NOT
IDENTIFIED QUANTIFIABLE COST
BUT NOTED THE BILL MAY CREATE A
KNOWN GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES. LAST ATTENTION A
SIGNIFICANT STATE REVERSAL
MANDATE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
ADOPT NEW POLICIES AS THEY
RELATE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT GANGS.
ALL RIGHT SENIOR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE FIVE
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
TEN THIRTY EIGHT GIPSON ON
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAMS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE TO
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT AB TEN
THIRTY EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRD
ONE ZERO THREE EIGHT. AND OUR
FIRST PERSON IS LYING TO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WILLIAM MUNSON BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE TO NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD- THEY THEY-
NINETY COULD GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN IS
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. SIT
AFTERNOON THAT EFFECTIVE TODAY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN COURT. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CAN A CHECK FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MODELING
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKS WERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. BY NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
WE ARE GETTING NO RESPONSE MY
NINETY EIGHT AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE CAN HEARING. THERE YOU GO
PLEASE SPEAK UP BOTH NON GAME
ENOUGH- OKAY MY NAME IS OUR
STUDENTS THROUGH. YOU GOT
BEHALF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE A CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL COMING IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK ALL RIGHT DROP
AND WE ARE NOW HOUSING Q. ALL
RIGHT NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSE OR SOMEBODY TWENTY
FORTY. PLEASE GIVE ANYONE
OPPOSED TO AB. TEN THIRTY
EIGHT. AND IF ANYONE IS OPPOSED
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
EIGHT B. TEN THIRTY EIGHT. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ON
THE PHONE. ALL RIGHT I WILL GO
TO FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. I WOULD
KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND JUST PASTE
THE NEED FOR FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND I'M GOING TO CARRY OUT THE
ACTIVITIES OUTLINED IN THE
BILL. WHAT IT IS I KNOW THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO
APPEAR TO BE DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AND THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION ABTEN THIRTY
EIGHT WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE I GIPSON
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
HE'S WAVE BUT WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IN THIS ROOM THERE IS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NINERS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. WHAT WE
DO OF SAN WORD I'M SORRY AND
YOUR ANY BIG PEAK CALIFORNIA
MERGING TECHNOLOGY IS ON THE
COASTLINE MICROCLIMATE STEAK.
THANK YOU- THE CHAIR PORTANTINO
AND BY SIR BATES AND SENATORS-
THIS IS SENDING ME PEAK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MERGING
TECHNOLOGY FUND- WE'RE HERE TO
UNDERSCORE THE COMMITTEE.
REPORT THAT SAID THERE IS MINOR
AND OBSERVABLE COSTS FOR AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IN FACT
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS OF FOR AND THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER.
THE PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND AS THEY HAVE
SINCE IT WAS ESTABLISHED BY.
NOW SENATOR BRADFORD IN IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN- THERE IS OF
NO ADDITIONAL COST THE P. UC
STAFF HAS DONE BILL MAKING
RECENTLY IN FACT IT'S OPEN.
THEY'VE ADMINISTERED GRANTS OUT
OF THE PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT
IN THE LAST YEAR AND THEY'RE
PREPARED TO CONTINUE TO DO SO.
MOREOVER THE FUNDING FOR THE
FIRST YEAR. IS CURRENTLY. BY
THE LEGISLATURE WAS AUTHORIZED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THERE AFTER THE AUTHORIZATION
FOR THE CONTINUED FUNDING IS AN
S. B. FOR THAT HAS BEEN PASSED
OUT OF. THE SENATE WE URGE-
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT THAT'S
WHY THERE IS SUPPORT FROM ALL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE
INCLUDING IN THE- THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES- HOUSING AUTHORITY-
IN CENTER BRADFORD DISTRICT AND
ALSO. EVEN HOUSING IN SENATOR
BY KASKI DISTRICT. THANK YOU
SIR ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU AGAIN
AND PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. AND OUR
FIRST PERSON IN LINE REAL ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DONNA THANK REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON WORK PACKET GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
THE PARTS. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
TO EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WILL
IMAGINE BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE TO NINETY EIGHT. HERNANDEZ
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER THANK
YOU THREE DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. AND OUTWARD
SUPPORT FOR TWO TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIR PORTANTINO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS LORRAINE
KINDRED VICE PRESIDENT PUBLIC
AFFAIRS NATIONAL COMMUNITY
RENAISSANCE AS CO SPONSOR AND
FOR THE ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE IN
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW
DECLINED TO NINETY NINE.
SEPENUH CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WALKED IN WITH A LOT THAT'S NOT
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM COME ON UP LINE UP.
TO OPPOSE FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
FIRST BERNIE OROZCO CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE THIS IS ALREADY
COVERED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BROADBAND FOR ALL SB ONE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. PICTURE WE ARE
CALIFORNIANS WHO REALLY WANT TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BY
MAKING A DECENT DEFINITION OF
BROADBAND NOT THE TEN MEGABIT
DOWNLOAD ONE MEGABIT UP
DEFINITION IN THIS BILL YOU'RE
NOT EVEN HELPING THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A BOLD
ENOUGH VISION. FOR HOW MUCH
THEY NEED. WHEN AT SEVEN FOR
NEVADA CITY TELECOM SAFETY
COMMITTEE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY OVER THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
THE BILL WILL NOT RESULT IN
INCREASED ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND IS CURRENTLY IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT FROM
CONSISTENT YEAR OVER YEAR
DECLINE IN INTEREST STATE VOICE
REVENUES THAT SUPPORT THE FUND.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
TOTAL REVENUE FOR THE CAST F.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WAS
CLOSE TO THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT IS C. PC WERE
TO EXECUTE THE PROVISION OF.
THIS BILL AND TRANSFER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TO THE FRONT DESK TO THE PUBLIC
HOUSING ACCOUNT IT WOULD BE
MORE THAN HALF OF ALL CURRENTLY
EXPECTED TO CAST OF REVENUE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SENIOR
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE HAVE ALREADY DONE
AB FOUR NINE NINE BY RUBIO.
TIME CALL SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
RUBIO UNLAWFUL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. THIRTY
THANK YOU PLAY PRESS. THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND LINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
THREE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. NINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. ALL RIGHT
LEVINE OF AN ACCOUNTING YOU.
I'M SORRY. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WOULD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSES NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY OPPOSES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU- WE
HAVE- RETURNS A LINE OF THREE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
THREE HUNDRED ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT AM SO PLEASE SPEAK. NINE
THREE HUNDRED IS BATTING OVER
TO. YEP AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT RESULT IN ADDITIONAL ONGOING
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TRIAL. FURTHER IT IS NOT
CLEAR IF THESE COSTS WOULD BE
FULLY REIMBURSED BY CIVIL
PENALTIES COLLECTED PURSUANT TO
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT WE WILL- GO
TO OUR COLLEAGUES NO QUESTIONS
SO THAT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A. B.
TWELVE FORTY THREE RUBIO
PROTECTIVE ORDERS ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WITH THE WAVE
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOBODY
THERE. WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWELVE FORTY
THREE ONE NINE ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION- AND I SEE NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. YOU ARE
OPPOSED PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
CHLORITE FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DOES NOT ESTIMATE
FISCAL IMPACTS FOR NEW AND
EXPANDED CAUSES OF CIVIL ACTION
WE KNOW THAT ANY INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD IS LIKELY MINOR CIRCLE.
ALL RIGHTS SENIOR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
FORTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON AB FIVE ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. ON
SECURITIES TRANSACTIONS AS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING. IN THIS
ROOM IS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWELFTH TWENTY
FORTY LETTERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
ELEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE
ELEVEN. AND WE HAVE NO WARNING
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FIVE
ELEVEN. GARBO'S PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'VE KNOWN QUEUING UP OUR AYE
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION IN
INNOVATION ESTIMATE COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE FINAL
FINANCIAL PROTECTION FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND SIX HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING. ALL
RIGHT NO QUESTIONS SO AB FIVE
ELEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN BYE MURATSUCHI ON HATE
CRIME HOTLINE. ASSIST SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAVE WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORTING AB FIVE
FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN. AND WE DO HAVE- WILL GO
TO THE LINE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
ELIZABETH HENRY FROM LAFAYETTE-
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN.
SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE FIVE SEVEN.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE OF
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU KNOW LOUIS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR A LENNY COULD UNLOCK
IT IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA POSITION A
FIVE FIVE SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THEY'RE COMING
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB FIVE FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. AB. FIVE
FIVE SEVEN. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT THE
FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COST BETWEEN
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND TWO TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING. FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS
MEASURE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT OBJECTION AB
FIVE FIVE SEVEN GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE IN AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT PER MURATSUCHI
DEMOGRAPHICS ANCESTRY AND
ETHNIC ORIGIN. IT IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO
TESTIFY WE'RE GOING TO FROM
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THEIR-
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY. EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO HAVE SOMEONE COMING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. DID YOU SAY WE
HAD SOMEBODY READ NO ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KATHLEEN GARGANO IN
THE HOUSE THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NORTH
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTER AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED IS NOW IN AROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSED TO AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. OUR RIGHTS WILL GO
TO FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES COST OF
THREE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE. FOR INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY POSITIONS AND NINETY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT CONTRACT COSTS WITH UC
SAN DIEGO. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ESTIMATES ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COSTS BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. ALL RIGHTS NO
QUESTIONS FOR FINANCE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CRISIS ACT.
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING AT
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WE'RE GOING TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. WILL OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT. OF AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION. LINE UP FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE GO AHEAD MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY QUEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW NOW HOLD ON ONE SECOND
WE HAVE ONE MORE DIRECTING TRIP
PORTANTINO WE ARE CALIFORNIANS
WHO SUPPORTS TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO CLEAN ATMOSPHERE ACT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO GO TO ZERO EMISSIONS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO SHIFT FROM
WIRELESS. TO FIBER OPTIC IT'S
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TIMES MORE
ENERGY EFFICIENT I KNEW THE
SAME AMOUNT OF DATA WE OPPOSE
THE BILL ALL RIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
PROJECTS OF BOTH OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND NOW TO
LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE THREE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RECOGNITION MEMBERS JAMES
THEREAFTER THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL FLAVORS IN OPPOSITION
TO THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND NOW TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY MODERATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSATILITY JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. YOUR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRES
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS I TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING. ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES COST OF
200-500-0025 HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO WORK
WITH THE BOARD TO ESTABLISH
CRITERIA FOR THE USE OF NATURE
BASED CLIENT SOLUTIONS. THANK
YOU. OUR RIGHTS SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE ABOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN BY CORK.
COMMUNICATIONS WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS- WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND WE
HAVE. TWO SPEAKERS WHO ARE HERE
IN PERSON AS OUR PRIMARY
SUPPORT. WITNESSES LINED UP THE
TWO OF YOU. BONTA THEIR
OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZED.
THERE'S NO ONE IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND TO THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M JULIE LEVINE WITH
FIVE G. PRE CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT THE SHORTENED
TIME CLOCKS MEDINA APPROVAL
TAKES AWAY ALL LOCAL CONTROL
THE THREE MOST RECENT FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA RESULTING IN ORDER
TO CLOSELY AND DOLLAR COST TO
TAXPAYERS WHAT'S GOING ON BY
TELECOM M. AND ON TRAILS I URGE
YOU TO RECONSIDER THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT
TESTIMONY ON. FIVE THREE SEVEN.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. RIGHT NOW WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION SO GO AHEAD THE TWO
OF YOU GOT THREE MINUTES.
HOPEFULLY DON'T TAKE HOURS GO
AHEAD MY KNEES WERE THAT SADDAM
FORMER CITY COUNCILMEMBER MERIT
NEVADA CITY CALIFORNIA HONOR
BOWL CHAIR PORTANTINO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. I MEAN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THE DEEMED
APPROVED DEAN PERMITS ISSUED
WIRELESS BILL THE FISCAL ISSUE.
IS MASSIVE LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
RAN INTO A SEVERE ROADBLOCK
ONLY DAYS AGO ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE MUST HEED THE
HISTORIC U. S. COURT OF APPEAL
RULING AGAINST THE FCC AND IT'S
OF MICROWAVE RADIATION EXPOSURE
GUIDELINE. IN CASE NUMBER
TWENTY DASH TEN TWENTY FIVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH TRUST
VERSES THE FCC THE PETITIONERS
ARGUED THAT THE FCC IGNORED
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF PEER
REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
AND TESTIMONY. AND THE FTC'S
RECORDS THAT INCLUDE MANY
HARMFUL DIRECT IMMEDIATE SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM ADVERSE
EFFECTS FROM WIRELESS REDUCE
RADIATION BLACK WAVE. TO HUMANS
WILDLIFE AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
IN FCC ORDER NINETEEN DASH ONE
TWENTY SIXTH OF DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE FCC
SIMPLY A PINE THE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX RADIO FREQUENCY
MICROWAVE RADIATION EXPOSURE
GUIDELINES. DID NOT NEED TO BE
UPDATED THE FCC THEN PROCEEDED
TO EXTENDED SCIENTIFICALLY
UNSOUND GUIDELINES UP UNTIL
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SPECIFIC ABSORPTION RATE
APPLIED ONLY. TO CARRY
FREQUENCIES UP TO SIX THOUSAND
MEGAHERTZ THE FCC GET TEMPTED
TO DO TWO THINGS IN ORDER
NINETEEN DASH ONE TWENTY SIX.
FIRST EXTEND THE GUIDELINE TO
COVER CARRIER FREQUENCIES UP TO
A HUNDRED THOUSAND MEGAHERTZ
FROM SIX THOUSAND TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
POWER OUTPUT BY INCREASING THE
PEAK. TO AVERAGE RATIO OF SUCH
WIRELESS SIGNALS MORE THAN
TWENTY TIMES. ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH ONLY DAYS AGO THAT
DE FACTO FCC RULEMAKING WAS
RULED BY THE AT THE DC CIRCUIT
JUDGES. TO BE ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS AND THEREFORE.
UNLAWFUL THE STATE CANNOT PASS
BILLS THAT SUBSIDIZE WIRELESS
EXPANSION WHEN THE INDUSTRY HAS
NO RADIO FREQUENCY MICROWAVE.
RADIATION GUIDELINE FOR
FREQUENCIES HIGHER THAN SIX
THOUSAND MEGAHERTZ PLEASE. R.
THREE SEVEN AND SUSPENSE IT
YOUR BILL. EVERY SINGLE CELL
TOWER ABOUT SIX OF THE MAKE IT
HURTS WHICH IS ALMOST ALL OF
THEM MUST IMMEDIATELY BE
POWERED OFF BECAUSE THERE'S NO
GUIDELINE ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
MEGAHERTZ THAT IS THE GAME
CHANGER THAT OCCURRED WITH THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION ON
AUGUST THIRTEENTH WE MUST NOW
WAIT FOR THE FCC ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK BEFORE APPROVING ANYMORE
TELCOM BILLS LIKE AB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT SHE LEFT YOU
FORTY FIVE SECONDS. I THINK.
THIS IS COURT OF APPEALS AND SO
I THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
CALIFORNIA STATE LAWS CANNOT
VIOLATE FEDERAL ACTS BECAUSE
THESE LAWS. COULD EASILY
BANKRUPT LOCALITIES OF CREDITS
MUST FOLLOW THE EIGHTY EIGHT FJ
THAT NEPA AND I DO NOT SIX
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ACT ITSELF
HEY WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
ACT PROMOTING SAFETY OF LIFE
AND PROPERTY. IT WAS STATED
TWICE. AB FIVE THREE SEVEN ITS
COMPANION BILLS SB 556-378-8014
TO THE EXTENT THEY ARE NOT
ACTUALLY TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. I
DO NOT PROMOTE THE SAFETY OF
LIFE AND PROPERTY CLEARLY
VIOLATE THESE FEDERAL LACKS.
THE SEC'S BEEN A SERIAL LOSER
IN THE U. S. COURTS OF APPEAL
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
INCLUDING THE ONE ON FRIDAY.
BUT THESE RULES MANDATE THE FCC
MUST FIRST COMPLETE SUBSTANTIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF ONE
MILLION CELL TOWERS BEFORE
CONSTRUCTED PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR A TIME PLEASE.
PERMANENTLY SUSPENDED THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YOU'RE ONLY ELEVEN
SECONDS. BOB LEFT. NO WE WERE
OVER A LOT OF. ONLY ELEVEN. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SIR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN. AND PURSUE GO
TO LINE THREE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE **** I WAS SAFE
CHECK FOR SANTA ROSA BUT THE
SENDING HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS RESPOND
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HELD IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
TO SEVENTY NINE. YES CHEN
MEMBERS WITH CATHERINE DODD
WITH THAT TELL ME A LINE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE NURSES FOR
A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING PHYSICIANS PERFECT
TECHNOLOGY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH TRUST THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP. POSITIONS SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY SAN FRANCISCO
BAY CHAPTER THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
MEDICINE THE CALIFORNIA BRAIN
TUMOR ASSOCIATION GMO SCIENCE.
CALIFORNIANS FOR ENERGY CHOI
CENTER FOR DEMOCRATIC AN
ENVIRONMENTAL BY. GRASSROOTS
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION HELP
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF
BIODIVERSITY. THE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH STATEWIDE
NON TOXIC NEIGHBORHOODS THE
ECOLOGICAL OPTIONS NETWORK AND
HOURS SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YES I'M
I'M SORRY I SPOKE OUT OF QUEUE
BEFORE I'M JULIE LEVINE-
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION ALSO
REPRESENTING FIVE G. PRE
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED- MEMBERS- I AM
CONCERNED THAT UP WITH A
SHORTENED TIME CLOCK AND THE
GAME APPROVAL TAKING AWAY MORE
EVEN MORE SURNAME IN
ORGANIZATION MODERATOR REALLY.
WE GOT TO MOVE ON THANK YOU
JUST GET YOUR NAME IN OUR
POPULATION NAME AN ORGANIZATION
AT THIS POINT. NEXT BIGGER.
THANK YOU AND THAT COMES TO
MIND TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CATHERINE THE OTHER GAME I
FORGOT TO MENTION IN OPPOSITION
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR ALL
RIGHT NEXT WEEK FROM TOXIC.
THANK YOU ALKALINE. THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN. HELLO
THIS IS JOHANNA **** WITH THE
NEVADA COUNTY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PUBLIC
WORKING GROUP AND WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND NOW TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD CARE OF THEM
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SIR AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BERMAN FINANCE. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ESTIMATES WILL HAVE NO FISCAL
IMPACT FROM THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW THAT AT
THE BILL'S NOT ANTICIPATED TO
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE. AS A AFFECTED LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
LEVY SERVICE CHARGES FEES OR
ASSESSMENTS SUFFICIENT TO COVER
ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS. ALL
RIGHTS EMAIL QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WTHOUT OBJECTION AB
FIVE THREE SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. AB FIVE FOUR FIVE BY
CORK UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURES AND TO
SUSPEND CANDIDATES. CALPERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. GO TO
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE WE'LL
SEE IF THERE'S ANY SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE FOR AB FIVE FOUR
FIVE. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE FOUR FIVE. AND MY MOMENT
PLEASE. ANYBODY THERE. WE HAVE
WHILE WE GO TO LINE OF TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ WITH
OPENING KIND YOU'RE ON BEHALF%
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION OF THE PORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT OVER OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO FIVE FOUR FIVE.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO FIVE FOUR FIVE. AND
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT FINANCE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATES ONE TIME COST OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO COMPLETE THE
REPORT ADDITIONALLY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD S. ACOSTA
FORTY FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AND FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND THEN IT
CANNOT BEGIN THE WORK UNTIL
APPROXIMATELY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHEN RESOURCES
BECOME AVAILABLE. ALL RIGHTS
EMAIL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FOUR FIVE
GOES TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON A.
B. SEVEN OH SEVEN BY MISTER
CORK DR COURT. MERCURY
THERMOSTAT COLLECTION ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH
NOBODY HERE. WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE SO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN OF SEVEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE NINE ZERO
IF YOU ARE JUST FOUR OF EIGHTY
SEVEN OH SEVEN. WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. OUR RIGHTS WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SEVEN
OF SEVEN. FAN ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO AB SEVEN OH
SEVEN. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS A BILL CAPS THE
REASONABLE REGULATORY COSTS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO OVERSEE
THE QUALIFIED THIRD PARTY AT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL COULD
EXCEED THAT AMOUNT.
ADDITIONALLY THE TIME LINES IN
THIS BILL DO NOT APPEAR
FEASIBLE AND WE AND CAL RECYCLE
ADMINISTERS THE STATE'S OTHER
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAMS IT
APPEARS TO BE BETTER EQUIPPED.
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVEN OH SEVEN GOES TO SUSPENSE
AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR. AND
CHILD CARE INDIVIDUALIZED
COUNTY CHECKERED SUBSIDY PLANS
IT'S DISPENSED CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAVE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. SO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS. TWELVE NINETY FOUR.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP
WE'RE OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TWELVE NINETY FOUR.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE OPPOSE
PLEASE QUEUE UP NOW. WE HAVE NO
WARNING Q. R. AYE FINANCE I
FOUND THIS YEAR NO FILE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
TWELVE NINETY FOUR GOES TO
SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE ON TO AB
FIVE SEVEN SIX BY MAIENSCHEIN
ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES. OR
SHIPMENTS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMON ROOM
THREE TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT AB FIVE SEVENTY SIX.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY TWENTY ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO FIVE
SEVENTY SIX. IN ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING UP
OUR OWN FINANCE EUROPE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE STUDENTS
ON MILITARY BASES ARE ALREADY
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN EXISTING
OPEN COURSE OFFERINGS INCLUDING
ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BECAUSE THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL GREAT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES IN THE LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR
APPORTIONMENT- NOT ACCOUNTED
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX GOES TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB FIVE
SEVEN NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA ON FIRE PREVENTION IT'S A
SUSPENSE KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
MONTEREY IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF AB FIVE
SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WELL
GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO FIVE SEVEN NINE.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE AB. FIVE
SEVENTY NINE. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP FINANCE. THANK YOU
HOW FAR DOES NOT ESTIMATED
FISCAL IMPACT FOR THIS BILL I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE PRISON
INDUSTRY AUTHORITY. SIGNIFICANT
FISCAL IMPACT SINCE DIVERTING
CALPERS BUSINESS FROM THE
AUTHORITY WOULD DIRECTLY IMPACT
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
LEARNING JOB SKILLS AT
MILLCREEK STATE PRISON WITHOUT
THIS REVENUE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHABILITATION-
ESTIMATE THAT IT COULD COST
STATE APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
ALL RIGHTS SEEING THEIR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB TWELVE
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLOOR. AND CONSUMER WARRANTIES
THAT TO SUSPEND KENNEDY'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. FROM FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE. IS THERE
ANYONE- ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. TWELVE TWENTY ONE.
IN ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU LIKE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT OPPOSITION AT TWELVE
TWENTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE TWENTY ONE. AGAIN ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE POSED AB
TWELVE. ANYONE. WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO FINANCE. BERMAN OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS ESTIMATES COST OF ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING ON THE
ELECTRONIC AND APPLIANCE REPAIR
FUND TO ADDRESS ADDED COMPLAINT
WORKLOAD FROM CONSUMERS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE TWENTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON A. B. SIX
NINETEEN BY CALDERON ON AIR
QUALITY IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OTHERS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE AND FILL
FORTY TWO OH THREE NOBODY'S
HERE WILL GO TO ROOM TWELVE
FORTY NOBODY'S THERE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO SEE IF
ANYONE WANTS TO SUPPORT AB SIX
NINETEEN. THANK YOU AND YOU
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT ORDER
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX NINETEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OF
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE- OPPOSED. TO SIX
NINETEEN. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE SB SIX NINETY. WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT THE FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES COST OF FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AND ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. AND CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT ESTIMATES
COST OF ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND I'M GOING. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX
NINETEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB SIX SEVENTY BY CALDERON ON
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT. AND IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AUTHORS
WAVE WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE FORTY TWO OH
THREE. NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO
ROOM- TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE WILL OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SIX SEVEN ZERO. ALL RIGHT AGAIN
WHEN THEY'RE ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI SIX SEVENTY. AND WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE COMING UP FROM THE LINE
OF TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KIND OF CHECK FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
THE COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION IS FOR
SIX SEVENTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION. TO SIX SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB SIX SEVENTY.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT FINANCE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE ESTIMATE THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS RANGING FROM
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
HELLO MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX SEVEN THE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON AB
TWELVE FIFTY BY CALDERON. ON
WATER AND SEWER SYSTEM
CORPORATIONS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WITH THE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PRESS THE PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY
TWO OR THREE NOBODY'S HERE. THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
IS ANYONE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINE OF TWELVE
FIFTY. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI. TWELVE FIFTY.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
TO TWELVE FIFTY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO TWELVE
FIFTY. N. ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO OPPOSE AB TWELVE FIFTY.
I HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT FINANCE EUROPE AGAIN. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ESTIMATES COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING. C. UTILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT ACCOUNT. REVENUE
FROM THIS ACCOUNT COMES
RESEARCH CHARGE AND WOULD
RESULT IN APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
EIGHT CENTS PER YEAR TO COVER
THIS ADDITIONAL COST. WE DO NOT
THAT THE FUNDING COULD BE
OFFSET TO SOME DEGREE BY THE
NEW CONSOLIDATION FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER FUND UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU SIGNAL
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE FIFTY WOULD GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANADA AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT GO AHEAD
SIR. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY QUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM SO A MOVE TO TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THERE IS ANYONE N THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
EIGHTY. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
EIGHTY. AND WE GO TO THE LINE
OF THREE HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- JAMES
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE. COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SECRETING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MODELING COOPER ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE REMAIN AND THAT THE PART OF
AMENDED PETITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED AB.
SIX EIGHTY. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED AB. SIXTY AND WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
FINANCE. YOUR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES COST OF THREE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AN HOUR AGO I KNOW I'M
GOING TO THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. THE REPORT OF ELEMENT
BOARD ESTIMATES COST OF ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ON GOING.
AND THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY NO EXTRA COST OF THE
STORE UNKNOWN BUT ESTIMATES
COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
FINALLY THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH ESTIMATES COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE KEEP
GREENHOUSE. GAS REDUCTION FUND.
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND I'M GOING. ALL RIGHTS
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. SIX EIGHTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB SIX
NINETY TWO BY WALDRON. THE LAKE
WILL FOR DAM THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. DAUGHTERS WAY
PRESENTATION IS NOBODY HERE
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THEIR MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
OF AB. SIX NINE TWO. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI SIX
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION TO SIX NINE TWO
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN A
OPPOSED TO SIX NINE TWO. IN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AND AB SIX NINE TWO.
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. FILE MISTER
CHAIR NO FILED NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX NINE
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. AB
SEVEN SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT ON COURT ACCESS TO
SUSPEND SCATTERED OFF HIS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
VETERANS TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN
SIXTEEN. AND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
ONLINE TO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
PENSION AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. VOTE
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO SEVEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR AB SEVEN SIXTEEN.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO FINANCE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHAT THE
COURTS HAVE INVESTED IN
TECHNOLOGIES DURING THE PAST
YEAR TO IMMEDIATELY ALLOW FOR
REMOTE ACCESS FOR PARTICIPANTS.
THE ADDITIONAL ON. KNOWLEDGE IN
STAFFING TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
ARE LIKELY SIGNIFICANT. DIGITAL
COUNCIL INDICATES COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY IN THE RANGE OF
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING. ALL
RIGHTS SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN SIXTEEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE. AB EIGHT
NINETY SIX BY BENNETT ON OIL
AND GAS WELLS IT'S A SENSE
SPENCE CANDIDATE THE OPPOSITE
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. VETERANS
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
NINE SIX. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT NINE SIX.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- BUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE OR SOMEBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED EIGHT NINE SIX. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU LIKE TO OPPOSE AB EIGHT
NINE SIX. AND WE HAVE KNOWN IN
Q. OUR AYE FINANCE THANK YOU
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
INDICATES COST OF ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS OIL
GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FUND. IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING. IF THE DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENTS AN IN HOUSE
COLLECTIONS UNIT. ESTIMATES THE
BILL REQUIRE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FRONT
IN THE FIRST YEAR AND ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON KELLY.
ALL RIGHT SEE O QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB. EIGHT
NINE SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON A V. TEN FIFTY ONE.
BY MISTER BENNETT ON MEDICAL
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR FOSTER YOUTH IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. OTHERS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. AND WE'LL SEE IF
ANYBODY WANTS TESTIFIED SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. TEN FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE EXPRESSED
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NOTING Q.
WITHOUT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSES
OPENING TWENTY FORTY OPPOSES
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TEN FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB TEN
FIFTY ONE. WE HAVE NO ONE TO
CLEAN UP ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO FINANCE. FILE THIS YEAR NO
FILE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TEN FIFTY ONE GOES
TO SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K.
HAND ON COUNTY JAILS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS. IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE SO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF S. B. C.
ME AB SEVEN THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP. BUT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO P. LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
WHAT. AND I HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP. ALL RIGHT FINANCEIRO. WHERE
TO STAY IN COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS ESTIMATES INITIAL
ONE TIME COST OF APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
STAFFING. WOULD ALSO KNOWN.
MEMBERS OF THE STATE MANDATE.
SHARE FINISH TRYING TO COMPILE
AND SUBMIT SPECIFIED DATA. TO
THE COMMISSION THANK YOU WITH
NO QUESTIONS AB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION FLEW IN AB
TEN THIRTY THREE OUR QUE HANNAH
AND CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS
ACT. IT IS A SUSPENSE CANADA
OFFERS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING HERE
AT FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY NOBODY THERE. FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TEN THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
CONNECT EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR A
BI AND. THIRTY THREE. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO A POSITION OF TEN
THIRTY THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU ALSO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY AND THIRTY
THREE. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP. THERE NOBODY
QUEUEING UP FACILITATED SUPPORT
OPPOSITION MISS THE FINANCE
EUROPE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE AS
IT FURTHERS THE USE OF
AVAILABLE THESE BENEFITS
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOALS WITHOUT
INCREASING COSTS GIVEN THE
RECENT AUGMENTATIONS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. ALL
RIGHT TO SAY NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN THIRTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX POWER
CADENCE AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING. IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
WE'RE GOING TO RUN TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THERE. AND WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE GO TO THE
LINE OF FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT THANK YOUNG BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER. BURKE
ON BEHALF OF NAY ROUTE LOOKS
LIKE CALIFORNIA AND REPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSEIN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE NINE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LATEST SIR ANYBODY THERE. WE
HAVE PEOPLE ONE MONTHLY THEN WE
GO TO LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB
NEAL REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD
AND COMPANY OPPOSED TO A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS COREY DURAN AND I
AM WITH THE RIGHT TO LIKELY TO
SEVEN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. THREE FIFTY
SIX. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHTS WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. FINANCE NEVER FILE. SHARE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND SIX
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING ESTIMATES COST FIFTY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND CONTINUING
BIANNUALLY THEREAFTER LASTLY
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS ESTIMATES COST
OF UP TO FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ONTO AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE BY PARA QUE HAN
ON OFF HIGHWAY VEHICULAR
RECREATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF.
FIFTEEN TWELVE. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE.
AND WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED THERE'S NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED TO ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO AB
FIFTEEN TWELFTH. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED TO AB. FIFTEEN TWELVE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE GO TO
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH THIS
IS BRUCE WHICH ARE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA OFF HIGHWAY-
LEGISLATIVE COALITION WERE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES STATE PARKS
USED PLAN FOR PURPOSES OTHER
THAN WHICH IT WAS PURCHASED
FOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT FORMER FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION ESTIMATES THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE EIGHT POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. THREE CLASSIFIED
LAMEDA TESLA EXPANSIONARY AS A
PRISONER. THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND WHICH IS
GENERALLY RESTRICTED FOR USE
THAT PARKS ARMENIAN ALTERNATIVE
FUND SOURCE FOR THESE COST AS
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT UP TO
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
PROVIDED TO THE FUND TO BE USED
FOR CONSERVATION PURPOSES FOR
THIS AREA. HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT WHILE THE BILL
MANDATES THAT PART :KS
OTHER ENTITIES TO PROVIDE THE
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT THE FUNDING BE
PROVIDED. AND IF NO FUNDING
MATERIALIZES A GENERAL FUND
LIKE THINK IT REQUIRES. ALL
RIGHT SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN TWELVE AGO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
SEVEN SIX TWO LEAD HAZARDOUS
EMISSIONS AND SUBSTANCES. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE ON HIS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING OR FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
GO TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT SEVEN
SIX TWO. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU LIKE- EXPRESSED
SUPPORT AND FIRST IN LINE TO
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT EXPORT. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE THREE THIRTY. BUT
YES ALLEN ADDS TO THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
IN SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND OUTLINED. THREE THIRTY
THREE. JOHNSON CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO. ANGELINA GOOD
SHARES ON BEHALF OF THE L. A.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING OPPOSITION TO SEVEN SIXTY
TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
IS NOW BEING TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO SEVEN SIX TWO.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO FINANCE. ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
IS UNLIKELY TO RESULT IN A
DIRECT FISCAL IMPACT TO THE
STATE WE KNOW THAT IT MAY
INCREASE COSTS AND TIMELINES
FOR PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT SEEKING
STATE FUNDING TO ACQUIRE A NEW
SCHOOL SITES BY ANOTHER
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT.
RENDITION WE NOTE THAT FOR THE
MEDICATION ESTIMATES UNKNOWN
ONGOING STATE OPERATIONS COSTS
TO REVIEW AND UPDATE STATE
RULES AND REGULATIONS. AS
REQUIRED BY THE STILL ARE
RISING UP QUESTIONS THAT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN SIX TWO WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE EIGHT.
FIVE ON CRIMINAL RECORDS BY MR
LEE IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION. AND WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. NOBODY'S HERE
NOBODY'S IN TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT NINE EIGHT.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME BUT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
NINE EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY
FORTY IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED EIGHT NINE EIGHT.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION- AB. EIGHT NINE
EIGHT AND ONE MORE PLACE. IN
ONE THEN ZERO AND TO THE LINE
OF THREE HUNDRED AND NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS SOCIAL WHAT WITH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING THE
COMMISSION HAS TAKEN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB
EIGHT NINE EIGHT BECAUSE IT
UNINTENTIONALLY WILL PREVENT
THE COMMISSION PROCEEDING
RECORDS FROM THE SUPERIOR
COURT. THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
DETERMINE FITNESS FOR LICENSURE
AND MANDATED BY LAW. REQUIRED
TO REVIEW ALL MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES INCLUDING THE
FOLLOWING IN ALL CASES.
ANNOYING OR MOLESTING A CHILD
PROTECTION OF CHILD **** SEXUAL
BATTERY MISDEMEANOR DUI WITH
INJURY. TO A MANSLAUGHTER
WITHOUT CALL BUT WITHOUT GROSS
NEGLIGENCE THEME A FEW. WITHOUT
A PROPOSED AMENDMENT STATED IN
OUR LETTER TO STILL PUT SCHOOL
CHILDREN AT SERIOUS RISK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT- WE WILL GO
TO FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
FINGERPRINT FINGERPRINT FEES
ACCOUNTED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AN ON GOING TO UPDATE CRIMINAL
RECORDS DATABASES TO IMPLEMENT
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE- STILL.
ALL RIGHTS ENOUGH QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB EIGHT
NINE EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON THE A. B. SEVEN SIX
FOUR CERVANTES CONTEMPT OF
COURT VICTIM INTIMIDATION. THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN TWELVE
FORTY. TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN SIX FOUR. THANK YOU AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI. SEVEN SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD- WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
LINE OF. TWO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HIS APPEAL
STORED ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. AND FORMER
STAFF AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WE ARE A PROUD CO SPONSORS.
SEVEN SIX FOUR AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
Q. I ORDERED OPPOSITION SEVEN
SIX FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS COMPANY ON IN TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE. OPPOSED. TO
SEVEN SIX FOUR. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE OUR RIGHTS WE WILL GO
TO FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BUT DO YOU KNOW
CONCERNED THAT IT COULD RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL CASES ENTERING
THE COURT SYSTEM BY EXPANDING
THE DEFINITION OF A CRIME. I
JAIL SENTENCE OR FINEOR BOTH.
THANK YOU R. I. C. NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SEVEN SIX
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
RHIANNA LEVIN EIGHTY FIVE BY
CERVANTES STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
CAL GRANT- WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. SOMEBODY IN THIS
ROOM IS ON THE TWENTY FORTIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR A BI ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION
OF ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU LIKE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION AB. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE KNOWN
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE THE NEW
VOTER FOR RUBIO YEAH OKAY.
ANOTHER HALF AN HOUR TO GET.
ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION RIGHT OF. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT FINANCE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND IMPACTS FURTHER
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT INCLUDES SECOND SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
FINANCIAL AID TO ASSIST
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENTS. ONE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION ESTIMATES LOCAL
ASSISTANT COSTS. THE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
FOR FOUR YEARS. ALL RIGHTS
SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
AGO TO SUSPENSE THERE'S A
COMMITTEE BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE ON SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
FORTY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S SOMEBODY HERE WILL GO
TO ROOM FOR TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT WHAT
OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS COMPANY TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE. WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP OUR AYE FINANCE. I
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
INCREASE ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES BY ESTABLISHING THE
SMALL BUSINESS RETENTION
PROGRAM- WE NOTE THAT THE
CURRENT PROGRAMS RECENTLY
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE OTHER
ELIGIBILITY TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM IN THIS BILL
MAY BE DUPLICATES. ALL RIGHT NO
QUESTIONS- AND SO WE WILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. BUILDING ON THE SEVEN
SEVEN NINE BIGELOW PEACE
OFFICERS DEPUTY SHERIFFS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP.
FORTY TWO OR THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY WILL GO
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NOBODY THERE. AND
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE AND
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. A PORTRAIT AB
SEVEN SEVEN NINE. WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP RIGHT WITHOUT
OPPOSITION IS NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
AND ONE NINE ZERO EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION AB SEVEN SEVEN NINE.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP.
ALL RIGHT FINANCE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL ESTIMATE CREATED
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE I
JUST. IF YOU'RE TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO US CITED IN
LAST YEAR STILL EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
SINGLE QUESTIONS ABOUT
OBJECTION SEVEN SEVEN NINE WILL
GO TO SUSPEND SEVEN NINETY FOUR
BY CARILLO ON AIR POLLUTION.
PURCHASE OF NEW SHORT HAUL
TRUCKS INSTEAD OF IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THERE'S NO ONE HERE WE'RE GOING
TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
NINETY FOUR. AND ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR. WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
TO OPPOSITION IS NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY FOR OPPOSITION ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
SEVEN NINE FOUR. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN
NINETY FOUR. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING UP ALL RIGHT FINANCED
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. YOUR
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES A
COST OF FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND ONGOING. THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ESTIMATES
COST OF FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SEVEN NINETY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN CAREER ON
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CHAIR FATALLY WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA'S SPONSOR OF THE
BILL STRONGLY SUPPORT I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF SOME OF OUR
SUPPORTERS AND- SPONSORS ALL OF
US OR NONE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND- MEN OF COLOR. ALLIANCE SAN
DIEGO AMERICAN FRIENDS SERVICE
COMMITTEE SAN DIEGO IF YOU AYE
WE ENTRY INCLUSION SUPPORT
EMPOWERMENT A. Y. P. L. BEND
THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
CALIFORNIA BLEND THIS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WOMEN
PRISONERS RESILIENCE OC.
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE UNITED
FOR A SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY
CENTER FOR EMPOWERING REFUGEES
AND IMMIGRANTS COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH
JUSTICE. COMMUNITY UNITED
AGAINST VIOLENCE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS
FREEDOM FOR IMMIGRANTS HOMIES
UNIDOS INK HUMAN RIGHTS ROCK
WATCH ICE ARE MARIN IMMIGRANT
LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
INDIVISIBLE VENTURA AND LAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE. SIXTY SEVENS WHEN YOUR
HOUSE AND ALSO A COUPLE OF
SPONSORED COMPANIES ARE IF
SUPPORTERS INDIVISIBLE
SAUSALITO S. U. R. J. MORAN CA
LULAC. CAN HEAL OUT COMMUNITIES
SYNAGOGUE VIET RAINBOW OF
ORANGE COUNTY CENTER FOR COMMON
GROUND NATIONAL AND
CALIFORNIA'S SOUTH BAY CHAPTER
SAN FRANCISCO PENINSULA AT THE-
PEOPLE POWER UNITARIANS.
PERSONALIST FELLOWSHIP. REDWOOD
CITY SOCIAL ACTION. SO VALLEY
THE BUG ORANGE COUNTY
ENGAGEMENT TABLE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTION PARTNERSHIP
YOU A. W. LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE CRITICAL OR ITS
RESISTANCE OAKLAND FIVE.
VENTURES ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT
IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES AND
CONSCIOUS CONTRA COSTA THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN PROCESS IN
ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER POWER BECAUSE SPONSORED
THE NINE THIRTY SEVEN ALSO
GIVING ME TO USE FOR THE
FOLLOWING CO SPONSORS.
INTERFAITH MOVEMENT FOR HUMAN
INTEGRITY LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN LONG
BEACH IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
COALITION LONG BEACH SOUTHEAST
ASIAN ANTI DEPORTATION
COLLECTIVE NATIONAL DAY LABORER
ORGANIZING NETWORK ORANGE
COUNTY EQUALITY COALITION
ORANGE COUNTY JUSTICE FUND.
ORANGE COUNTY RAPID RESPONSE
NETWORK RESTORE JUSTICE SAN
DIEGO IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CONSORTIUM SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE SECURE
JUSTICE SERVICES IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND EDUCATION NETWORK
SIREN SOUTH BAY PEOPLE POWER
THE BLACK ALLIANCE FOR JUST
IMMIGRATION BIJI. THE FORESTRY
AND FIRE RECRUITMENT PROGRAM
TRANSFORMATIVE IMPRISONED
WORKGROUP SERVER FOR SOLIDARITY
YEAH RISE YOUNG WOMAN'S FREEDOM
CENTER HE JUSTICE COALITION
WOMEN FOR AMERICA VALUES AND
ETHICS WAVE. IS ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING SUPPORTERS OF AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN EMPOWER PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES EPIC
TWENTY SECONDS A. P. I. QUALITY
ONLY OKAY PROGRESSES TECHNICIAN
IF THE WORST RECORD COMMUNITY
SERVICES WHY BECAUSE FOR BLACK
LIVES. SUCCESS STORIES PROGRAM
VENTURA COUNTY CLEAR GMAT
UNITED FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE
PEOPLE BUDGET ORANGE COUNTY
CONTRA COSTA LIVER CANCER
CENTER THE GOD THE REST UP IN
MINUTES THE SPEECH. INTERN
UNIVERSAL'S JUSTICE MINISTRY
CALIFORNIA EARLY ON THAT
SACRAMENTO WOMEN FOR ORANGE
COUNTY F. T. LOCAL TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE ALL RIGHT. LIVE OAK
THANK YOU MISTER. I RIGHT ELSE
GO TO FOUR. THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
EXCUSE ME- NINE THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB NINE
THREE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND NOW TO THE LINE
OF THREE THIRTY SEVEN. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE OF
THREE TWENTY SEVEN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
WILLIAM MUCH BURKE ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
TO NINETY SEVEN. MATALIN COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN PART THINK HE'LL.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. CONNECTION DISABILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
ONE SIXTY FOUR. HELLO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S MELISSA
CARLSON I SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA OPPOSITION OF
NINE THREE SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS COMING TWENTY
FORTIES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO NINE THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE THREE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
FINANCE. THANK YOU WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE BECAUSE
IT IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
BERMAN OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ESTIMATE COST OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND ON GOING TO COMPLY WITH THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS THERE MAY
BE SOME MINOR SAVINGS RESULTING
FROM REDUCED WORKLOAD THAT
COULD PARTIALLY OFFSET THESE
COSTS ALTHOUGH SPECIFIC AMOUNTS
ARE DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY.
BURKE JUST DISGUSTING THIS ONE
BACK TO THIRTY TWO THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AS  RESULT STILL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE
THIRTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
THE ROLE ON RUBIO I BELIEVE
IT'S FOUR NINE NINE. MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT WOULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINE NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR JONES. JONES ARE
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER A SEVEN VOTES
THE BILL IS OUT OF WITH SEVEN
VOTES THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO AB ONE TWELVE BYE
CARILLO BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP FOR THE COMMON
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE WAS A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
TWELVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR. AB
ELEVEN TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LATEST.
ANYONE THERE THEY GET OUT TO A
LINE OF THREE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO BEEN NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN YOU
CAN CALIFORNIA ABSTRACT
EXCELLENCE SPONSORED BY THE
SPELLING AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE ABOUT OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM NOBODY IN
TWENTY TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN TWELVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT ALREADY
REFLECTS A MULTI YEAR PLAN TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAMS. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDES AN INITIAL ESTIMATE OF
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
THIS BILL APPROPRIATE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND AND WE ASSUME
THAT ANY COSTS INCURRED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WOULD
BE SUPPORTED BY THE BILL'S
PROGRESSION. THANK YOU SEEN OUR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN TWELVE CLOSE TO SUSPENSE%
AB EIGHT FOURTEEN BY LEVINE
PERSONAL INFORMATION. THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATUS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL MOVE
TO TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS. ONE AND
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI H. FOURTEEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AN OUTLINE
OF THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU REMEMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ LED CORBIN IN KEIZER ON
BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION AND PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE IMPORT
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. I WITHOUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED A FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE NINE ZERO. ANTICLINE OF TWO
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO EIGHTY SIX ARE THEY
TOOK THEMSELVES AT ACU. BY
TWENTY SIX IF YOU LIKE TO QUEUE
UP PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ALL RIGHT MOVE ON. ALL RIGHT
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
GO TO OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN. NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
A FOURTEEN. ALL RIGHT ONE ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
FOURTEEN. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP OUR AYE FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT RESULTS IN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FISCAL
PLAN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF TWO HUNDRED
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING. ADDITIONALLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA NOTES
THE BILL CREATES UNKNOWN COST
PRESSURES TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU SEE RESEARCHERS ARE
PRECLUDED FROM USING THEIR- AND
SEEK TO CONTRACT WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. TO OBTAIN DATA ACCESS.
ALL RIGHT SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A FOURTEEN GO
TO SUSPENSE AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE BY LEVINE ON FOSTER
CHILDREN. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CAVITIES WAY PRESENTATION IS
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OF
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU ONE ZERO LIKE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE. AND A LINE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE TO
EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KIND OF CHECK WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE OF THREE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON INJURING THE
BALANCE ON THE OFFICE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND OUTLINED TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADELINE BROWN BEHALF
OF THE EUROPEAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT TWENTY NINE.
SOMEBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY TWENTY FORTIES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED A
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT FINANCE
WE ESTIMATE THE BILL RESULTS IN
COST PRESSURE OF SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THE DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER FOR
COUNTIES. ORIGINALLY ESTIMATE
ONE TIME AUTOMATION COST OF TWO
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO MAKE
NECESSARY AUTOMATION CHANGES TO
THE STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM. LASTLY TO THE EXTENT
THE BILL RESULT IN AN INCREASED
NEED FOR LOCAL SERVICES AT THIS
BILL THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
PRESSURES. ALL RIGHTS IN THE
QUESTIONS THAT OBJECTION EIGHT
TWENTY NINE GO TO SUSPENSE AB
NINE SIX FIVE LEVINE BUILDING
STANDARDS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO
OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
WELL THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
NOBODY THERE WILL GO TO THE
OPERATOR FOR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. NINE
SIX FIVE. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE SIXTY
FIVE. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AB
ONE MOMENT- IN. ONE NINE ZERO.
AN OUTLINE OF THREE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB MEMBERS
JUST MULLIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE U. S. GREEN BUILDING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
SIX FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE HIGHER OVER
OPPOSITION IN NINE SIX FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPPOSEDTO NINE SIX FIVE. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND. ZERO TO
EIGHTY NINE SIX FIVE. I LIVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES THIS BILL RESULTS IN
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM COST OF
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE IN THE BUILDING STANDARDS
ADMINISTRATION SPECIAL
REVOLVING FUND. APARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES MINOR
KIND OF STUMBLE COSTS. ALL
RIGHT NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION NINE SIX FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON AB EIGHT
THREE FIVE BY NECESSARY IN.
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
HIV TESTING IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE GOT HIS WAY
PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WE'RE
GOING TO TWENTY FORTY NOBODY
THERE. ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT THREE
FIVE. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION AT
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM KNOWN IN
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. THANK YOU A
ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
FINANCE. POSTED THE BILL
BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE ONGOING
GENERAL FUND IN H. DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FUND COST
PRESSURES DRIVEN BY A PROJECTED
INCREASE IN UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES. AND DOES THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE AN ONGOING COST
PRESSURES ON YOU SEE HEALTH
CENTRES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE IS
VERY NON BUILDING CODES THE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL GO TO SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN ALREADY
THERE IS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU ONE AND
ZERO. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY TWENTY ONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IN OPPOSED
IT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT FINANCE. THE COST
INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH NEW
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION AS A
RESULT OF THIS BILL ARE UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT AND
COULD BE IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. APARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST RANGING FROM SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND. AND ONGOING COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT ONE
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND SH TO
UPDATE MAINTAIN AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE ON STANDARDS REQUIRED
BY THE BILL. BERMAN OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ALSO
ESTIMATES ONGOING COST OF ONE
POINT ONE EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT AND
MAINTAIN THE NEW STANDARDS.
RIGHT SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON AB EIGHT THREE EIGHT
FRIEDMAN ON STATE HOUSING.
ENFORCEMENT IT'S A SUSPENSE CAN
EIGHT AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMANDEERED FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE IS OR
ANY SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE
FOR EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE
MOVED THE LINE OF TWO EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KIND OF CHECK
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION OF
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FORTIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
EIGHT THIRTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE IN AB FORTINO
ONE ON RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WHO TO SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC. COMMENTS HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE A LOT OF ROOM TWELVE
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATOR'S ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT AN
OUTLINE OF THREE TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VOLUME BUTTON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS CALIFORNIA YIMBY
AND- AND SPONSORS-THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION BACK-
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CIRCULATE
SAN DIEGO AND THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN THE PARK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB NEAL
REPRESENTING FEELS SOUTHERN
COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE. THREE
FORTY TWO. MICHELENA THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANET URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION A BILL
SPONSOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
OUTLINED. THREE FORTY SEVEN. HI
MISTER KERR MY NAME IS MIA KONG
I'M WITH THE COUNCIL OF INFILL
BUILDERS ONE OF THE BILL
REPORTER IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN OUTLINE THREE FORTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST MARRIAGES
BOOK ABOUT A LEADERSHIP GROUP
WHERE CROWDS- SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CAN AYE LARA
POSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY
NOW AND MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION- AB
FORTINO ONE AND NOW TO LINE TO
EIGHTEEN. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
HENRY AND ON BEHALF OF LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA. UNITED NEIGHBORS-
CATALYST AND SAVE LAFAYETTE I'M
STE WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
OF THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SARAH
MERRITT I GREW WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
TENNESSEE LAWCENTER AND A LINE
FOR COUNTY TRANSIT LA OPPOSE AB
FORTINO ONE UNLESS AMENDED TO
PREVENT LAND VALUES FROM
PRICING OUT NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE TO EIGHTY
SEVEN. I MEAN BOKAN CENTER PARK
SIDE NEIGHBORHOOD SAN FRANCISCO
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FORTINO
ONE. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE R.
I. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BERMAN OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES ANNUAL
COST OF NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM GENERAL FUND. ALL
RIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FORTINO ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
WE HAVE FORTY MORE BILLS LEFT
LET'S MOVE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLINS- AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
WHICH IS THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH REGIONAL CLIMATE
NETWORKS REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE
ACTION PLANS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDID MISTER MULLIN HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. SO WHETHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
SEEING THEM I LOOK IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC ARE THERE TO TEST
FIND SUPPORT THERE ARE NONE SO
MODERATE- CAN YOU PLEASE PROMPT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT NINE SEVEN AND CALL THEM
FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU LIKE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN. AND TO THE
LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
JONATHAN CLAY IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO
AND CITY IN THE INTIMATE US.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. REGARDLESS COULD
OPPOSITION OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING FROM FORTY
TO THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY I
SEEN NINE THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT NINETY SEVEN I SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WAS
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR- PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB. EIGHT NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU LIKE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION IN AB EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
HERE WE GO TO LINE OF THREE
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON ASHLEY OVER HELP ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS THE RIVER
AGAIN WE SUPPORT IF AMENDED AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN WE'RE
CONCERNEDAGAIN WITH THE
INTERCONNECTION OF RELATED
BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. YOU HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
MISS ON A TERRACE AT THE
FINANCED YOU HAVE A- POSITION
ON THIS BILL. I KNOW POSITION
MR CHER BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
OFFICE PLANNING. IT'S GENERAL
FUND COST OF ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND ONGOING COSTS
THEREAFTER OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM. WE REGIONALLY
NOTED THAT THE BILL CREATES
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES TO SUPPORT REGIONAL.
NETWORKS AND TO FUND THE
CREATION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
REGIONAL CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PLANS. THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
IS WITH THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO IS AB
NINE NINE ZERO WHICH DEALS WITH
PRESENTS AN INMATE- VISITATION
IS THIS SUSPENSE CALENDARS HIS
WAVE PRESENTATION SO MOVED TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO THREE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE NINE ZERO
AND I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
DETAILS FIND SUPPORT SO LET'S
GO TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR WE PLEASE QUEUE THE
FIRST. MEMBER SURE AGAIN ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE EXPECT
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI. NINE NINE ZERO. THEN ONE
THEN ZERO AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND NOW TO LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD MA'AM. HI MY
NAMES ALYSSA CARLSON THURMOND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB NINE
NINETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE OF TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ERICA EVERYDAY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY CLUB FONG THE CARD
THREE PERSON AND IF YO THINK.
EIGHTY NINE NINETY WE HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED. LET'S TALK FOR
INCORPORATE PEOPLE AS WELL AS
LOWER. RATES AGAIN I STRONG
SUPPORT WELL EIGHTY NINE NINETY
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE CAN Q. PLEASE CARDS
LET'S SEE IF THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN OPPOSITION WERE
WERE. IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TEST OF OR WILLING TO
TESTIFY WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THE BABY NINE NINE
ZERO NAY C. NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ROOM TWENTY FOUR HE WAS
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR. LET'S MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES. WHEN TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE
ZERO. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AB NINE NINE ZERO.
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE
GO TO THE LINE OF TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TWO
HUNDRED SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS MATT USUALLY
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AS WRITTEN BUT
CURRENTLY IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
I WAS CHECK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ARE ON THE SAME LINE
MISS ON ON THEIR OWN TO HAVE A
FILE. MISTER CHAIR YES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS. NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL COULD JEOPARDIZE THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF THE
PRISONS BY LIMITING THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ABILITY. TO
RESTRICT EDITING SIGNIFICANTLY
CURTAILING PRISON OFFICIALS
DISCRETION AND OPERATING THE
FACILITIES. NOTE THAT THIS BILL
MAY IMPOSE A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE AS DETERMINED BY THE
COMMISSION ON STATE MANDATES.
REQUIRING IN PERSON VISITATION.
AND LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ANTICIPATES THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
LITIGATION COSTS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. NINE NINE ZERO IS MOVED TO
SUSPEND SPIRAL. NEXT U IS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY ALSO BY
SIN REMEMBER SANTIAGO WHICH IS
DISPENSED CALENDARS HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION. I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN I LOOK IN
ROOM TWENTY FOURTEEN C. NO
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING
THERE SO. OUR MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC- WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE MAN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR A BI. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND WE GO TO
LINE OF THREE FORTY FIVE.
REGARDING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE R. WILL
FOREGO THE OPPOSITION ON THIS-
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BANKING OPTION ACT I SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE NOW
DO I SEE MEMBERS REPUBLICANS.
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU
LIKE EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO AB.
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. VERY GOOD
MISS ON A THEREOF WITH THE PART
OF FINANCED YOU HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL THAT WOULD NOTE THAT THE
BILL RESULT. RESULT IN UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME AND ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COSTS AT MINIMUM IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO COMPLETE
MARKET ANALYSIS AND TO
IMPLEMENT. AND SUSTAIN THE
PROGRAM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION INNOVATION
ESTIMATES THE TOTAL ONE TIME
COST TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL WHICH
INVOLVES THE COMPLETION OF THE
ANALYSIS AND STARTED WITH THE
PROGRAM- TO BE A ONE HUNDRED
POINT. ONE HUNDRED NINE POINT
EIGHT. FINE YES. ADDITIONAL IT
ESTIMATES THE TOTAL ONGOING
COST FOR THE STATE TO RUN THE
PROGRAM REQUIRED BY THIS BILL
AT THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. BERMAN ALSO
ESTIMATES UNOBSERVABLE COSTS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AND I'M GOING. AT THE TIME OF
OUR ANALYSIS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. ESTIMATED
THAT IT WOULD NOT HAVE A FISCAL
IMPACT TO THEIR TO.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE HAD YET NOT
YET PROVIDED SPECIFIC COST FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL. UP TO PROVIDE AN ESTIMATE
OF THE COST TO STAFF THE BOARD
IN THE RANGE OF TWO TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS CANNOT
ESTIMATE THE COST INVESTMENT
THE BILL THIS TIME BUT KNOWS
THE POTENTIAL FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES OF AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT.
OF THE BILL EXPANDS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ENFORCEMENT
STRESSED. THANK YOU VERY WELL
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN TO SUSPENSE
CALENDAR- THE NEXT STEP IS AB
NINE NINE EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY WRITTEN REGARDING
CARS RATED PERSONS AND THEIR
HEALTH RECORDS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CALENDAR AND HE IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY IS WAY
PRESENTATION I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE NINE EIGHT ORDERS HE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SO LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND
MODERATE WE PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE NINE EIGHT AND CALL
THEM FORWARD. THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE NINE ZERO THREE LIKE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
NINE EIGHT. AND TO THE LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE EXISTING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES AS THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND FROM THE PORT.
THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE
TO OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT NINE
NINE EIGHT I SEE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE AT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO WAS TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE
EIGHT SO MODERATOR LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE OF HIS
EMPLOYEES PROP INDIVIDUALS
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE NINE
EIGHT. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO P. LIKE EXPRESS OPPOSITION
AB NINE NINE EIGHT. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S
CHECK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE ON THE ZOOM LINE MISS
UNDER THERE AND YOU HAVE FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND A DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ESTIMATED TO COST RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL WOULD BE MINOR
AND SEVERAL. ADDITIONALLY CCR
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AT THE BILL MAY
ACTUALLY RESULT IN MINOR COST
SAVINGS TO BOTH ENTITIES. WOULD
KNOW THAT THIS BILL COULD
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BY REQUIRING A NEW
PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES. FINE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINE NINE EIGHT IS
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE COUNTER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. EDUARDO GARCIA
HAS AB TEN THIRTY SIX WHICH
DEALS WITH CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS ACT. OR IS
ENTITLED CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING EMERGENCY
FAIRNESS ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT IS A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSION HE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SO GOING TO THE
PUBLIC HEARING I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE NORDIC ST
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC. WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. AB TEN
THIRTY SIX IN ROOM. TWENTY
FORTY SO. MODERATE REALIST
MOVED TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING FOR SOME
PLEASE PROP THEM INDIVIDUALLY.
THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A
BI TEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. N. ONE THEN.
ZERO AN OUTLINE OF TWO EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY SO SHE
CAN WORK PROUD SUPPORT AND
SPONSOR AT TEN THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE YOU PLEASE CONTINUE I WAS
KERN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
THIRTY SIX NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WHICH THE
TESTIFIES HOPE MODERATOR LET'S.
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE REVERSE IN Q.
THEM. INDIVIDUALLY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IN AB TEN
THIRTY SECS. AND WE HAVE
KNOWING Q. PLEASE CONTINUE
FORGET THE DEPARTMENT FINEST
MISS UNDER THERE AND YOU HAVE A
FILE. SHARE WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUSION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT. IN ADDITION
ESTABLISHING CONTINUES THEY
APPROPRIATED FUND WHEN THE
STATE MINISTRATIONS ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY PERFORM OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO
STATE STAFFING AND SPENDING.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND COST OF TWO POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS A TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL. AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT A
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS
WILL LIKELY NEED TO COME FROM
THE GENERAL. BECAUSE FEES WILL
NOT BE COLLECTED UNTIL AFTER
THE PROGRAMS ARE OPERATIONAL.
VERY WELL WITHOUT OBJECTION AB-
TEN THIRTY SIX THIS MONTH TO
SUSPENSE COUNTER- AB TEN SIXTY
SIX BY SEVEN MEMBER BLOOM IS
ALSO CANDID FOR SUSPENSE THIS
IS THE PRIORITY INLAND WATER
CONTACT RECREATION SITES WATER
QUALITY MONITORING MEASURE-
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
FORTY TWO OH THREE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN
SIXTY SIX NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN SIXTY SIX SO
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WE NEED
TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE REVERSE IN
PLEASE- PROMPT THEM.
INDIVIDUALLY THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB. ONE
ZERO SIX SIX. AND WE DO GO TO
LINE OF THREE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WROTE IN
MESSAGE- JUST ALONG HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND STRONG SUPPORT. OF
AB TEN SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT LET'S LOOK TURN
TO OPPOSITION NOW I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO- THREE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
SIXTY SIX IN ORDER TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY.
FORTY WHICH TESTIFIES TO
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO TESTIFY
VR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IN AB AND
SIXTY SIX. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT LET'S
CHECK WITH FINANCE MISS ONODERA
DO YOU HAVE A FILE. THANK YOU
MISTER SHARE THE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATES COST OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE WASTE
DISCHARGE PERMIT FUND FOR TWO
YEARS. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF. COST OF ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. FINALLY
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DEVELOPED
PURSUANT TO THIS BILL. COULD
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT FUTURE
COSTS AND COST PRESSURES TO THE
STATE. AND OR LOCAL AGENCIES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN SIXTY
SIX OF DISPENSED- AB ELEVEN
TWENTY SIX. ESTABLISHES THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF HATE
IS SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM HAS WAIVED- PRESENTATION
THIS IS A SUSPENSE COUNTER. I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
NOR DO YOU SEE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
LIKE TO TESTIFY SO- MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAY IN THE TESTIFIED
VIA. OUR TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. ONE
NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO GO TO LINE OF TWO EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KINDA CHECK FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN CONCORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHT
PULLED TURNED TO OPPOSITION I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
OF WHO MAY WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX NORTH TWO IC. ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- IN OPPOSITION SO
MODERATE LET'S TURN TO.
WITNESSES WAITING ON V. R.
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE WHO MAY
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IN AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT
LET'S CHECK IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
SAME LINE MISS ON A DEREK YOU
HAVE A FILE. ON THE MISTER
CHAIR YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT. NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. ADDITIONALLY THE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
COMMISSION THE RESULT IN
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES. I
WOULD NOTE THAT A SIMILAR SIZE
AND SCOPE OF THE NEW COMMISSION
IS SIMILAR TO OTHER CONDITIONS.
THE BILL COULD RESULT IN ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND COST OF ROUGHLY
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
IS MOVED TO OUR- SUSPENSE FILE.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED
MERRY MEDICINE AND BLOOD BANKS
FOR ANIMALS. IS ALSO AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM IN THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR. ARE CANDID
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN.
ROOM FORTY TWO- THROUGH WHICH
TESTIFIED. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO NOR DO I SEE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY WHO MAY WISH TO
TESTIFY SO. LET'S MOVE TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MIGHT
BE WAITING SAYS FIVE YEAR OUR-
TELECONFERENCE. SERVICE
MODERATOR FREE PLEASE PROMPT
THEM INDIVIDUALLY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND NOW
TO LINE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SACKETT THEM OF HIS
ANY PEOPLE FOR THE ETHICAL
TREATMENT OF ANIMALS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO ON BEHALF
OF THE BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL
SOCIETY SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
SPCA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
OUTLINE OF. THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
HI THIS IS JUDY MAN CREW SO
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION-
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY GROUP
ARE THOUSANDS OF SUPPORTERS AND
LOTS OF THAT MARION THEN THE
ANIMAL RIGHTS AND WELFARE
GROWTH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. NEXT THANK YOU AND NOW
TO LINE. ONE THIRTY NINE. IT
JUST CAN'T BE FROM AN EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IN THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT IT AMENDED CONDITION ON
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.PART
WITH ALL THE SAME I'M PROCESS
FOR OPPOSITION I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO THROUGH MIGHT WISH TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO NOR DO I SEE
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY YOU MAY TESTIFY
SO. LET'S MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES
NGUYEN TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WILL PROMPT
INDIVIDUALLY. THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWELVE EIGHTY
TWO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE CUEING
UP THE ZEN OR TERROR WITH
PARTNER FINANCING HAVE A FILE
ON THE- AB. TWELVE EIGHTY TWO.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE. AS
A BILL RESULTS IN SHORT TERM
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND
POTENTIAL ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES. TO THE EXTENT
FEES DO NOT GENERATE SUFFICIENT
REVENUE TO COVER ASSOCIATED
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES.
FURTHER WE HAVE ALREADY IN THIS
BILL DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE TO RECOVER
INITIAL GENERAL FUND COSTS
INCURRED. WHICH WILL BE
REQUIRED FOR THE FIRST YEAR
SUPPLEMENTATION. FINALLY THE
TIME LINES IN THIS BILL.
WORKABLE AND WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO REDIRECT EXISTING
RESOURCES IN THE CURRENT YEAR
IN AN EFFORT TO MEET THE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE DEADLINE FOR BEST
PRACTICE DOCUMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO IS MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE- SIX ANIMUS.
AB TWELVE OH FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEEKS WHICH IS
HOSPITAL EQUITY REPORTING IT IS
SUSPENSE COUNTY AUTHORS WE
PRESENTATION. SO MOVED TO
SUPPORT I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE WHO MIGHT WANT TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWELVE OH
FOUR NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO WISHING TO TESTIFY SO LET'S
MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
WHEN THE TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU MAY. PROMPT
THEM INDIVIDUALLY DESIST
SUPPORT. FOR A BI TWELVE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI TWELVE
OLD FOR. WE HAVE NO IN QUEUING
UP. OUR THE SIMS COMPOSITION AS
THE NUMBERS THE PUBLIC HEARING
OF TWENTY FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB TWELVE OH
FOUR NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO MIGHT WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AB TWELVE OH FOUR
SO MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO ARE
ON OUR TELECONFERENCE OVER
SWITCHING TO OPPOSE AB TWELVE
OH FOUR. THANK YOU ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU LIKE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE ALL.
FOR AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING
UP RIGHT MISS SOME OF THEIR
UPON BUT TO PART FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE A POSITION OR- A FIRE. IT
IS ISSUE MISTER CHAIR BUT WOULD
NOTE THAT THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. ESTIMATES COSTS
TOTALING ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
AND APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING. I WOULD KNOW
THAT THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE
OFFICE TO ISSUE FINES HOWEVER
THE FUNDING RAISED THROUGH THIS
MECHANISM IS NOT LIKELY TO
SUBSTANTIALLY OFFSET THE COST
OF THE BILL. WELL WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE OH FOUR IS
MOVED TO SUSPENSE CONDER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER WEBER
SAID- HAS THE NEXT ITEM UP IN
AB. TWELVE AU SEVEN PATHWAYS
THROUGH PENN. PANDEMIC TASK
FORCE WHICH IS A SUSPENSE
COUNTER AND SHE'S WAVE.
PRESENTATION I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO- THROUGH THE- THREE
WHO MAY WISH TO TESTIFY. NOR DO
I SEE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. WHO ARE
THERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE OH SEVEN SO MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WE NEED TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR AB. ONE TWO OH SEVEN. THEY
HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP PART WAS
CORRUPT MEMBER. LET'S MOVE TO
THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWELVE A SEVEN NOR DO I SEE
WITNESSES IN A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY CAN MAKE WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE OH
SEVEN SO MODERATOR LET'S MOVE
TO THE THOSE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY V. R. TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IF YOU'D PLEASE. PROMPT
THEM INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE OR
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE QUEUING UP VERY GOOD
LET'S CHECK IN WITH FINANCED
PRESS ON A TERROR DO YOU HAVE A
FILE AND AB. TWELVE OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL APPEARED TO PUT
COULD HAVE OF EFFORTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY. WE KNOW
THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACTING STRANGELY IN
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. PERFORMER
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO THE
COMMON NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND A
PROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS UP OVERALL
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE OH
SEVEN. IS MOVED TO SPEND FILE
SO. LET'S MOVE TO PAGE SEVEN OF
OUR SEVEN PAGE AGENDA WHICH IS
OF THE- LAST FOUR BILLS ON IT
THIS IS. AB TWELVE. SIXTY BY A
SEVEN MEMBER CHEN IS. AS ALSO
SUSPENSE CALENDAR- MISTER
CHAIRMAN. HE IS WAIT FOR OUR
PRESENTATION- I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTEEN OR
DO I SEE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM A TWENTY FOURTEEN IN
SUPPORT OF A B. TWELVE SIXTIES
A MODERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE PUBLIC- WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTY
V. R. R. TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE AND ZERO
COULD LIKE EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR AB. TWELVE SIXTY. AND WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD LET'S MOVE
OPPOSITION I SEE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWELVE
SIXTY. AND I SEE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO MAY WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF.
TWELVE SIXTY WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT EXEMPTION
TRANSPORTATION RELATED PROJECT
MANAGERS SO MODERATOR PLEASE
PROP MEMBERS- WAITING ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE RESUMING WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION IF AB
TWELVE SIXTY. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO EFFECT
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO AB.
TWELVE SIXTY. WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. VERY GOOD LOOKS A
TURN TO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
MASSANA TERRA TO HAVE A
POSITION AS A FINANCIAL
POSITION ON AB TWELVE SIXTY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND NO
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE AT
THIS TIME- BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
AND THE DEPARTMENT EFFICIENT
WILDLIFE. ALL ESTIMATE NO COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
SO BE IT WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWELVE SIXTY IS THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR. A SUMMER IRWIN HAS
THE NEXT ITEM UP A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT I WHICH IS THE
SUSPENSE COUNTER DID THIS DEALS
WITH CLINICAL LABORATORY
TECHNOLOGY. AND PHARMACISTS THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION- I SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT NOR
DO I SEE WHAT. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE WILLING TO TESTIFY
HER EAGER TO TESTIFY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SO. OUR MODERATOR
PLEASE WOULD YOU PROP MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC FEAR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE YOUR
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
CALL THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY.
THERE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE TO IN UP OUR THIRTY
LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE- WHOSE. MIGHT WANT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT NOW DO I
SEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY YOU MAY
WISH TO TESTIFY IN. OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TO
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES. I WERE WAITING TO
TEST FIVE YARD OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN.
AGAINST IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AND CALL
THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY-
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. AND WE MOVED THE LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ENSURE
RIGHT SPENCER BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE. WEBER RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN POINT TWENTY
EIGHT UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND WE MOVED TO LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EMILY HUGHES
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AREN'T
HAVING HER SMALLER WITNESSES
MISSED ON A TERROR WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO HAVE A
FILE ON THIS. MEASURE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YES FOR NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE. ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE NEXT SIGN UP IS AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE ALSO BY
SOME REMEMBER IRWIN- THE-
MENTAL HEALTH STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR OF. CRISES SERVICES
ACT IT'S A SUSPENSE CALENDAR
SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE ROOM
FORTY TWO THREE WHO MIGHT WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN. ROOM TWENTY FOUR
FORTY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE SO
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WAITING TO
TESTIFY B. R. TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE IF YOU Q. THEM
INDIVIDUALLY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
APPEARANCESUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE ELIGIBLE TO
LINE OF THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANNY OFFER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NON THE
CALIFORNIA OR ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ALONG WITH
THAT THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
ASSOCIATION WHO WAS NOT ABLE TO
ATTEND TODAY- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT LET'S CUT OPPOSITION I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE NOR DO I SEE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY CAN MY POINT WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONCE A
MODERATOR IF WE MAY MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY B.
R. TELECONFERENCE OR RECEIPT TO
THEM INDIVIDUALLY WHO MIGHT. UP
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE. WE HAVE NO WARNING
Q. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA CHECK IN
WITH PARTNER FINANCE MISS ON A
DIRT ROAD YOU HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MEASURE. YES MR SURE THANK
YOU THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ON GOING. TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE STILL SKEWS
ME. RAMOS ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE IS MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILE
IN THE HOUR HAS ARRIVED EIGHT
THIS IS OUR LAST BILL ON TODAY
IT'S AB THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY SEVENTY MEMBER
FRAZIER WHICH IS ALSO SUSPENDS
COUNTERED ADDRESSES FORESTRY
CARBON FORCE CARBON AND
RESILIENCY GOALS THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE MIGHT
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE NOR DO I
SEE MEMBERS REPUBLICAN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY SAYS FAISAL.
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WIENER
TEST VR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP ALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I SEE NUMBERS THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE NOR DO I SEE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHICH TESTIFIES TO
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO PROP
MEMBERS OF THE- PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. PLEASE
CALL THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY.
SURE THANK YOU AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION THE AB. FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP OUR MESSENGER THERE
THIS LAST BILL. FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE THIS IS PART OF FINANCE
HAVE POSITION. I KNOW POSITION
MISTER CHAIR BUT WOULD NOTE
THAT AT THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL ONGOING COSTS TO
COLLECT INFORMATION AND PROVIDE
ANNUAL REPORTING AS REQUIRED BY
THE BILL. WOULD KNOW THAT THE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
PACKAGE- THAT IS STILL TO BE
FINALIZED AS PROPOSED PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOALS OF THE
BILL- BUT THESE INVESTMENTS
WOULD BE ONE TIME IN NATURE SO
THAT THE BILL- MAY CREATE
ONGOING COST PRESSURES TO THE
GENERAL FUND AFTER THOSE FUNDS
ARE EXHAUSTED. ALAS THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
ESTIMATES COST OF ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND ONE HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
THEREAFTER. I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DOOR IS NOT. SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDED IN THE BILL AND WE
KNOW THAT THOSE COSTS AND
MAKING MINOR AND SOLVABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
INTERNALLY WE'RE OF THOSE FINAL
PREPARATIONS ON OUR WILDFIRE-
PACKAGE THAT ARE BEING WORKED
OUT- WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE FILE. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS. OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMONSENSE EJECTS SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US. WHAT'S.
INCLUDED TESTIMONY IN THE
FISHEL. HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU WE'RE- YOUR PURCHASE. THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR GENDER THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CENTER.